Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Wie reich bist du eigentlich?
Ich habe nur gutes Geld.
Also bist du superreich. Gutes Geld. Also der Titel des Buches, den finde ich sehr gut.
Ich will das auch gleich auflösen, was ich damit meine, weil ich gestern in der Bild-Zeitung einen Artikel las über den, wie heißt der, Anzeigenhauptmeister oder so etwas. Es gibt ja diesen jungen Mann, der alle möglichen Leute aufschreibt, die mit dem Auto falsch geparkt haben und der so ein Social-Media-Phänomen geworden ist, deshalb auch Kooperationen hat irgendwo eingeladen wird. Und der sagte dann in diesem Interview, dass er inzwischen Millionär sei, er lebe aber auch ganz sparsam. Er gönne sich nichts und habe schon immer so gelebt, drehe jeden Cent dreimal um und hat jetzt ganz viel Geld gesammelt, denn Geld sei das Wichtigste in seinem Leben. Und genau das ist nicht gutes Geld, denn gutes Geld bedeutet für mich, dass ich mit dem Geld mir etwas ermöglichen kann. Zum Beispiel den Opernbesuch oder das Abendessen mit Freunden. Das ist gutes Geld. Was er macht, ist die Akkumulation von Geld als Summe. Und das ist schlechtes Geld. Das ist eigentlich diese Idee von Christian Lindner. Wir haben hier so und so viel Geld noch da. Prima. Wenn wir vieles gespart haben, dann wird das schon gutes Geld sein. Nein, das ist schlechtes Geld, weil es nicht in den Kreislauf geht. Es wird nicht damit etwas Gutes realisiert. Es wird nichts investiert. Und insofern stehe ich auf der Seite des guten Geldes. Wenn Geld da ist, dann gebe ich es für meines Erachtens sinnvolle Dinge aus.
Ja, gutes Geld, das im Kreislauf ist. Wie wird man denn Millionär als Anzeigenhauptmeister alle? Einfach durch Einladung?
Naja, der bekommt ja dann irgendwelche Werbeverträge und was weiß ich. Das ging ja relativ schnell.
Ich habe ihn eigentlich nie wieder so irgendwo gesehen, außer halt in dieser Berichterstattung darüber, dass er jetzt hier verprügelt wurde und da irgendwie was macht.
Der macht dann so Touren durch Diskotheken und was weiß ich. Na ja, gut.
Okay, da gratulieren wir natürlich, denn Millionär sein ist ja gut in dieser Gesellschaft. Also um millionären Euro gerechnet, da wo die Uhren so ticken, wie sie ticken.
Ja, hilft weiter. Aber wir beginnen ja bei diesem Buch, das den Untertitel trägt, Wege zu einer gerechten und nachhaltigen Gesellschaft. Nicht in Deutschland unsere Reise. Philippa Sigl-Glöckner ist erst einmal in Liberia und führt uns auch dorthin. Und wird dort gefragt, wie viel Geld denn eigentlich Liberia ausgeben kann.
Also lassen wir uns kurz vororten. Ich kannte sie so ein bisschen über Twitter, weil sie da so virulent ist, sage ich mal. Sie galt dann irgendwie als Teil des Finanzministeriums, dort aber so ein bisschen neben der Spur, keine Ahnung.
Also neben der Spur im Sinne von nicht orthodox.
Ja, genau. Und es ist ja schon interessant, wenn man so Leute als Medienphänomen so ein bisschen mitbekommt, aber sich nicht so richtig Gedanken darüber macht, wo sie ihn so zu verorten, weil man folgt da 1000 Leuten und 500 davon machen interessante Sachen, nur man denkt jetzt nicht über jeden Einzelnen nach. Und jetzt wissen wir allerdings Dezernatz Zukunft. Also da lasse ich mir auch mal die Mails schicken, was da so gedacht wird. Und dann kam das Buch.
Da ist die Geschäftsführung dieses Dezernats Zukunft. Und sie war dann im deutschen Finanzministerium und zuvor im liberianischen Finanzministerium.
Genau. Und kam aber auch dahin über die Weltbank. Und dann erfahren wir im Buch, sie hat aber noch in irgendwo, hat sie Philosophie studiert, dann hat ihr das nicht gereicht. Und dann hat sie ihrem Bruder in England, weil sie gleichzeitig mit ihm dort gelebt hat, versucht Ökonomie zu erklären, wie sie es im Studium gelernt hat. Also lauter solche Sachen. Bei manchen Biografien fragt man sich manchmal so ein bisschen, was hat es damit auf sich? In der Ansicht ist dieser Einstieg ins Buch schon ganz illustre. Ich kam aus der Weltbank und kam nach Liberia, aber habe dort im Finanzministerium gearbeitet, allerdings angefragt über eine NGO, whatever. Und dann steht aber der Finanzminister vor ihr und stellt ihr die Frage, die du schon angeschnitten hast.
Genau. Und der fragt sie, wie sehr sich Liberia verschulden kann, die Straßen sind kaputt, es ist so viel zu tun. Und er fragt, wie viel Schulden darf ich dieses Jahr aufnehmen? Dieser Minister, Amara Kunne, Anfang 20, ist gekleidet wie ein westlicher Banker, schreibt sie. Und er ist auch kein Fan von Metadiskussionen. Er wollte jetzt mal eine konkrete Antwort wissen. Und dann sagt sie, zu Hause kramte ich in meinen Uni-Notizen und sah mir das europäische Regelwerk zu Staatsschulden an. Die Sache schien einfacher als gedacht. Eine Schuldenquote, also das Verhältnis der Staatsschulden zum Bruttoinlandsprodukt, dem BEP, von 60 Prozent, galt in Europa als nachhaltig. Alles darüber als zu hoch. Liberias Schuldenquote lag bei lediglich 20 Prozent des BEPs, da es nach dem Bürgerkrieg einen Schuldenerlass bekommen hatte. Rechnete man ein bisschen herum, war klar, dass Liberias Schulden trotzdem schnell bei 60 Prozent landen könnten. Ich präsentierte dem Finanzminister meine Analyse und argumentierte, dass die Regierung mit der Kreditaufnahme vorsichtig sein sollte. Der Schuldenerlass sei schließlich noch nicht lange her gewesen. Ob mir bewusst sei, in welchem Zustand sich das Land befinde, fragte der Minister. Es gebe zur Regenzeit kaum befahrbare Straßen, kein sauberes Wasser, nicht mal in der Hauptstadt Monrovia. Natürlich müsse er mit dem Geld verantwortungsvoll umgehen. Er brauche aber eine gute Begründung, wenn er seinen Landsleuten grundlegende Infrastruktur vorenthalte. Ich soll mir noch einmal genauer ansehen, wie man in Europa die maximal zulässige Schuldenquote von 60 Prozent begründete und ob das auch wirklich die richtige Messlatte für Liberia sei.
Ja, genau. Gutes Geld. Und dann kommt sie gleich am Anfang mit diesem, ich muss meinen Landsleuten erklären, warum ich ihnen Infrastruktur vorenthalte. Denn man steckt ja in einem weltweiten Geld- und Kreditsystem drin und an Schulden machen, also was hindert einen Schulden zu machen, ist ja so seine Frage. Und dann kommt sie relativ zügig auf unseren Finanzminister, also dieser Zeit damals zu sprechen, 2015, Schäuble. Das Land diskutiert Flüchtlingswellen und Schäuble sagt, ein guter Zeitpunkt, jetzt diese Zahlen, die sie gerade hinterfragt, mal richtig einzuhalten. Und die Frage ist, warum eigentlich? Und Schäuble so, das ist mir egal, warum eigentlich? Wir haben diese Richtwerte und legen jetzt verfassungskonforme Haushalte vor. Die Schuldensbremse stand ja schon eine Weile drin. Was für uns jetzt bedeutet als Leser und für sie, manchmal stehen so Zahlen im Raum. Das 1,5 Grad Ziel, das 2% Ziel, die 3% Verschuldungsquote, die so eintradiert sind, die sich so im Gedächtnis verankert haben, dass wir die Geschichtsschreibung darüber hinaus vergessen haben. Und wenn wir uns die anschauen wollen, gibt es eigentlich gar keine. Also es ist, wir haben es mit einer Haltlosigkeit in den ernstesten Fragen zu tun.
Und sie legt eigentlich dann dieses Buch wie ein Krimi an. Sie fragt nämlich, who done it? Sie möchte wissen, woher kommen diese ominösen 60 Prozent Schuldenquote? Denn je tiefer man einsteigt, desto verwirrender wird es. Und man bekommt nicht Klarheit darüber, warum das ausgerechnet 60 Prozent sind. Und als kleiner Spoiler schon mal, in Liberia gelten natürlich ganz andere Regeln oder müssen andere Regeln gelten, weil Liberia nicht eine so stabile Volkswirtschaft ist wie die Deutsche. Da ist die Frage, wie hoch man sich verschulden kann. Wirklich noch einmal ganz anders zu beantworten. Aber sie fragt sich jetzt, wie kann das eigentlich sein, wenn in Liberia der Finanzminister sagt, ich muss meinen Landsleuten doch erklären können, warum man ihnen Infrastruktur vorenthält. Wie kann es denn sein, dass in einem so reichen Land wie Deutschland und dann auch in den reichen europäischen, denn dann generell man den Menschen Notwendiges vorenthält, nur weil man einer Schuldenregel gerecht werden will. Und woher kommt diese Schuldenregel? Wer hat sie eigentlich in Stand gesetzt? Und wer glaubt plötzlich, wem damit zu dienen? Denn das ist ja auch die große Frage, die man sich im Krimi stellt. Hatte der Täter ein Motiv? Und dann ist das oft sehr einfach. Wollte jemand ans Erbe ran oder gibt es eine Eifersucht? Solche Geschichten. Und hier merken wir, so ein klares Motiv kann man vielleicht nicht ausmachen. Aber was man wohl im Allgemeinen sagen kann, es ist sehr viel egozentrig dabei. Sehr viele machtgetriebene Politiker. Und es ist schon der deutsche Wunsch, danach sagen zu können, den anderen, wo es lang geht. Und das kriegt man über eine Austeritätspolitik ziemlich gut hin. Ob das sinnvoll ist oder nicht, sondern alleine, dass man es kann, dass man die Macht besitzt, scheint eine Triebfeder zu sein.
Genau. Aber da verzieht er ihr Buch, die Wendungen nach, die es in der geschriebenen Geschichte gab. Das ist ja dann ganz interessant. Bleiben wir noch beim archämedischen Punkt. Du hast jetzt gesagt, Schulden regeln. Sie interessiert sich für Zweierleihe. Es gibt die deutsche Schuldenbremse und die europäischen Schuldenquote. Also ein Land darf sich nicht mehr als 60 Prozent von seinem BIP verschulden und pro Jahr nicht mehr als drei Prozent oder sowas. Und 2024 ist nun ein sehr guter Zeitpunkt, sagt sie, um dieses Buch zu schreiben. Denn die Protokolle der Verhandlung des Maastricht-Vertrags, also Einführung der Einheitswährung Euro und damit auch dieser Schuldenregeln, steht jetzt zur Verfügung. Also man kann sie, ich weiß nicht genau, ob es jetzt öffentlich ist, aber man kann sie nachvollziehen. Sie hat sie gelesen. Er geht dem nach. Und sie fragt sich, insbesondere in Deutschland, was hat es mit dieser 0,35-prozentigen Investitionsquote, die das Grundgesetz über die Schuldenbremse da erlaubt? Was hat es damit auf sich? Woher kommen alle diese Werte? Fragt sie. Ökonomisch lassen sie sich nicht begründen. Also braucht man einen Zugang zur Geschichte, um nachzuvollziehen, wer da was gemacht hat.
Du sagst das jetzt gerade so, Lapita, das muss man sich mal vor Augen führen. Man kann sie ökonomisch nicht begründen. Und das wird sehr deutlich immer wieder in diesem Buch, dass es nicht ökonomisch begründbare Ringe gibt.
Und Schäuble war ja auch kein Ökonom.
Das sind auch keine A-B-Tests. Man hat nicht irgendwas ausprobiert und gesagt, ah ja, ab da wird es schlecht. So wie man selbst gucken kann, wenn ich 10 Kilo mehr wiege, dann fühle ich mich nicht so gut. Also 10 Kilo weniger wären besser, so etwas. Sondern man setzt diese Regeln. Und wir haben ja eine Technokratie, die sich immer stärker ausgebreitet hat. Und da regieren mathematische Formeln statt politischer Kampf. Und was sie jetzt eigentlich macht, ist zu sagen, diese mathematischen Formeln sind ja aus einem politischen Kampf heraus entstanden. Und die sind eben keine mathematischen Formeln, weil die Mathematik ja in ihrer Reinheit eine bloße Sachlichkeit dann darstellt. Während wir es hier mit ganz viel im Hintergrund zu tun haben, in dem man sich jetzt im Nachhinein nur wundern kann.
Genau. Das macht sie wirklich hervorragend, weil es hier auf jedes Wort ankommt. Diese Geschichte, nach der sie sucht, ist die einer gefährlichen Idee, Zitat. Gefährliche Idee. Mit der Pointe, die nie einer hatte, aber das klären wir gleich auf. Diese Zahlenmagie, die da drin steckt, du hast es jetzt schon betont, ist also begründet ein technopolitischen Apparat, der, sagt sie später auch nochmal in aller Deutlichkeit, wurde ja auch schon von uns so kritisiert, die Freiheit des Parlaments in seinem wichtigsten Recht, nämlich Budgetentscheidung zu treffen, aushebelt und damit aber Einfluss auf persönliche Schicksale nimmt. Also die größte Frage, die sich ein Staat stellen darf, wie viel Geld darf ich ausgeben, obliegt nicht mehr dem Parlament, sondern einem technopolitischen Apparat. Und betroffen sind die tief ins persönliche Schicksal eingreifenden politischen Fragen, die zu klären sind, wie zum Beispiel, in welchem Maß sollen Frauen erwerbstätig sein? Wie viele Arbeitslose braucht die Volkswirtschaft? Also nicht, wie viele können wir uns leisten oder so, sondern wie viele erzeugen wir künstlich, weil die Volkswirtschaft sie braucht? Und da würde ich sagen, sehr gut. Also auf dieses Buch haben wir dann gewartet. Das sind genau die Sachen, die wir wissen wollen, denn all diese Fragen über Unmacht, Unfreiheit des Einzelnen, Stabilität der Wirtschaftsordnung, wie groß ist die Reservearmee, wie viele Frauen arbeiten und so. All das steht in unseren Schuldenregeln. Ja, sie haben richtig gelesen, tun sie extra nochmal. Also eine sehr gute Ausgangslage für ein Buch, das uns dann interessiert im Folgenden, wenn man das dann weiter liest.
Sie setzt sich mit zwei Denkern auseinander, einmal mit Marx und einmal mit Keynes. Marx kritisiert sie oder sie versucht, Marx zu widerlegen. Nicht den gesamten Marx, aber doch zumindest einen Aspekt von Marx. Und zwar diese Idee mit der Reservearmee. Das muss man, glaube ich, kurz erklären. Marx geht davon aus, dass der Kapitalismus so funktioniert, dass es nie auf eine Vollbeschäftigung hinauslaufen kann oder soll. Deshalb, weil das Kapital Interesse daran hat, dass immer eine gewisse Reservearmee an Arbeitslosen zur Verfügung steht, aus einem einfachen Grund, man kann so besser Druck ausüben auf die Beschäftigten, auf die, die in Lohn und Brot sind. Denn wenn ihnen die Arbeitslosigkeit droht, müssen sie natürlich jeden Job annehmen und können sich nicht so sehr darauf verlassen, woanders eine Stelle zu bekommen. Deshalb ist also die Arbeitslosigkeit für Marx eine wichtige Komponente in einem kapitalistischen System. Denn anders hätten die Arbeiter eine viel größere Macht. Das ist jetzt sehr verkürzt, gebe ich zu. Aber man muss sagen, dass Marx sich auch hier in dieser Idee von der Reservearmee mit Malses auseinandersetzen, mit diesem Bevölkerungsgesetz. So ein Malses, der ging ja davon aus, dass die Leute sich immer weiter vermehren. Und dann gibt es so eine Bevölkerungsexplosion, die wird dann wieder eingedämmt durch große Hungersnöte. Und er versucht, so natürlichen Kreislauf zu zeigen. Und Marx sagt, nee, das stimmt gar nicht. Und insofern ist das also erstmal eine Kritik von Marx an Malses, die sehr gerechtfertigt ist, zu sagen, nein, der Kapitalismus produziert diese Arbeitslosigkeit, er braucht sie mitunter auch. Und da der Kapitalismus eher ein krisenhaftes System ist, kann es also diese Art der Vollbeschäftigung nicht geben und schon gar nicht, wo alle gute Jobs haben. Sie stellt dem nun Keynes entgegen. Keynes sagt, ja, das ist sehr häufig zu beobachten, dass das im Kapitalismus so ist, aber das sei nicht ein Gesetz des Kapitalismus, wie man das bei Marx vielleicht eher lesen kann, sondern der Staat kann ja selbst als Akteur auftreten und da, wo Arbeitslosigkeit herrscht, Jobs vergeben. Also wir haben jetzt Arbeitslose in Deutschland. Dann könnte man also sagen mit Keynes, was muss dann getan werden? Denn es ist ja so, dass erst mal, wenn Leute nicht arbeiten, unglaublich viele Ressourcen ungenutzt bleiben und viele Tätigkeiten nicht ausgeübt werden, die gesellschaftlich notwendig vielleicht wären, aber nicht profitabel sind. Das ist ja ganz klar. Wir könnten ja sagen, die Arbeitslosen kümmern sich um Nachmittagsbetreuung und machen Hausaufgaben mit den Kindern zusammen. Irgendwie sowas. Und dann wäre das zwar nicht profitabel in dem Sinne, aber der Staat könnte sie anstellen. Die Sache ist natürlich, dass der Staat damit als Konkurrent der Privatwirtschaft auftritt und die Privatwirtschaft damit unter Druck setzt. Und ich bin da skeptischer, was diesen Keynesianismus anbelangt, und würde sagen, naja, so wie sie das im Prinzip jetzt hier ausbuchstabiert, dass wirklich dann gute Jobs für alle geschaffen werden könnten, wenn man so ein Keynesianisches Programm ansetzt. Das ist ja auch, was man bei Maurice Höfgen immer wieder hören kann. Da würde ich sagen, das hat immer die Grenzen, da wo das Kapital das mitmacht und wo es sich dagegen stellt, wird es dann schwierig. Was aber feststeht ist, dass natürlich mit entsprechenden Investitionen sehr viel mehr Gutes getan werden könnte in Bezug auf Jobs. Und dass man vielleicht auch nicht so sehr dieser Willkürherrschaft des Marktes ausgesetzt sein müsste.
Interessant, dass du es so rumgelesen hast, denn jetzt hast du sozusagen die funktionale Analyse geliefert.
Ja.
Während ich das las, dachte ich, ah, das ist eine sehr gute historische, also eher im Sinne von, Marx hat ja auch als Historiker verstanden, dass man eigentlich bei ihr auch das historische Interesse sieht. Denn du hast jetzt gesagt, sie argumentiert mit Marx und dann stellt sie dem aber Keynes gegenüber. Da würde ich sagen, interessanterweise ja nicht in meiner Lesart. Denn wir haben ja ganz viele Bücher, in denen immer Hayek und Keynes nochmal erklärt wird. Also mit so einer Funktionalen, der eine wollte das so, der andere so und das ist ein Widersatz. Und heute müssen wir eine Synthese, irgendeine Dialektik, was auch immer. Und bei ihr erstaunlicherweise finde ich das überraschend, anders, mal einfach historisch verortet. Nämlich Karl Marx hat gesagt, es gibt eine Reservearmee von Arbeitskräften, die relativ niedrig bezahlt, ihren Kapitaleignern, weil die die Werkzeuge haben und so, die Maschinen, die Fabriken gegenüberstehen. Nur man kann es ja einfach runterbrechen, sagt sie dann auf, naja, als 1867 das Kapital veröffentlicht wurde, hatte sich in den 50 Jahren vorher die Bevölkerung einmal verdoppelt. Klar hat Marx so argumentiert.
Genau, das ist ja in Bezug auf Malces, der sagt ja, die Leute vermehren sich immer mehr.
Und dann weist sie aber darauf hin, dass ja, das Kapital ist damals sehr stark gewachsen, aber die Ungleichheit im Einkommen ein bisschen weniger. Also so richtig zu kräftig ist das Marx-Argument gar nicht. Also war folgerichtig, und Keynes wurde dann drei Monate nach Marx totgeboren, war dann folgerichtig der nächste Gedankengang, welche Rolle spielt jetzt der Staat, der ja aus diesen Zwangslagen, hier muss mal was organisiert werden, im Marxischen Sinne entsteht. So und dann haben wir plötzlich kein Bevölkerungs, also jedenfalls nicht mehr kein, kein explosives Wachstum mehr, sondern nur noch stetiges Steigen. Was bedeutet? Auf Massenarbeitslosigkeit und Angst wird anders reagiert. Ja, es gibt diese Reservearmee, aber man kann eben auch Ansprüche an den Staat stellen. Und sie lässt das dann ausfaden mit so einem Hinweis auf, es ist ein bisschen blöd, wenn dann, nachdem man eigentlich recht kluge Ansprüche an den Staat vorgestellt hat, man doch wieder zurückfällt auf Bildung und Beten. Beim Nutzen von biografischen Chancen. Und das ist ja ihr eigentliches Interesse. Wie nutzen wir unsere biografischen Chancen? Wer gibt uns Freiheiten? Und welche Freiheiten stehen uns eigentlich zu? Oder im ökonomischen Zwang, welche sind möglich? Also totale Freiheitsfantasien sind ja auch jetzt nicht sehr tragfähig. Und da ist ganz interessant, dass sie eben über diese Philosophie da einsteigt. Also sie kommt ja nicht zuerst mit Marx und Keynes, sondern sie kommt erst mal mit Amartya Sen, einem indischen Philosophen. Geht es nach Sen, brauchen Menschen für Freiheit die Chance, ihren Lebensentwurf selbst zu wählen und die Fähigkeit, ihn umzusetzen. Und dann kann man im Text gut nachvollziehen, wie sie diese Fragen interessieren und sie in der Ökonomie und der Wirtschaftswissenschaft Antworten darauf findet, die sie in der Philosophie nicht fand. Und da bei Marx dann anzukommen, finde ich meine richtig gute Begründung, zu sagen, wir müssen kurz über Marx sprechen, statt einfach nur zu sagen, wir müssen über Marx sprechen, weil ich habe im Gegenstandpunkt gelesen, Marx ist wichtig oder so.
Ich glaube auch eher, dass dieser Bezug jetzt dazu, also Opposition bei mir, wichtig ist, weil sie versucht ein Programm, ein Jobprogramm auch aufzulegen, was also alles möglich wäre, wenn man über Schulden anders nachdächte. Und dass sie dadurch natürlich in so eine Opposition kommt, macht man also so ein kainsianisches Jobprogramm. Oder hält man doch an dem fest, was Marx sagt, dass so eine gewisse Reservearmee da ist? Was sie erst mal feststellt, ist, dass dieses neoliberale Schuldenregime, das da in den 80er-Jahren dann installiert wird, dafür sorgt, dass Marx quasi bestätigt wird. Man hat da die Reservearmee und dann guckt man noch mal, auch bei der FED, wie viel Arbeitslosigkeit brauchen wir dann? Aber wir brauchen noch ein bisschen. Dann gehen wir noch mal mit der Zinsrate nach oben. Also da wird eigentlich so ein, Marx wird da noch mal bekräftigt von den Neoliberalen. Und sie sagt jetzt, und das ist quasi die Opposition dazu, also Marx war das ja nicht recht, dass das so ist. Der hat ja nur ein Gesetz beschrieben oder glaubt, ein Gesetz zu beschreiben. Und was sie jetzt sagt, ist nein, wenn der Staat als Akteur auftritt und zum Beispiel vielleicht sogar so weit gehen kann, dass er selbst die Jobs schafft, die gebraucht werden, wenn die Privatwirtschaft es nicht übernimmt, dass genau damit eigentlich das ausgehebelt werden kann, dieses so ehrenerscheinende Gesetz. Und da hat sie sicherlich einen interessanten Punkt, bei dem man sich auch hier fragen muss, wie weit kann das gehen? Also wie weit kann der Staat als wirtschaftlicher Akteur auftreten? Ich würde unterstreichen wollen, dass der Staat jetzt sich so schlank gemacht hat, dass natürlich erstmal sehr viel auszubauen wäre, was auch dem Kapital gar nicht im Wege stünde. Also ich glaube, wenn jetzt der Staat anfangen würde, sagen wir, eigene Chipfabriken zu bauen. Also wirklich nicht zu subventionieren, sondern eigene Chipfabriken zu bauen. Oder eigene Marketing-Agenturen, was weiß ich, eigene Kleidung herstellt. Dann wäre das natürlich etwas, wo das Kapital sich zurückziehen würde aus Deutschland und sagen würde, gut, hier ist nichts mehr zu machen. Die machen ja da eine Planwirtschaft. Die machen nur noch eine staatlich gelenkte Wirtschaft. Was habe ich als Privater da noch zu verdienen? Wenn aber jetzt zum Beispiel der Staat sagt, wir finanzieren die Kinderbetreuung stärker. Wir finanzieren ökologische Projekte, die die Infrastruktur im Ganzen verbessern stärker und können da selbst als Akteur auftreten, dann habe ich auch den Verdacht, dass das dem privaten Kapital gar nicht unangenehm wäre, weil die dann sagen würden, na Gott sei Dank, in diesem Land ist ja schon mal für die Kinder der Mitarbeiter gesorgt, also kümmern wir uns um den Rest und haben nicht das Problem, dass wir keine Leute bekommen, weil die gar nicht wissen, wohin mit den Kindern. Und da gibt es, glaube ich, ganz viele Beispiele, warum das so ist. Warum also der Staat tatsächlich viel stärker auftreten kann und vielleicht auch da auftreten muss, wo Dinge nicht profitabel zu machen sind. Oder wo auch wir darüber reden müssen, wenn wir jetzt wirklich über Humanressourcen reden. Was kann dann eigentlich der Staat sinnvoll leisten oder wo muss er was leisten? Man könnte ja noch sagen, Kinder auszubilden ist das Wichtigste eigentlich, was ein Staat machen kann, weil das das zukünftige BIP sichert.
Darauf kommen wir gleich ausführlich zu sprechen.
Aber bei den Alten ist es ja genau nicht so. Also sich um alte Menschen zu kümmern, hilft dem BIP nicht. Das ist nicht in die Logik der Verwertbarkeit einzuspeisen. Jetzt kann man natürlich und sollte man nicht in so einen Sozialdavinismus verfallen und in den verfallen drohen wir zu verfallen, wenn wir das dem Markt überlassen, weil der sagt einfach, lau lohnt sich für uns nicht. Sondern genau in solchen Fällen muss ja der Staat eingreifen und muss also dort dann das übernehmen, was dem Markt gar nicht entspricht, sich um Leute zu kümmern, die danach nicht ins Berufsleben gehen, sondern die gehen ja ihrem Lebensabend entgegen.
Hier in diesem Text liegt also eine, finde ich, sehr große Pointe, die jeder nutzen sollte, der demnächst mit Carsten Linnemann oder Friedrich Merz oder wem auch immer aus dieser Riege, Thorsten Frei, eingeladen ist, eine Maischberger Sendung oder so zu bestreiten. Denn wenn jemand in seinem politischen Denken meint, Arbeitslosigkeit sei eine Sache, die natürlich und notwendig ist und die der Staat aber abmildern kann, ist das marxistisches Denken. Das sind die eigentlichen Marxisten. Weil das ist weder natürlich noch notwendig, sagt sie. Dass eine Reservearmee sich gegenseitig die Löhne kaputtmacht und der Staat dann daneben steht und sagt, ja gut, dann stocken wir ein bisschen auf. Das ist marxistisches Denken. Das sind die Marxisten. Ja, bitte. Während sie daneben steht und sagt, wir müssen, wenn wir über Geld neu nachdenken, über Arbeit neu nachdenken. Denn wenn wir einfach ein Paratigma der Freiheit ist, die Freiheit von Einmischung, also der Raum der Nicht-Einmischung, sagt sie, je mehr Geld über Arbeit verteilt wird, desto besser funktioniert tendenziell Freiheit als Nichtbeherrschung, weil große Armut und großer Reichtum zurückgehen. Sie beginnt das Kapitel mit Rousseau, der nochmal darauf hinweist, dass sowohl der Bettler als auch der Reiche nicht geduldet werden können, weil sie die Gesellschaft zerstören. Man braucht also ein Ausgleich, ein Medium, das für Nichtgleichheit, sondern für Ausgleich sorgt. Und umso mehr– und ich komme jetzt spezifisch aus persönlichem Interesse, umso mehr Milliardäre sich einfach Geld rausnehmen aus diesem Kreislauf und Kapital mehr Rendite erwirtschaftet als Arbeit. Also dieser Kreislauf aus Arbeit immer mehr auf Verknappung setzt. Bis hin zu, wir müssen leider dein Fernseher ausschalten, wir können uns das Programm nicht mehr leisten. Solche Argumentationen. Das ist eigentlich Marxismus. Das ist marxistisches Denken.
Naja, also es ist nicht marxistisches Denken, sondern Marx ist ja nur jemand, der das schreibt.
Das sind die marxistischen Paradigmen, mit denen Marx reingegangen ist. Ich meine nicht die Abhilfe, sondern der historische Marx, der Gesellschaft beschreibt.
Marx beschreibt das genauso.
Also der Vorwurf müsste dann lauten...
Die Realität scheint Marx zu bestätigen.
Genau. Lieber Herr Lindemann, Sie müssen aus diesem historischen Marxismus jetzt ausbrechen. Wir können uns diesen Marxismus nicht länger leisten. Seien Sie kein Marxist. Und zwar wirklich gut begründet. Das ist Marxistisches Denken, das ist jetzt zu beginnen.
Ich freue mich auf diese Talkshow, die werde ich mir dann ansehen.
Genau. Und Sie definieren dann auch...
Nur, um das nicht alles über einen Kamm zu scheren. Wir hatten ein Buch Crazy Rich im vergangenen Salon von Julia Friedrichs. Sie beschäftigte sich damit, wie Milliardäre leben, wie man sie besteuern sollte, könnte. Hier gibt sich eine Autorin nicht dieser Frage hin, denn sie sagt, wenn man es mal durchrechnet, so viel ist es nicht, um das zu realisieren, was wir realisieren müssen. Also das ist einfach nicht ihr Thema. Man kann natürlich über Ungleichheit sprechen und wie kann man die minimieren. Und da spielt die Besteuerung von Milliardären eine Rolle. Was sie aber sagt ist, man wird nicht die Finanzen mobilisieren können, die man braucht, indem man Milliardäre besteuert. Und das stimmt natürlich. Also man kriegt nicht einen Doppelwumms hin, wenn man Milliardäre besteuert. Das gibt keinen Doppelwumms. Das gibt ein paar Milliarden und das wäre gut, wenn man das täte. Da wäre sie bestimmt auch dafür. Nur sie beschäftigt sich jetzt hier damit, wie kann das eigentlich sein, dass man 100 Milliarden mal hat oder sie nicht hat? Und womit hängt das eigentlich zusammen?
Die Besteuerung der Milliardäre ist ja kein Selbstzweck. Sie sagt das ja auch. Das Ziel ist ja, das Geld so zu verwenden, dass alle davon was haben und nicht nur Milliardäre. Was sollen wir mit 9000 Superjachten? Wir brauchen 20.000 Züge. Sie sagt zu Recht, und es ist ja auch die Adam-Tues-Vernunft, wir sollten jetzt in Billionen denken, also reichen uns Milliardäre nicht aus. Und wenn Draghi sagt 800 Milliarden im Jahr, nur. Dieses Geld kann man auch einer demokratischen Kontrolle unterwerfen, bevor man es ihnen wegnimmt. Denn wenn die argumentieren, ich brauche einen Bedarfsschonung, ich habe einen Schonungsbedarf, denn meine Gelder sind alle investiert, dann sagt der Staat, es bleibt investiert, nur wir werden der Anteilseigner der Entitäten, in die es investiert ist. Wenn ein Management sagt, ich möchte aber nicht, dass der Staat bei mir mit drin hängt, wie bei der Commerzbank oder bei der Lürftansa. Ich möchte gerne eine eigene Entscheidung treffen, die nicht von der Demokratie meines Anteilseigners, 20% von VW gehören dem Staat, gestört wird. Dann soll er den Staat freikaufen. Dann muss er Geld mobilisieren. Das ist, finde ich, eine sehr kluge, sehr kreative Antwort auf diese große Frage. Nicht, wir nehmen den Milliardären das Geld weg, sondern wir unterwerfen auch das Geld von Milliardären, das investiert ist, in irgendwelche Firmen. Auch diese Firmen können wir mal ein bisschen darauf trimmen, nicht nur Renditeerwartung von Superreichen zu entsprechen, sondern auch demokratischen Anliegen, die eben im Parlamentarismus entschieden wurden, was auch immer. Also sie hat da durchaus eine Antwort drauf. Und ich bleibe aber dabei, ja, Adam Toos hat recht und sie hat auch recht. Wenn wir Millionen brauchen, reichen die Milliardäre nicht. Trotzdem allein, weil ich nicht möchte, dass noch eine weitere Superjacht gebaut wird und Supernachten nur von Milliardären gekauft werden können, darf es keine Milliardäre geben.
Ja, ja, ich bin auch sehr dafür. Nur muss man die Dinge ein bisschen auseinanderhalten.
Aber es gibt noch einen Punkt, den wir damit übersprungen haben, die Arbeit. Definition von Arbeit. Denn es gibt, und das finde ich immer sehr gut, wenn man einen Begriff nimmt und sagt, den gibt es doppelt. Wie bei Verantwortung, Schuld, wie auch immer. Arbeit auch. Wenn jemand arbeitet und sichtbar bei körperlich aufzehrt, Dachdecker, der berühmte Dachdecker, Said von Julia Friedrichs, der die U-Bahn putzt. Ist das ein anderer Arbeitsbegriff, als wenn Friedrich Merz sagt, mir macht arbeiten Spaß, denn ich sitze gerne in beheizten Räumen, werde gern bewirtet. Und wenn mich abends mein Fahrer nach Hause bringt, arbeiten sogar zwei. Das ist besser.
Sie vergleicht ja die Professoren mit der Paketbotin.
Genau, die Professorin und die Paketbotin.
Die Paketbotin sagt nicht, Mensch, das macht alles so viel Spaß. Ich habe heute wieder noch drei Stunden länger gearbeitet, sondern sie guckt auf die Uhr und sagt, endlich Feierabend. Die Professorin, die schon immer zu diesem Thema forschen wollte, steht noch nachts im Labor, weil sie unbedingt noch das Ergebnis abwarten möchte.
Genau.
Das ist der Unterschied. Und hier kommt meine Hauptkritik an diesem Buch. Deswegen bringe ich sie jetzt, weil ich viel loben, das gleich zu sagen habe.
Ich habe nur Lobendes.
Ich habe eine Hauptkritik. Und zwar will sie, dass das Politikziel ist, dass genügend gute Jobs für alle entstehen. Und dabei klammert sie dann leider aus, dass wir ja gesellschaftlich notwendige Arbeit verrichten müssen. Und diese gesellschaftlich notwendige Arbeit wird gerade von Leuten verrichtet, die nicht besonders viele in aller Regel dafür verdienen. Manche gesellschaftlich notwendige Arbeit wird auch sehr gut bezahlt. Gesellschaftlich notwendige Arbeit kann auch Spaß machen, aber es gibt auch sehr viel, was jetzt niemals auf das Niveau kommt, der Professorin, die an einem Projekt forscht und so eine intrinsische Lust dabei erlebt. Deshalb muss man also feststellen, eine gewisse Arbeit, die jetzt nicht sonderlich viel Spaß macht, so will ich mal mich ausdrücken. Ich will jetzt noch nicht von den Dirty-Jobs und Scheiß-Jobs und alles sprechen. Die muss verrichtet werden. Wenn man das gerne ausgleichend machen will, dann kann man natürlich Menschen stärker entlohnen, dass man quasi damit abfedert, dass sie ein bisschen auf das schöne im Leben dafür verzichten, aber sie machen dann diese Arbeit. Oder man verteilt diese Arbeit, und das wäre dann sozialistisches Programm, und sagt also auch du, Stefan, auch ich, wir alle müssen in der Woche zehn Stunden gesellschaftlich notwendige Arbeit verrichten. Und das wäre dann Straßenkehren und, und, und. Das, das, das, wenn man ehrlich ist, weil gute Jobs für alle zu versprechen, während man gleichzeitig ja dann noch jemanden haben möchte, der einem um 22 Uhr die Pizza, bitte aber warm, liefert, da wird's schwierig. Was soll man der Person bezahlen, dass man sagt, das ist aber jetzt ein toller Job. Und das ist der eine Kritikpunkt, der zweite.
Warte, überlassen wir uns mal über den ersten Plan.
Ja.
Denn hier würde ich einfach wirklich direkt widersprechen. Sie definiert ja später die Wirtschafts-Nutzleistung und sagt am Anfang, ich hab's ja eben vorgelesen, je mehr Geld über Arbeit verteilt wird, desto besser funktioniert tendenziell die Freiheit der Nichtbeherrschung. Wenn du also Arbeit hast, die du auf einem Felde definierst, die besonders hohen Nutzen hat, aber besonders wenige Entgelte, niedrige Entgelte, besonders wenig Entlohnung, setzt ja die Wirtschafts-Nutzleistung genau da an und sagt, ein Lehrer, den wir niemals durch Technologie ersetzen können, oder eine Pflegekraft, die das Harari betont, den Arzt, der eine Diagnose-Einschätzung macht, aufgrund von keine Ahnung, welche Kennziffern, in welcher Diagnostik so anläuft, genau, das kann man ersetzen. Nicht ersetzen kann man ein dreijähriges Kind schreit, weil es die Nadel fürchtet und braucht aber eine Impfung. Also kommt eine Pflegekraft, die das kann. Sich mit dem Kind auseinandersetzen, die Eltern beruhigen und so weiter und so fort. So, und wenn wir diese Umdefinition schaffen, also von diesem Renditegedanken übers BIP kodiert, hin zu einer Wirtschafts-Nutzleistung. Und in Leistung steckt nun mal Arbeit, mal Zeit. So, und da eine Entlohnung finden, die diesen Unterschied, den sie ja extra macht, in der Definition von Arbeit. Also die Professorin, die aus intrinsischer Motivation ihr Forschungsergebnis und so weiter. Wir wissen ja nie, wohin es führt. Wir haben jetzt einen Wirtschaftsnobelpreis vergeben, der an eine Frau ging, die 30 Jahre lang gar nicht wusste, ob das überhaupt klappt. Und der ganze Forschungsprinzip hat ihr gesagt, diese mRNA kriegst du nie stabilisiert. So, und dann zehn Jahre vor Corona, nach 20 Jahren da bin, in der Welt, ständig gene die Forschungsbudgets flöten, kommt einfach BioNTech und sagt, wir glauben daran. Ja, also man kann es ja eh nie richtig verorten, dass die Professorin jetzt hier ausgewählt wurde, finde ich so ein bisschen fragwürdig. Aber der Paketbote, wir wollen, dass der Gram zu uns geliefert wird. So, und wenn das Geld kostet, muss jemand dieses Geld bezahlen und damit jemandem, der genauso gut sagen könnte, ich könnte mich auch ins Labor stellen und dort einfach unter der Heizdecke warten und Netflix gucken, bis mein Experiment durchgelaufen ist, dem zu sagen, wir geben dir jetzt Freiheit zurück. Die Nichtbeherrschung wird ausgemerzt, indem wir da sagen, statt 2.000 Netto im Monat 8.000. Dann bringt man das Paket sehr viel freiwilliger. Dann macht man diese Arbeit sehr viel freiwilliger. Und so steht es aber auch im Buch.
Ja, das steht so im Buch. Aber da sehen wir ja dann den Zahlen, auch die du da gerade genannt hast, dass das sehr illusorisch ist, dass man dahin kommt. Man sagt dann, die Millionäre können sich dann noch was liefern lassen.
Material mag das illusorisch sein, aber die Argumentation steckt im Buch. Ja, die Argumentation steckt im Buch.
Aber man kann nicht gute Jobs für alle versprechen, weil das ein Versprechen ist, dass im Kapitalismus notwendigerweise nicht eingelöst werden kann. Bessere Jobs für alle kann man versprechen. Also man kann die Situation der Leute deutlich verbessern. Und ich bin ja auch für eine starke Mindestlohnanhebung und das wäre auch möglich. Dadurch fallen gewisse Dinge vielleicht auch weg. Und manche Leistungen kann man dann nicht mehr wahrnehmen, weil man sagt, ist mir jetzt zu teuer, mir für 10 Euro nochmal Aufschlag eine Pizza liefern zu lassen. Aber so hoch ist jetzt der Mindestlohn.
Ja, ohne Automatisierung.
Ja, man muss sich im Klaren sein, dass da Dinge dann wegfallen. Also ich glaube, dass diese Illusion der guten Jobs für alle wird da schwierig, wo man nicht gesellschaftlich notwendige Arbeit dann nochmal auf alle verteilt. Und da kommt der Punkt hinzu, wo sie dann sagt, pro Jahr werden hierzulande Neuwagen im Wert von ungefähr 100 Milliarden Euro einem Scholz einen Wumms abgesetzt. Aber Geld, um alten Menschen im Heim die Zähne zu putzen, ist keines da. Und da ist aus der kapitalistischen Perspektive herausgesagt, keinen Widerspruch zu erkennen. Denn Autos, die produziert und verkauft werden, bringen Geld und steigern das BIP. Wenn Menschen, die alt sind, die nicht mehr als Arbeitskräfte wieder zurückkommen, denen die Zähne geputzt werden, dann bringt das kein Geld. Deshalb muss man doch hier einfach unterscheiden zwischen dem, was profitabel ist und dem, was notwendig und wichtig ist, nämlich dass Menschen die Zähne geputzt bekommen, die es nicht mehr selbst können. Und da muss dann das staatliche Geld rein. Aber ansonsten ist da im Kapitalismus selbst kein Widerspruch da.
Stimmt, weshalb sie ja sagt, wir müssen grundsätzlich neu denken. Also da, wo du jetzt sagst, dem Alten die Zähne zu putzen, da ist ja gar kein Return on Investment möglich. Weil das ist ja keine Entwicklungsgeschichte wie beim dreijährigen Kind, das dann irgendwann mal 50 Jahre zu dem Arbeitsmarkt zur Verfügung steht, sondern umgedreht. Der stirbt dann einfach und ist weg. Und umso früher er stirbt, umso besser für die Volkswirtschaft. Nur, wir haben es doch jetzt so, dass wir Pflege zu 80 Prozent privat organisieren und die ambulante Pflege darf sich untereinander nicht mal koordinieren. Also jeder muss seinen eigenen Vertrag mit dem ambulanten Pflegedienst machen. Du kannst jetzt nicht einfach so stadtteilmäßig eine Pflege Mutter wie für Kinder, da geht das. Aber für die Alten geht das nicht, weil da gibt es einfach gesetzliche Hürden. Was ja bedeutet, der Raum der Freiheit derjenigen, die diese Pflege jetzt gerade machen, ist eingeschränkt. Diese Frauen, also überwiegend sind das Frauen, die die älteren Familienmitglieder pflegen, stehen im Arbeitsmarkt nicht zur Verfügung. Das dämpft die volkswirtschaftliche Leistungsfähigkeit. Wenn diese zur Verfügung stehen würden, hätte man, und das kann man ja dann ausrechnen, in Stunden, wie viel mehr Arbeitszeit es ist. Also Friedrich Merz jammert rum, dass wir viel weniger arbeiten. Ja, weil der Pflegebedarf so hoch ist. So, nur und jetzt kann man die Synergieeffekte einfach durchrechnen. Die Frage ist nur, wie organisieren wir es jetzt? Wenn wir eine Wirtschaftsnutzleistung argumentiert bekommen, die auch gesetzlich kodiert ist, dann kann man einfach sagen, ja natürlich erlauben wir den 15 Betroffenen in diesem Straßenzug einen ambulanten Pflegedienst so einzurichten, dass er die Leute an alle Synergieeffekte holt, sodass 80 Leute frei haben zu arbeiten. Nur wir haben es bisher nicht so kodiert, weil wir an diesem BIP hängen. Und die Abrechnung eines Autogewinns möglich ist und die Abrechnung eines volkswirtschaftlichen Zugewinns an Arbeitskraft nicht möglich ist. Nur, und das ist eben dieser Punkt, das könnte man ja einfach anders machen. Und im Kapitel zwei, also im Kapitel eins, kommt sie mit dieser Philosophie, mit ihrem biografischen Einstieg, mit Marx, Keynes, Rousseau, dann diesen indischen Philosophen und so weiter. Kapitel zwei beginnt damit, dass sie unzufrieden ist mit der ökonomischen Theorie, die das nämlich abbilden soll. Dass eine Pflege durchaus energetischen Mehrwert für die Volkswirtschaft hat. Und sie sagt ganz deutlich, die ökonomische Theorie ist nicht einfach nur unvollständig, sondern es gibt Ökonomen, die bilden nur Geldflüsse ab. Und dann gibt es Modelle, die kennen gar kein Geld. Also wir haben hier extreme Defizite. Einfach nur im politischen Planen und politischen Denken. Und das könnte man alles anders machen. Und dann hätte man auch gar keine großen Probleme, denke ich, um zu sagen, ja klar klingt das heute unrealistisch, Arbeit neu zu denken. Aber es ist so zwingend nötig, dass wir es einfach grundsätzlich machen sollten.
Ich bin sehr dafür, das neu zu denken und dann das zu machen. Nur glaube ich, dass wir uns nicht der Illusion hingeben dürfen, dass wir alles in diese Nutzenrechnung einfließen lassen können und dass das dann immer ein positives Ergebnis gibt. Sondern wir müssen auch dann einfach feststellen, und das widerspricht ja gar nicht ihrer grundsätzlichen Annahme, wir müssen einfach feststellen, dass gewisse Dinge sich nicht rentieren, aber wichtig sind. Und das ist zum Beispiel die Pflege alter Menschen. Und die muss finanziert werden und das Geld dafür ist da. Wären diese Schuldenregeln nicht, könnte man da viel leichter in den Topf greifen. Aber darüber kommt man nicht hinaus. Also das kann man natürlich dann noch so rechtfertigen, dass es Synergieeffekte dadurch gibt, wenn sich einige um die Pflege kümmern, die anderen arbeiten gehen und dass da viele in Teilzeit getrieben werden, weil sie sich zugleich um Anhörige kümmern müssen. Das ist definitiv so. Aber es hat eine Grenze, diese Synergieeffekte. Und da kommt das ins Spiel, was man einfach als wichtig gesellschaftlich erachtet oder moralisch als wichtig erachtet. Und das kann ja dann das Geld ausfüllen. Ich würde nur Abstand nehmen davon, dass man alles in diese Nutzenrechnung wird einfließen lassen können. Das hat Limitierungen.
Hier bin ich Kapitalist.
Manches ist aber nicht kapitalistisch. Also im Kapitalismus ist nicht zu rechtfertigen, dass Menschen nicht arbeiten. Das ist eigentlich unsinnig. Es sei denn, sie sind zu klein und können noch nicht arbeiten und müssen noch dahin geführt werden. Also der Kapitalismus ist ein sehr altenfeindliches Modell. Und deshalb muss man hier sagen, dem setzen wir diesem Kapitalismus etwas entgegen, was an sich wichtig ist. Und das ist die Würde des Menschen. Das haben wir ja nun im Grundgesetz. Und deswegen brauchen wir da gar nicht diese Nutzenrechnung. Ich glaube aber, sonst hat sie absolut da die richtigen Punkte angesprochen. Nämlich, dass wir es aufgrund nicht hinreichender Modelle oder Modelle, die es noch nicht mehr die Mühe geben, die Realität abzubilden, dahin getrieben haben, dass wir eine sehr ineffiziente Art des Wirtschaftens haben, die sowohl den Leuten, die gesellschaftlich notwendige Arbeit brauchen, schlecht geht, als auch jenen, die so ganz normal am Erwerbstätigen Leben teilnehmen. Weil sie einfach nicht genügend Zeit aufbringen können.
Ich möchte diesen Punkt, über den wir hier streiten, nochmal explizieren. Denn folgend dem Buch, weil sie es ja an einem Punkt macht, leider nicht an den Alten. Denn das wäre super interessant. Ich hätte es natürlich für die Altenrepublik auch mal anstoßen können, dass man das ökonomisch einfach durchkalkuliert. Es ist aber so, wenn die Pflege stationär stattfindet, also du hast einen Pflegeplatz für deine Eltern oder Großeltern gefunden, kostet der jetzt gerade 2900 Euro im Schnitt, also liegt im Top Ten des gesamten Einkommens, das man mobilisieren kann. Also darüber, man braucht Vermögen dafür. Was bedeutet, diejenigen, die von ihrem Arbeiten leben, können sich die Pflege nicht leisten und werden dann aber am Arbeiten gehindert, weil der Betreuungsschlüssel in der privaten Pfleger eins zu eins ist. Ein Pfleger, also einer aus der Familie erklärt sich bereit, eine Person zu pflegen. Der Synergieeffekt, wenn man das besser organisieren würde und man hätte einen Betreuungsschlüssel von sieben zu eins, zumindest tagsüber, dass man sagt, okay, der Kopf ist frei zum Arbeiten, man muss sich keine Sorgen um 12 Uhr mittags machen, dass 17 Uhr jemand gestorben ist. Man hat es gar nicht mitbekommen oder so. Denen rechnet sie. Also leider macht sie dieses, wo ich glaube, da sind auch gigantische volkswirtschaftlichen Renditen drin, wenn man es anders organisiert. Macht sie leider nicht als Thema auf. Aber dafür beim anderen guten Thema, nämlich Bildung. Sie nennt ja Bildung und die Bahn, also Mobilität und Bildung. So, die Bildung, für die interessiere ich mich ja nun besonders, weil das ja beim Familienthema auch so immens wichtig ist und dann ja immer wieder Argumentationen kommen, und zwar aus allen Richtungen, bis hin zu Ohle bei euch im Podcast. Wenn jemand in der Familie irgendwas macht, ist mir das doch egal, das spielt ja volkswirtschaftlich keine Rolle. Ich habe sogar die Clips dazu, weil ich mal gucken, ob ich die im Buch dann unterbringe. So, und hier macht sie diese Rechnung auf, dass eine Ausgabe für Bildung immer, immer Investition ist, niemals Konsum. Ist immer Investition. Geld, das in eine Schule fließt, das in Kinder fließt, ist immer eine Investition. Und die Frage ist nur noch, wie hoch ist die Rendite? Und jetzt sagt sie, 12 Prozent. Also besser als die Fonds, verdächtig, sagt sie. Besser kriegt es auch in Family Offices kaum hin. Nur, man muss eben aus der BWL-Bibdenke ausbrechen und muss in eine VWL-Nutzenrechnung einsteigen.
Unter andere Länder machen das. Esstland gibt 60 Prozent mehr für Vorschule und Grundschule aus, obwohl die nun volkswirtschaftlich Wesenden schlechter dastehen, was sich schon daran zeigt, dass in Estland ein Mindestlohn von nur 5 Euro gezahlt wird.
Ihre Argumentation geht so weit, und sie bleibt ja in der ökonomischen Vernunft verhaftet, aber sie geht so weit, dass sie sagt, wenn wir heute in Bildung investieren und damit ein nächstes Erwerbspersonenpotenzial bekommen, dass automatisch höherwertige Produkte herstellt, allein weil der Beitrag der Menschen im Produktionsprozess höherwertig ist. Höherer Ausbildung, mehr Wissen, mehr Freiheit im Kopf, mehr Sensibilität für kleine Variation, Erfindung, Innovation, was auch immer. Dann würden die Renditen, die später volkswirtschaftlich allein durch Steuerzahlung herausgezogen werden können, würden den Bedarf an Bildungsfinanzierung übertreffen. Es wäre in einem ganz seltenen Felder ein sich selbst tragendes und noch profitabwerfendes Ziel, das man erreichen könnte. Das ist einfach eine Sensation.
Können die Leute jetzt gut nachvollziehen? Ja, wenn man sagt, 12 Prozent Rendite, das ist natürlich auf die Zeit gesehen. In dem Sinne, dass man sagt, erst einmal muss sehr lange investiert werden, bis sich das dann auszahlt. Kinder sind ja ein sehr langfristiges Projekt, wie man weiß. Man muss erst einmal 18 werden, bis man dann erwachsen ist, dann ins erwerbstätigen Leben so langsam hineingeht. Sicherlich noch vielleicht ein Studium dazwischen und Ausbildung und sowas. Aber dann zahlt sich das entsprechend aus. Und wenn man das dann mal über die Jahrzehnte betrachtet, dann hat man eigentlich ein positives Investment. Während die Rechnungen heute so aussehen, und die werden auch von der Politik ausgemacht, wir haben so und so viel Geld für Bildung in diesem Jahr ausgegeben. Da ist aber weder darin enthalten, inwieweit die horrenden Bildungsausgaben von 2003 dazu geführt haben, dass wir jetzt wirtschaftlich gut dastehen, noch ist da eingespeist, dass genau diese Investitionen jetzt dafür sorgen, dass 2039 der Ertrag dann für die Volkswirtschaft da ist.
Es ist so crazy, dass Maurice Höfgen im aktuellen Wirtschaftsbriefing den Clip von Daniel Günther bei Junge NAEF zweimal gespielt hat. Wie er sagte, eigentlich hätten wir gerne mehr Lehrer angestellt, aber unser Haushalt gibt es nicht her. Und das muss man sich zweimal vorspielen, weil man es nicht glauben kann. Es geht doch hier um eine zwölfprozentige verzinste, renditeträchtige Investition. Und er macht sie nicht. Und jetzt ist die Frage, was ist los mit diesen Haushalten? Und sie sagt, wenn wir uns das anschauen, zehn Prozent des Bundeshaushalts werden vom Bundesrechnungshof als freie Mittel bezeichnet. Also wenn der Bundestag eine Haushaltsdebatte führt und fragt, was man mit dem Geld machen, geht es nicht um 450 Milliarden, sondern um 45 Milliarden. Der Rest ist gebunden. Das sind einfach langfristigte, strukturelle und das finde ich auch so crazy. Es kommt ja auch auf dieses Urteil vom 7. November zu sprechen. Das Bundesverfassungsgericht sagt dem Bundestag, wenn ihr im Bundeshaushalt schreibt, muss alles, was finanziert wird, in diesem Jahr erwirtschaftet werden. Nichts von dem, was erwirtschaftet wird, findet in diesem Jahr statt, sondern erwirtschaftet wird mit Maschinen, die vor zehn Jahren gekauft sind oder was auch immer. Dieses Prinzip der Jährlichkeit und Jährigkeit und was auch immer ist so grotesk dumm, dass man sich wirklich fragt, was ist los beim Bundesverfassungsgericht. Wenn man das hier so liest, wird es einem noch mal umso deutlicher, wie crazy das eigentlich war. Wie der Journalismus so drüber ging und meinte, das wird jetzt aber schwer für die Wiederwahl.
Wir haben ja durch die MMT noch mal eingebläut bekommen, dass man private Haushalte nicht mit Staatshaushalten vermischen sollte. Hier müsste man aber eigentlich wieder sagen, man müsste mal über den Staat wie ein Unternehmen nachdenken und müsste sagen, welchem Unternehmen wirft man dann vor, dass es vor fünf Jahren teure Maschinen angeschafft hat, wo es jetzt immensen Reichtum damit schäfe. Also du würdest ja jetzt auch nicht sitzen und sagen, das war aber dumm, als ich 2019 hier die rote Podcast-Mikrofone gekauft habe. Das war richtig teuer, das war aber richtig dumm. Ne, du machst halt seit fünf Jahren damit erfolgreich Podcasts.
Die werden ja jede Aufnahme billiger. Jede Stunde rentieren die sich mehr. Und das ist ja auch, ich meine, wir haben darüber, also wir haben über das Wohnen gesprochen und haben uns gewundert, wie kann das alles sein? Also wir waren ja wirklich fassungslos darüber, wie krass dieser Markt einbricht, dass der Staat da auf hunderte Milliarden Steuereinnahmen verzichtet, einfach nur, weil das Wohnen nicht in Gang kommt. Was ja bedeutet, im Prinzip sind sich alle einig. Es ist Staatsziel, dass Menschen mit 30 Jahren in ein Haus ziehen, das sie sich erst mit 55 leisten können. Und der Mechanismus, der das ermöglicht, heißt Kredit. Und dann kommt das Bundesverfassungsgericht und sagt, ist nicht.
Also China hat es ja so weit getrieben, dass sie einfach Dinge gebaut haben, die schon keiner mehr braucht. Weil sie dachten, damit können wir das BIP hochhalten. Was ja funktioniert im Ganzen dann, bis man dann irgendeine Blase produziert. Aber hier ist eine absolute Notwendigkeit in Deutschland dafür, da das gebaut wird. Alle sind sich einig und man macht es nicht.
Also man muss grundsätzlich neu denken.
Und das ist das Bemerkenswert an diesem Buch. Wir haben jetzt sehr viele Problemfelder, die geschildert werden, aufgerufen. Das ist ja das Bemerkenswerte an diesem Buch, dass es zeigt, wie sich ein Regelwerk bildet und sich dann verselbstständig beziehungsweise als ein Naturgesetz wahrgenommen wird. Und man unterwirft sich ohne Not, also wir sind eben nicht in Liberia, das ist ja die Pointe, man unterwirft sich ohne Not einem solchen Regime, dass man sich selbst geschaffen hat. Also eigentlich ist es ja wie, wenn man anfängt, irgendwelche Zwänge zu entwickeln und dann muss man sich dem irgendwann unterwerfen, aber diese Zwänge sind gar nicht extern, sondern die sind selbst gemacht. Und diese Zwänge hat man sich hier produziert.
Und warum? Ich sag's nochmal, die Pointe will ich euch eintrichtern, weil Carsten Linnemann nicht davon ablassen kann, Marxist zu sein, der glaubt, es gäbe diese Naturgesetze.
Jaja, das ist schon der Verdacht, dass es so sein muss.
So, und jetzt sind wir, glaube ich, an einem guten Punkt. Folgt ja auch nach Bahn und Bildung.
Staatsbilanz.
Na, kurz über die Superreichen nochmal zu sprechen.
Okay.
Denn ich will es so vorstellen, wie sie es auch genannt haben. Ich hab's ja eben schon mal zusammengefasst. Ich find's sehr witzig, dass sie dieses Kapitel metaphorisch mit Nussknackern, Nussdresor, der Eichkater und so weiter. Denn es gibt Tresore. Also das Eichhörnchen muss ich nicht die Nüsse mühsam zusammensammeln. Man könnte auch einfach zum großen Herrscher gehen und sagen, lass mich doch mal an dein Tresor. Mir reicht eine Nuss nicht, ich will 5 Milliarden. Und jetzt sagt sie, 20 Prozent des gesamten Nettovermögens gehört 0,1 Prozent der Bevölkerung. Kann man damit nicht was machen. Und jetzt hast du gesagt, es reicht nicht und wie auch immer. Und ich sag, es muss ja auch nicht komplett reichen. Also ich zahle auch meine Steuern, obwohl jetzt meine 5,80 Euro nicht reichen, sondern es sind einfach alle ihre Steuern und damit reicht es dann schon. Also könnten die nicht auch 5,80 Euro 000 bezahlen. So und dann sagt sie, große Vermögen werden derzeit verschenkt mit homöopathischem Ausmaß besteuert. 0,3 Prozent hat das Netzwerk Steuergerechtigkeit errechnet. Was bedeutet, wenn der Staat hier als stiller Teilhabe an diesen verschenkten Unternehmen beteiligt wird? Also jemand kriegt ein Unternehmen geschenkt und man sagt, nehme ich gerne. Okay, du kriegst aber nur 80 Prozent geschenkt. Die anderen 20 Prozent gehören jetzt dem Staat. Er hat jetzt Stimmrechte. Reicht mir völlig. Also das ist ein Argument, mit dem kann ich absolut das genauso. Und ich will auch niemanden das Vermögen wegnehmen, sondern in dem Moment, wo es die Personenttitelung wechselt, also erbemäßig übergeht, beteiligt sich der Staat. Wenn derjenige, der die 80 Prozent erbt, dann meint, ich will aber nicht, dass der meine Managemententscheidung reinfunkt, dann muss er ihn ausbezahlen. Das bedeutet, der Staat weiß nicht, wann er und ob er Geld bekommt. Aber das ist mir auch egal. Er hat dann Hoheit oder Anteile, Stimmrechte über die Ausrichtung von Unternehmen. Und das ist ja das, was ich will. Das über den Bundeshaushalt, über irgendeine finanzielle Entscheidung. Und wenn der Bundeshaushalt blockiert ist, weil 90 Prozent der Mittel eh gebunden sind und die anderen zehn Prozent einem technopolitischen Pradigma unterliegen, dann machen wir jetzt dieses neue Fass auf und sagen Beteiligung des Staates und zwar überall.
Nur fügt sie auch hinzu, dass das jetzt nicht die Rettung ist. Also das ist nicht das, womit wir am Ende alles finanzieren können. Sie schreibt, würden diese Superreichen besteuert, wie die Vermögen profaner Halbreicher? Könnte das genug Geld bringen, um die Lehrer für Ganztagsschulen zu finanzieren? Auch das schreibt sich leichter, als es ist. Denn entzieht man den Beschenkten zu rabiat das Geld, fehlt am Ende womöglich das Kapital für Unternehmensinvestitionen. Und schon wieder sind Jobs in Gefahr. Was ich hier deutlich machen will, ist, dass also auch das Kapital ein scheues Reh bleibt. Ich finde aber, das hätte sie gar nicht nochmal so hinzufügen müssen, sondern man kann schon mal da ran und sie wie profane Halbreiche zu besteuern. Das ist erstmal ein guter Ausdruck und auch, denke ich, die richtige Sache. Nur ganz nebenbei eine Zahl, die mir auch gar nicht so bewusst war, gehört jetzt nicht hierher, aber wird im Text in einem anderen Kontext genannt, nämlich der Verkaufspreis von Autos. Bei den Chinesen geht er immer weiter runter. Elektro-Kleinstwagen ab 9.000 Euro. Mercedes steigerte den durchschnittlichen Verkaufspreis seiner Autos von 2019 bis 2023 um 46 Prozent. Wie kann denn das sein, dass das hingenommen wird von 2019 bis 2023? Das ist ja nicht lang. Und 46 Prozent?
Also 90 Prozent aller S-Klassen werden von der Mercedes-Benz Bank gekauft und dann über, ich sage es mal in Anführungszeichen, Finanzvehikel an Unternehmen mit Leasingverträgen, die dann steuerlich den Geldwerten Vorteil und so weiter ihre Endnutzer vom Lohn verrechnen und dann gibt es wieder Zuschüsse des Staates kreuz und quer. Das sind halt unglaublich komplizierte finanzielle Strukturierungen.
Sagen wir mal, der typische Kunde, der Privatkunde, der Zahnarzt, wird ja gemerkt haben, die sind aber ganz schön teuer geworden. Wenn das jetzt in vier Jahren einfach mal 46 Prozent teurer ist.
Niemand hat sein Auto cash gekauft, sondern dann eben die staatlichen Finanzierungen. Und die 50 Milliarden Subvention CO2 müssen halt irgendwo herkommen. Die verstecken sich halt irgendwo. Von daher ergibt sich das dann schon.
Sollen wir zur Staatsbilanz?
Staatsbilanz, Kredite, Staatsanleihen, IWF-Bedingungen für Kredite, was du willst. Das Buch ist voll mit tollen Sachen.
Also amerikanische Staatsanleihen sind das beliebteste Finanzprodukt der Welt. Wer hätte das gedacht? Wir können das ja immer sehen. Auch wenn eine Krise ist, selbst wenn eine Krise in den USA ist, dann bleiben die Staatsanleihen beliebt. Nein, sie werden sogar noch beliebter. Und sie beschäftigt sich aber jetzt nicht mit amerikanischen Staatsanleihen zu fördern, sondern vor allem mit Europa, mit den deutschen Anleihen auch. Und sie schreibt da auch über die IWF-Bedingungen. Da heißt es, erstens sollte die Schuldenquote so niedrig sein, dass ein Staat keine Schwierigkeiten hat, seine Anleihen zu verkaufen, also sich zu refinanzieren.
Da hat Deutschland kein Problem, noch nie gehabt.
Richtig. Kann ein Staat keine Anleihen mehr verkaufen, hat er kein Geld mehr und ist zahlungsunfähig. Zweitens sollte die Schuldenquote so niedrig sein, dass die Regierung ihre Zinsen bezahlen kann, ohne radikal sparen oder weitere Schulden dafür aufnehmen zu müssen.
Ja, sie macht hier einen sehr wichtigen Punkt, der immer mal wieder aufkommt. Japan. Japan ist mit 260 Prozent verschuldet, volkswirtschaftlich ungefähr genauso groß wie wir. Nicht so viel Export und sowas wahrscheinlich, dadurch, dass es mehr Japaner als Deutsche gibt. Aber man kann relativ gut vergleichen. Prozentpunkte, Verschuldungsquote am BIP sind so und so viel Euro. Und wenn man jetzt den Unterschied von 60 und 260 Prozent vergleicht, bedeutet das, wenn sich Deutschland wie Japan verschulden wollte, wären so 6 bis 7 Billionen Euro drin. Und dann kann man einfach fragen, warum machen wir das nicht? Japan schadet es doch auch nicht. Und dann kommt immer dieses Argument, das sie auch aufgreift, dass man sagt, ja, aber die Japaner verschulden sich ja an eigener Währung. Und wir haben ja keine Demarkhoheit her, sondern unsere Regeln gelten dann immer für ganz Europa und so weiter und so fort und so. Und sie sagt einfach, vergiss alles. Ja, man kann das direkt miteinander vergleichen. Denn man braucht keine eigene Währung, sondern nur die Zusicherung einer Zentralbank, dass sie die auf dem Markt befindlichen Staatsanleihen eines Landes immer kauft. Und die Zusicherung hat Deutschland.
Und zudem kann sich, schreibt sie, Deutschland noch stärker verschulden als Frankreich oder Italien, eben weil Deutschland so stabil ist. Und wenn Lindner glaubt, dass das AAA-Rating in Gefahr sei, man also dann bald nicht mehr diese hohe Kreditwürdigkeit genießt, dann hält sie dem entgegen. Nein, gerade diese Sparsamkeit könnte dazu führen, dass dieses AAA-Rating in Gefahr gerät. Und das war ja auch kürzlich, ich glaube sogar im Economist zu lesen, dass sich einige Sorgen machen, ob Deutschland sein AAA-Rating aufgrund der Austeritätspolitik verlieren könnte. Und das liegt auch daran, dass man eben nicht diese enge Kopplung von Beliebtheit der Staatsanleihen und der Höhe der Schuldenquote vorfinden kann. Sie beschreibt beispielsweise, wenn ein Land wie die Schweiz Währungsabwertungen vornehmen will und dafür europäische Staatsanleihen kauft, dann guckt sie nicht auf Schuldenquoten oder so, sondern sie hat ein eigenes intrinsisches Anliegen, nämlich Währungsabwertungen. Deswegen werden diese Anleihen gekauft. Dann kurzfristig gesicherte Kredite, also Repos. Dort spielt der Kauf eine Rolle. Sie sind risikofreie Vermögensanlagen.
Also Pflichtanlagen für Banken?
Für Banken, Pflichtanlagen und auch für die größeren Geschäfte, die gemacht werden. Also wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel Milliardenunternehmen verkauft, dann ist ja nicht so, dass man dann einfach eine Milliarde aufs Konto überwiesen bekommt. Sondern das geht dann über Staatsanleihen. Dann gibt es da wieder wieder Absicherung und interessanterweise bei diesen Repos ist es ja so, dass drei Länder da die beliebtesten in Deutschland sind. An erster Stelle bei den Staatsanleihen Deutschland, dann Frankreich und dann schreibt sie an dritter Stelle das Hochschuldenland Italien. Also spielt es da gar keine Rolle. Sonst würden wir sagen Finger weg von Italien. Die haben so viele Schulden und schon, das war mir auch nicht klar, 2018 empfahl der IWF, dass Deutschland mehr Schulden machen soll. Man hat einfach nicht darauf gehört.
Sie kommt im Finanzministerium an 2018, arbeitet jetzt dort mit dieser Weltbank und Liberia Erfahrung und denkt, jetzt bin ich da, 4 Billionen, Bilanzsumme der deutschen Volkswirtschaft, so viel Power, drittgrößte Volksnation, Volkswirtschaft der Welt. Hier kann man mal richtig, hier kommt keiner und fragt, wie viel kann man uns verschulden, weil es unendlich ist. Sie stellt fest, ich wollte gern wissen, wieso in der Wilhelmstraße 97 die Welt so anders aussah, als in den USA, in Großbritannien oder beim IWF. Sie kommt mit dieser Erwartung und trifft auch so eine Behörde, wo einfach alle nur am Sparen sind die ganze Zeit. Der IWF hatte Deutschland im Frühjahr 2018 als erste Empfehlung mitgegeben, seinen reichlich vorhandenen Spielraum innerhalb der Fiskalregeln zur Steigerung des Wachstumspotenzials der Wirtschaft zu nutzen. Spielraum innerhalb der Fiskalregeln nutzen hieß übersetzt Macht mehr Schulden. Sie erlebt aber nichts von diesem Zeitgeist in diesem Haus. Das liest sich besonders driftig, weil dieses Staatseinleihen-Kampittel, das hat Lehrbuchcharakter. Wir hören ja immer von Staatsschulden, Staatsanleihen, wie auch immer, nur weil der Börsenbericht irgendwas dazu sagt, dass das irgendwie verkoppelt ist mit dem Bundeshaushalt. Und die Art und Weise, wie sie das verkoppelt, du hast jetzt schon ein paar Themen genannt, aber man kommt ja nicht, um hinzudenken, was immer, wenn ich mir eine Milch im Supermarkt kaufe, hat das mit der Finanzsie, also hat das mit Staatsanleihen zu tun. Ja, aber ja, alles hängt miteinander zusammen.
Sie bestreitet das in schönster Klarheit.
Ja, und resultiert dann eben, sie sind das Öl, also die Staatsanleihen sind das Öl und das wichtigste Scharnier unseres Geldsystems, das zwischen Zentralbanken und Geschäftsbanken und überall drin hängt. Sie hat, also die Staatsanleihe hat mehr Funktion als ein Schweizer Taschenmesser. Also sie bricht dann sogar noch mal aus und wird so metaphorisch, um uns einfach zu verdeutlichen, lasst euch da nicht veralbern, nur weil Frank Beetman im heutigen Journal irgendwas von, oh die Staatsanleihe und was auch immer gesagt hat. Nein, das ist so als, man findet gar keine Beispiele dafür, wo andernfalls solche Art von Reduktionen stattfinden. Also es ist wirklich sehr gut und damit wirkt dann auch dieses Kapitel. Mit diesem Denken komme ich dann ins Finanzministerium und was ist hier? Sparpolitik, unergründliche Sparpolitik.
Aber diese Angst vor den hohen Zinsen und da sagt sie, naja, dass es zu einer Zinsplage kommen könnte, liegt ja daran, ob die EZB das will, dass es dazu kommt. Sie schreibt, in der Corona-Krise erwarb die EZB Staatsanleihen im Wert von über 1,7 Billionen Euro, was über zehn Prozent der Wirtschaftsleistung der Eurozone entsprach. Sie sorgte so dafür, dass die Eurostaaten ihre Krisenmaßnahmen günstig finanzieren konnten. Wenn die Zentralbank nicht will, dass die staatlichen Finanzierungskosten steigen, passiert das auch nicht.
Ja, und sie sagt es ganz deutlich. Wenn jemand heute kommt und sagt, wir bezahlen zu viele Zinsen für unsere Staatsschulden, wie Lindner und seine Rechentricks, da kommt sie auch nochmal drauf.
Ja, das ist ja schön, wie sie das macht.
Nur frage ich mich eins, wenn die Sorge vor den Zinskosten das zentrale Motiv für eine geringe Verschuldung war, wieso reagierte die Finanzpolitik dann nicht auf die seit der Finanzkrise andauernde Niedrigzinsphase? Man verdiente Geld damit als Staat, wenn man Schulden aufnahm. Es war eine Lizenz zum Geld drucken.
Ja, also man lieh Geld, man gab Staatsanleihen raus.
Man gab 100 Euro raus.
Und hat aber 103 bekommen.
Genau. Oder man hat nur 97 rausgegeben.
Das war ja damals die Argumentation von Adam Tuese, als es darum ging, wer bezahlt dann eigentlich die Impfstoffe für die armen Länder? Und dann sagt er ja, am besten macht das Deutschland, da könnte Deutschland Geld bei verdienen.
Ja, genau. Also es ist eigentlich, umso mehr das Buch fortgeht, umso mehr sitzt man daneben und denkt sich, das kann doch alles gar nicht sein. Wieso diese engen Scheuklappen und überhaupt und wieso diese immer gleichen Argumentationen, die man dann abends in den Tagesthemen bekommt, die wirklich gar kein empirisches Korrelat, sondern nur noch so eine historische Sehgewohnheit sind. Es ist völlig haltlos und so viel zum Thema Fake News und so weiter. Die kämpfen dann groß gegen Fake News und so weiter und Christian Lindner erzählt uns, ne, wir bezahlen aber 30 Milliarden für Zinszahlung.
Es ist eigentlich, vielleicht sollte man das einfach ausdrücken. Ich meine, hier, das klingt immer noch alles so ökonomisch und richtet sich dann vielleicht doch eher wieder an einen kleinen Kreis. Also der Quartrier-Verlag, wo das Buch erschienen ist, sollte einfach noch mal das Buch rausbringen, genau so. Und dann steht da einfach drüber, mein Kampf gegen Fake News. So ist einfach der Titel. Man sagt gar nicht, dass es um Wirtschaft geht. Alle denken, ah, geht wieder um AfD-Trolle bei Twitter. Ne, das ist jetzt hier das Buch gegen Fake News.
Fake Politik des Finanzministers. Die Aufklärung. Okay, Horst Seehofer. Hier im Text folgt nun, also nach Gelddrucken und so weiter der Stadt. Warum zügeln wir uns da so? Das macht doch gar keinen Sinn. Wir haben kein Problem mit Zinsen. Unser Problem sind fehlende Kitas, mangelnde gute Jobs, Autograten und die Erderwärmung. Das sagt sie ausdrücklich und fragt sich danach, wieso kommt es zu dieser Technopolitik Schuldenbremse? Als sie damals diskutiert wurde, hieß es irgendwie, ja, man hat so gesehen, die Länder wie Griechenland und Italien haben sich heillos überschuldet. Davor müssen wir Deutschland schützen. Wir wissen ja nicht, wer als nächstes regiert. Also legen wir sie mal an die Kette. Die Idee ist es, im Grundgesetz zu verankern und gerade noch mal so eine kleine Potentialschätzung zu ermöglichen. Ja, ihr könnt so ein bisschen. Zehn Milliarden dürft ihr mal investieren, aber mehr nicht.
Wir müssen jetzt sagen, wir gehen jetzt erst noch mal in die 90er-Jahre zurück. Also es gibt da einen Tiet Meyer, heißt der. Der ist der Staatssekretär im Finanzministerium. Und der hat aber schon 1982 dieses Lambsdorff-Papier verfasst. Das ist so eine neoliberale Agenda, die Lambsdorff wollte und die dann Kohl zugespielt wurde. Kohl ließ das in der Schublade verschwinden, hat das nicht aufgegriffen. Das Lambsdorff-Papier wurde dann eigentlich 1998 von Rot-Grün umgesetzt. Das ist so das, was wir unter deutschem Neoliberalismus verstehen. Und dieser Mann, der das verfasst hat, der wechselte 1990 zur Bundesbank. Und sein Nachfolger im Finanzministerium, Chefunterhändler für die Währungsunion, wurde dann der spätere Bundespräsident Horst Köhler. Und Köhler hat auch für Lammstorf schon gearbeitet. Also das ist, wir können also sehen, das ist so eine ordoliberale Sichtweise auf die Welt. Und da geht es vor allem um eines, die Begrenzung des Staates. Wie können wir verhindern, dass der Staat zu groß wird und zu mächtig wird und damit ja auch die Demokratie zu mächtig wird? Und da kommen jetzt die 60 Prozent ins Spiel. Sie schreibt, die Schuldenquote dürfte für das ordoliberale Projekt so hilfreich gewesen sein wie das BIP für Roosevelt, der damit in Zahlen fassen konnte, wie fabelhaft sich die US-Industrie unter seiner Präsidentschaft entwickelte. Nun werde kein Finanzminister mehr der Schuldenkontrolle entkommen. Endlich gebe es eine klare Kennzahl, die alle einhalten mussten. Über Europa, so könnte man die Geschichte zu Ende spinnen, war den Ordo-Liberalen gelungen, woran sie in Deutschland bisher gescheitert waren, den ausufernden Staat für immer in die Schranken zu weisen. In den 80er Jahren, auch interessant, wie Paradigmen überhaupt erst entstehen, war von Schuldenquote gar keine Rede.
Nein, niemand hat sich dafür interessiert. Und es ist ja interessant, ich habe es ja im Fernsehpodcast auch immer mal wieder, wenn wir die amerikanischen Nachrichten schauen, da spielt das ja auch keine Rolle. Da spielt der, die Regierung schaltet durch die Nichtanhebung der Schuldengrenze, schaltet sich jetzt aus und alle Verwaltungsbeamten kriegen für 3 Monate kein Lohn oder sowas.
Und dann machen die diesen Kampf und dann am Ende geht es doch wieder weiter.
Aber die Schuldenquote selbst wird dann nie diskutiert. Also ausuferndes Budget, ja, aber Schuldenstand Amerika ist nicht so. Und diese Schuldenquote schleicht sich also über diese Papiere da so ein. Und man will sich dann nicht dagegen erwehren, dass irgendwelche Zahlen irgendwas bedeuten. Und dann fühlt man nur noch so Spezialdiskussionen. Sie kommt ja auf Thomas de Maizière zu sprechen, der dann bei diesen Fragen, die dann im Folge des Paratikmas entstehen, wie zum Beispiel Potentialschätzung der deutschen Wirtschaft, also um wie viel darf man sich dann noch verschulden? Und er fragt, was ist denn so eine wirtschaftliche Normallage, von der aus wir das berechnen? Und dann kriegt er halt irgendwie so zwei Antworten, die aber von Sachverständigen aus der Juristerei und nicht von der Ökonomie kommen. Und sie kann es dann nachlesen in diesen Protokollen auch.
Sie hat auch mit Theo Weigl gesprochen. Also sie hat mit einigen, auch mit Köhler, dem dankt sie auch am Ende noch in ihrem Buch. Sie hat sich mit diesen Leuten ausgetauscht. Und es stellt sich auch heraus, deswegen die Idee, die keiner wollte, dass Köhler gar kein Verfechter dieser 60 Prozent war. Er glaubt jetzt nicht, dass, wenn die überschritten werden, das zum Sündenfall wird. Sondern er dachte, man braucht irgend so eine goldene Regel, die darauf abzielt, dass es nur investive Ausgaben und keine konsumtiven Ausgaben gibt.
Und die Schlussfolger dann auch, also bei diesem europäischen Streit um die Schuldenregeln. Ist eigentlich ganz witzig im Buch, weil sie so auf, also weil sie der Sehgewohnheit nochmal entspricht. Also sie kommt nochmal mit der Geschichte, dass die Schuldenquote auf Drängen der Deutschen eingeführt wurde, ist auch deswegen plausibel, weil sich erst spät im Verhandlungsprozess diskutiert wurde. Es war sozusagen das finale Bonbon an die Deutschen, die die D-Mark aufgeben mussten und denen man dann versprach, wir machen den Euro so hart wie eure D-Mark. Nur, das stimmt halt nicht. Also das lässt sich aus den Protokollen nicht nachlesen. Vielmehr hat halt Frankreich damals diese 3%-Regel erfunden und die Quelle der 60%-Regel ist völlig unklar. Es wurde ewig lange diskutiert. All diese Themen waren mehr so Randthemen, mussten halt auch noch mit in diesem riesigen Katalog der Euro-Einführung mit aufgenommen werden. Man einigte sich also auf einen Wert, für den es keine Begründung gibt, der nicht besonders viel Zustimmung hatte und will eigentlich lieber einen anderen Indikator. So, am Ende gab es eine 7 zu 12-Staaten-Mehrheit für die Schuldenquote von 60%.
Sie schreibt, das Sitzungsprotokoll enthält keine Begründung. Es vermerkt nur, dass man die 60% nicht gewählt habe, weil sie der damalige Durchschnitt in der Europäischen Gemeinschaft waren. Und eigentlich will man auch keine Proto- sondern eine Netto-Schuldenquote. Bei der Netto-Schuldenquote werden die Schulden abgezogen, denen Finanzvermögen gegenübersteht. Man einigt sich also auf einen Wert, für den es keine Begründung gibt.
Ja, und solche Ideen von Stabilitätspakt, also Stabilität und Pakt einfach in einem Wort zusammengebunden, waren so attraktiv, so populär, dass Oskar Lafontaine, das damals als SPD-Parteivorsitzende gleich so als Parteidoktrin und gleich in den Parteitagen mit Aufnahmen dafür geworben hat, in eigenen Reden, die SPD-Finanzminister damals, Hans Eichel und so weiter, waren ganz eifrige Sparer. Also man folgte einfach so im Zeitgeist.
Man hat ja der Kohl dann noch damit unter Druck setzen wollen. Also es ist dann auch interessant, dass also jeder sich das immer zu eigen macht, dieses Modell, um den politischen Gegner unter Druck zu setzen und zu sagen, hier müsst ihr mal sparen. Und das ist ja bis heute so auch in den Landesparlamenten zu beobachten, dass sich der SPD und CDU und auch Grüne zum Teil nichts tun und sich gegenseitig beschweren, dann wenn der andere das nicht tut und versuchen dann mit der Verfassung zu drohen oder was weiß ich. Und die Wirtschaftsweisen, die waren aber auch schon skeptisch, haben immer so sich gefragt, warum eigentlich nicht 70 Prozent?
Oder 50, ja genau. Also es wurde dann in der Peripherie im Vorfeld irgendwie diskutiert, aber so richtig konnte man da nicht ran.
Und jetzt hat man das ja über Europa erst mal auf den Plan gebracht. Und jetzt trickle down, findet hier wirklich statt, geht das zum Bund über und dann in die Länder. Und hier kommt so langsam unser Horst Seehofer ins Spiel.
Die Euro-Einführung um die 2000er-Wende, Maastricht-Vertrag und so, hat für Deutschland ja eine europäische Schuldenbremse bedeutet. Also Deutschland schwappt ja dann auch, hat ja auch so blaue Briefe und so ein Kram bekommen. Und alle fragten sich so, warum, was soll das jetzt und so. Ich weiß auch noch, wie das so im Fernsehen dann... Es kam jetzt ein blauer Brief, was bedeutet das? Und dann so ein Börsenbericht irgendwie zum Thema, was das bedeutet. Völlig unklar. Aber man brauchte dann für Deutschland eine Krise. Lehman pleite 2008. Und damit war die Schuldenbremse auch in Deutschland plötzlich Thema. Die Haushaltspolitiker der Union schreibt, sie sahen ihre Chance. Sie machten die Einführung der Schuldenbremse zur Bedingung für ihre Zustimmung zu einem zweiten Konjunkturpaket. Also 2009 wurde das dann alles diskutiert. Die Föderalismuskommission tagte und damit kam ja dann die Schuldenbremse ins Grundgesetz. Das heißt, sie gilt auch in den Ländern. Und dann nennt sie, obwohl sie das Kapitel beginnt, mit eine Idee, die keiner hatte. Ja, weil die Idee dann da war, gab es zumindest einen Verfechter. Horst Seehofer war weder zu Konzertiedelungshilfen bereit, noch wollte er irgendeine strukturelle Verschuldungsmöglichkeit in der Schuldenbremse der Länder zulassen. Der Bund hatte vorgeschlagen, 0,5 Prozent strukturelle Neuverschuldung zwischen Bund und Ländern aufzuteilen und ging mit 0,35 Prozent für sich und 0,15 Prozent für die Länder in die Verhandlung, um am Ende sicher bei 0,25 Prozent zu landen. Seehofer wollte aber gar keinen Verschuldungsspielraum. Warum?
Und da heißt es, er bekam seinen Willen. Die finanzschwachen Länder ihre Konsolidierungshilfen. Dem Bund blieben die 0,35 Prozent, mit denen er die Verhandlung eröffnet hatte. Verhandelt wurde nicht aus ökonomischer Überzeugung heraus, sondern um Siege einzufahren. Aus einer singulären Position Bayerns wurde eine Position aller verkündete ein übernächtigter Seehofer am Morgen nach der Verhandlung. Sein Sieg sollte zukünftig die Finanzpolitik Deutschlands bestimmen. Weil Bayern eh diese Probleme der anderen Länder nicht hat, hat Bayern das aufgedrückt.
Nicht mehr hat.
Nicht mehr hat, wie Deutschland, Europa seine Regeln aufdrückt. Also es ist interessant, dass immer der Mächtigste am Ende die Regeln aufdrückt und ist dann tonangem. Und alle bayerischen Minister, die wir ja so hatten, lieben es ja, Bayern was zuzuschustern. Man sieht Andy Schäuher. Und sie lieben es, dass sie alle anderen Ministerpräsidenten an der kurzen oder langen Leine herumführen können. Und dass sie am Ende immer die Tonangeben ist. Und aus dieser reinen Frackigkeit, aus dieser Machtgetriebenheit heraus, haben wir jetzt ein solches Desaster.
Ja, die Länder haben zwei Möglichkeiten, sich zu verschulden. Entweder das Ausland, also die anderen Bundesländer, oder halt Verschuldung. Und Bayern tobt seit 20 Jahren rum und erzählt uns was vom unfairen Länderfinanzausgleich. Sie haben aber den anderen Spielraum den Ländern eben genommen.
Und deswegen will ich das nochmal, was ich eben sagte, stark machen. Ja, die Milliardäre sind ein Problem. Aber was ein einzelner Horst Seehofer anrichten kann, das schaffen natürlich 50 Milliardäre nicht.
Das stimmt. Und nicht nur Horst Seehofer wird hier genannt, sondern auch Olaf Scholz.
Oh ja.
Ich dachte ja immer, Olaf Scholz, bescheuertste Rede ist die letzte als Finanzminister. Als er nochmal sagte, die Demografie, es war alles falsch, wir müssen nur ein paar mehr Frauen in den Arbeitsmarkt kriegen, dann geht das schon. Und ausgeblendet hat er, dass die AfD damals schon größte Fraktion in der Opposition war und dass wir Migration dringend brauchen, da die Geburten nicht reichen. Heute sehen wir, egal was tatsächlich wichtig ist, nichts ist den Deutschen wichtiger, als das weiterhin auszublenden und eine ewig dumme rassistische Migrationspolitik durchzudiskutieren. Es ist nicht nur die letzte Rede des Finanzministers Olaf Scholz, sondern es war auch die allererste Rede des Olaf Scholz als Finanzminister, die hier wirklich zu Problemen führt. Denn er löst Schäuble ab, die SPD erobert das Finanzministerium und sie schreibt, Olaf Scholz brauchte nur 36 Sekunden, um in seiner ersten Haushaltspressekonferenz klarzumachen, dass es weitergehen sollte wie bisher. Man würde im kommenden Jahr keine neuen Schulden machen und habe sich auch vorgenommen, bis 2022 keine neuen Schulden zu machen. Ja, es ist ungeheuerlich. Es ist unglaublicher.
Ganz kurzer Hinweis noch. Gregor Gysi war ja dann sehr hellsichtig. Der hat 2009 im Bundestag zu der Schuldenbremse gesprochen und sagte, ich sehe schon jetzt den tapferen Sozialdemokraten vor mir, der hier in ein paar Jahren stehen und sagen wird, 2009 haben wir einen großen Fehler begangen. Dieser tapfere Sozialdemokrat wird dann genauso viel Beifall bekommen wie heute der, der den Fehler begeht. Das ist das Übel daran. Noch schlimmer ist aber, dann wird ihnen die Union und damit die zwei Drittel Mehrheit fehlen, das Ganze zu korrigieren. Dann leiden die Bürgerinnen und Bürger wirklich darunter. Und was wir ja jetzt sehen können, was 2009 Gysi noch nicht ahnen könnte, ist ja, dass wenn die nächste Bundestagswahl kommt, wir zwar die Konstellation wahrscheinlich haben, dass auch die Union von der Schuldenbremse wird ablassen wollen, wenn sie zumindest reformieren wollen. Die SPD sowieso, die Grünen auch. Aber mit BSW und AfD Ist die Zweidrittelmehrheit nicht mehr da? Ist die Zweidrittelmehrheit wahrscheinlich nicht mehr da.
Aber darauf kann man gleich zu sprechen.
Ob das BSW sich dazu überreden lässt, wo wir hier nochmal von Tens Rolle geschildert bekommen, dem zuzustimmen. Auf Landesebene kann das möglich sein, auf Bundesebene kann ich es mir kaum vorstellen. Eigentlich müsste man jetzt sagen, bis Weihnachten muss das noch geklärt werden, damit das schon mal sicher ist. Also wenn es die ganze Zeit um die Resilienz der Demokratie geht, dann vielleicht nicht die ganze Zeit gucken, welche russischen Trolle kommen, sondern die Resilienz würde hergestellt werden, indem man jetzt nochmal die demokratischen Mehrheiten sammelt, um das zu tun. Das wäre eigentlich jetzt das, was angebracht wäre.
Sie macht ja gleich Vorschläge mit einer Änderung oder auch ohne Änderung.
Da kenne ich mich natürlich in der Sache zu wenig aus, ob das am Ende wieder von Karlsruhe kassiert werden kann.
Aber vorher nochmal zu diesem Punkt. Du hast jetzt Gisis Zitat von damals vorgelesen. Ich finde es ja ein bisschen schade, dass sie nicht die Chance nochmal genutzt hat, die damals nicht oppositionellen Protagonisten nochmal zu nennen. Denn auch Norbert Lammert hat als Bundestagspräsident der Schuldenbremsen-Tagung davor gewarnt, und der damalige Finanzminister, Per Steinbrück, warnt heute oder sagt heute, das war eigentlich ein Fehler. Und diese beiden Stimmen scheinen mir sehr relevant zu sein. Die sollten eigentlich überall platziert werden. Die fehlen sozusagen jetzt hier im Text. Aber dafür haben wir ja ein gutes...
Es war ja auch nicht damals einfach so eine Entscheidung von Union und SPD. Also auch Grüne haben ja auch dafür gestimmt.
Die Grüne haben auch dafür gestimmt, genau. So, die Wirtschafts-Nutzleistung. Also wir könnten grundsätzlich... Also klar, wir verrechnen das, was wir volkswirtschaftlich tun in Euro. Das ist die Einheit. Aber was verrechnen wir? Das kann man neu beobachten. So wie man den Warenkorb bei der Inflationsrechnung umbaut oder was auch immer. Also wir haben ja sozusagen auf der eigentlich ungewöhnlichen Seite der Gleichung Handlungsmöglichkeiten. Denn sie sagt, statt nur das BIP zu begutachten, kann man ja auch eine Wirtschafts-Nutzleistung definieren, die also nach konkretem Nutzen fragt. Sie fragt nicht, wie viele Endprodukte eine Wirtschaft in der Lage ist herzustellen, sondern wie viel der Wirtschaftskreislauf an dem abwirft, das wir brauchen. Erziehung, Bildung, Pflege, gute Löhne und Renten. Wir hätten dann so einen Fokus auf die, das fände ich interessant, personalintensiven Arbeiten. Die nicht gut automatisierbar sind, also die sich auch so einer ganzen neuen KI-Paradigma, alle sind ganz hyped bei LinkedIn und fragen sich, was bedeutet das jetzt für das BIP und mein betriebswirtschaftliches Auskommen und so weiter. Man könnte hier grundsätzlich mal den Fokus wieder auf Menschen lenken, statt auf Renditen. Finde ich mal nicht verkehrt.
Sie hat ja auch diese 18-Euro-Stundenlohn, würde ja bedeuten, also das fordert sie jetzt Mindestlohn. Das wäre ein Jahresgehalt von 37.000 Euro. Und derzeit ist es so, dass weniger als 50 Prozent der Beschäftigten in Deutschland mindestens so viel verdienen. Folglich wäre das also eine große Aufwertung der Hälfte der Bevölkerung. Jetzt muss man sagen, diese Mindestlohn-Kommission sieht ja gar nicht vor, dass der Staat sich derart einmischen kann. Ich glaube aber, dass das genau der richtige Ansatz ist, an der großen Stellschraube Mindestlohn zu drehen. Ich würde da auch Scott Galloway zustimmen, der sagt, ja die Gewerkschaften können sehr viel machen, oder er ist ja viel gewerkschaftsskeptischer, das bin ich ja gar nicht. Aber dass man noch mal dieses große Rad drehen kann. Und dazu muss ich dann wiederum alles verhalten. Also ich finde eigentlich ist dieses Instrument Mindestlohn viel interessanter, um auch wirkliche Massen zu mobilisieren. Also wenn man sagt, so der Hälfte der Beschäftigten in Deutschland soll es deutlich besser gehen, dann denkt man so die Hälfte? Ah, das ist ja interessant. Und wir haben es ja dann in so Landkreisen, wo war das Sonneberg oder was gehört, wo 44 Prozent unter 14 Euro arbeiten. Ja, dann kann man sich ja ausdenken, was dadurch passieren könnte. Und was jetzt will, ist ja, dass nicht nur dadurch, die Leute mehr Geld haben, sondern dass auch diese Arbeit aufgewertet wird. Und Nutzleistung, sagt sie, da geht es nicht um einen Stapel Autos, oder auch nicht Kartoffeln, sondern es soll ja eigentlich die Geldströme dahin delegieren, wo sie gebraucht werden.
Du hast jetzt Scott Galloway gesagt, ich finde das auch ein ganz interessanten Punkt, weil ich würde jetzt auch nicht sagen, dass er irgendwie so gewerkschaftsfreundlich oder was auch immer ist. Nur wenn man gerne auf Stabilität, Investitionserwartungsabsicherung und so weiter abstellt, kommt man nicht mehr umhin. Gerade jetzt, wenn wir in Amerika sehen, dass da ganze Häfen einfach plattgemacht werden von den Gewerkschaften oder im Gegenstandpunkt ist ja auch der eine Text über den Erfolg bei den Autobranchen und so, was die Gewerkschaften dann doch schaffen, dass das zu relativ viel Turbulenzen führt im gesamtwirtschaftlichen Ablauf, der auch für die Kapitalseite nicht gut ist. Weshalb man dann einfach sagt, können wir denen nicht einfach 25 Euro zahlen und gut? Das finde ich eigentlich auch nicht verkehrt, dass man sozusagen gewerkschaftliche Arbeit unter, nee, das ist einfach Stress und Chaos im System, so dass die daneben stehen und sagen, kann ich einfach einen Blakoscheck schreiben? Jeder 25 Euro und gut, ja, können wir machen.
Naja, du weißt natürlich, dass das so eine Dominofunktion haben könnte. Also sobald die dann nur noch leise mitstreikt und gibt sofort eine Riesenlohnerhöhung, das ist ja immer was der Austere.
Da hat diese Gefahr sich nun mal nicht, aber...
Naja, gut, das ist ja dann gegeben. Also wenn ich...
Ich glaube, die werden immer viel Lärm machen müssen. Ein leiser Lärm und schon gibt es, glaube ich, nicht...
Das ist mit Sicherheit so, ja. Also es war in jeder Hinsicht ineffizient, wie das bei der Deutschen Bahn gelaufen ist, dass man das so gegen die Wand fahren lassen und solche Megastreiks produziert hat. Das hätte man natürlich mit Geld kostengünstiger regeln können.
Sie hat ja einen Fun-Fact in diesem Text, den sie zweimal nennt, weil sie es selber nicht glauben kann. Du hast jetzt das mit der Bahn, also sowas zum Beispiel, dass ein Streik volkswirtschaftlich hundertmal teurer ist als der Nutzen für die Belegschaft von der staatlich organisierten Betrieb Bahn in hundertprozentiger Eignerschaft einfach mal sagen würde, ja okay, so.
Kriegen jetzt so viele Euro mehr.
Volkswirtschaftlich macht das einfach Sinn, wir geben jetzt nach. Wir verlieren jetzt unser Gesicht kurz, wir geben nach. Sie nennt ja über diesen Schuldenbremsen-Diskussion den Autobahnbau Nürnberg-München. Den hätte man einfach staatlich organisieren können. Und sie hat ja dann ihre Liste. Eine Milliarde sind 60 Kilometer Autobahn. Man hätte also einfach durchrechnen können, München, Nürnberg sind so und so viele Kilometer. Also das Land sagt, okay Budget genehmigt. Stattdessen sagt das Land, nein, wir dürfen uns ja nicht verschulden. Aber die Autobahngesellschaft, die das für uns baut, die eigentlich wir sind, die darf sich verschulden. Diese ist aber nicht der Staat oder das Land, sondern die tritt selber als, wir müssen hier schon Sicherheiten bringen, auf dem Finanzmarkt auf und verschuldet sich dort. Was bedeutet, für die gelten einfach die regulären Zinssätze. Was bedeutet, dass nicht nur der Kilometer oder die 60 Kilometer Autobahn eine Milliarde kosten, sondern die 60 Kilometer kosten eine Milliarde Euro plus noch mal eine Milliarde Euro Finanzierung. Das ist einfach so absurd. Man kann es nicht glauben.
Ja, und das, was du jetzt für die Autobahnen beschrieben hast, gilt ja auch für das private Bauen. Die Privatleute sind auf die Marktzinsen angewiesen und können sich dem nicht erwehren. Würde der Staat genau da einschreiten, und das war ja mal von Guy Witz angedacht, aber dann wieder so klein nur, dass es überhaupt nicht fruchtete. Das waren ja dann so Konstruktionen, dass der Staat auch Kredite mitvergibt oder Teile davon. Aber dann musste man eine Familie sein mit drei Kindern und noch zwei Elefanten im Keller. Und dann machen sie es.
Aber auch nur für zehn Jahre und auch nur nach Windhund-Prinzip.
Jaja, aber statt da einfach so reinzugehen und zu sagen, wir können das ja günstig aufnehmen, wir müssen uns darum nicht scheren, und dann wird wenigstens was gebaut. Es ist, wenn man das liest, also diese groteske Situation, in der man sich befindet. Und ich versuche immer ein Beispiel noch heranzuziehen, um das mir selbst klarzumachen. Ich finde keins, weil es wirklich beispiellos ist. Also wir kennen immer das Problem, wenn man Knappheiten hat und wie man damit umgeht. Und dafür finden wir auch tausende Beispiele. Aber dass man eine Selbstbeschränkung vornimmt, wo eigentlich es nicht knapp sein müsste, dafür fällt mir nichts ein.
Das ist ein bisschen so, als würde Rewe hier einfach sagen, unser Supermarkt ist ein Museum. Das sind alles Exponate, die sind unverkäuflich. Aber wir stellen euch noch ein Automat hin, wo ihr Cola-Dosen kaufen könnt. Das ist unser Angebot. Man geht in diesen Supermarkt und fragt sich, warum kann ich das hier nicht kaufen? Muss das jetzt hier verschimmeln? Und der deutsche Staat so, ja, das muss jetzt hier verschimmeln. Das ist wirklich grotesk und man kann es sich kaum vorstellen. Sie macht sich auch sehr darüber lustig, wie im Finanzministerium jeden Tag 50 kleine Dinge geschrieben werden. Und das ist jetzt die große Offensive der Regierung, die Investitionsoffensive. Und dann erklärt Habeck Stolz, wir haben jetzt ein 50-Punkte-Programm. Ich subsumiere es unter Kinderklima irgendwas und so. Und alle fragen sich, aber könnt ihr nicht einfach mal den großen Hebel umlegen? Warum legt ihr nicht den großen Hebel um? Soll ich jetzt die 50 Dinge selber lesen? Sollen wir die Klo zusammenfassen?
Ich habe das ja gelesen. Absurd. Das sind irgendwelche Kleinigkeiten. Manche mögen davon sinnvoll sein, aber das kann doch niemals bedeuten, dass sich da groß was ändert. Und nun ist es ja so, dass sie beschreibt, dass diese Schuldenbremse sich also verselbständigt hat, dass diese anderen Schuldenregeln als mathematische Gesetze inzwischen von allen, ob Opposition oder Regierung, angenommen werden, dass man plötzlich diese erfundenen Zahlen so als Parameter ansetzt, um wirkliche Prognosen zu machen, um das ganze Handeln danach auszurichten, dass man sich die Hände gebunden hat, was dann am Ende dazu führt, dass man Vollzeit nicht realisieren kann, Frauen nicht mehr Erwerbsarbeit zugestehen kann, weil man aufgrund von irgendeinem willkürlichen Kriterium meint, sagen zu können, dass das ein schlechter Effekt für die Wirtschaft sei. Und jetzt meint sie ja auch, das fand ich noch ganz bemerkenswert, weil wir das dann doch manchmal nicht so auf dem Schirm haben, dass in Deutschland wohl die Schuldenbremse noch reformiert werden könnte bald. Das wird sich ja zeigen. In Europa aber, sagt sie, wird es schlimmer. Nämlich, es sieht in Deutschland so aus, als sei der fieberhafte Ausbau des technopolitischen Apparats vorbei. Europa dagegen baut seinen technopolitischen Apparat mit Werbe weiter aus. Und das mit wesentlich modernerer Technologie als Deutschland. Hierzulande soll eine Schuldenbremse mit mehr oder weniger zufälliger Defizitbegrenzung, aus der dann auch noch dies und das herausgerechnet wird, eine Schuldenquote von 60 Prozent des BIPs sicherstellen. Nicht so in Europa. 2022 schlug die Europäische Kommission vor, für alle EU-Staaten individualisierte Vorgaben für den Abbau der Schuldenquote zu berechnen. Der IWF hatte in den Nullerjahren einen Apparat dafür entwickelt. Eine große Excel-Tabelle, die mit Zahlen zu Wachstumzinsen, Haushaltssaldo und Inflation gefüttert, die Entwicklung der Schuldenquote berechnet. Erfunden wurden diese sogenannten Schuldentragfähigkeitsanalysen, um die Kreditvergabe des IWF zu de-politisieren. Das wird sich jetzt in der EU ausbreiten. Das heißt, da wird jetzt noch mehr Ländern, die ohnehin eine unglaubliche Jugendarbeitslosigkeit haben, die Hände gebunden haben.
Nun ist ja so. Diese Berechnung, sie nennt das ja demokratische Schuldenregel, dass man im Grundgesetz ja recht harte Formulierungen vorfindet, aber dann in den Gesetzen, die es im Einzelnen regeln, wie also diese Normallage beschrieben wird und so. Sie sieht da Spielraum, das ist ja auch nicht nur in diesem Buch, sondern es ist ja auch sozusagen Gründungsgedanke, dieses Dezernat Zukunft, dass man sagt, in der Bundesbank gibt es so und so viele Dezernate, aber kein Dezernat Zukunft. Also gründen wir das sozusagen außerhalb der Bundesbank und sagen, da arbeiten ja jetzt auch irgendwie 15 Leute oder so. Die Webseite ist ja voller Köpfe, die da irgendwie arbeiten. Clemens Fußt sagte hier, also damals, die Schuldenregel war ja, könnte man ja so auf Zeit, ist nicht für die Ewigkeit gedacht, wie auch immer, also 2007 gesagt. Heute als IFO-Chef, wir haben ihn ja zuletzt gehört im Podcast, das ist ja in Stein gemeißelt. Also bevor hier irgendwer irgendwas, soll ja erstmal die Bürokratie aus dem Weg gehen, das private Geld und so. Also das ist nichts mehr zu holen.
Und das private Geld, schreibt sie ja im Übrigen, wenn ich das gerade anführen kann, investiert ja kaum. Das private Geld hat sich ja einfach auf die Finanzmärkte zurückgezogen. Da macht man seine Renditen. Genau.
Man kennt diese Brücke gar nicht zur Realwirtschaft. Und wenn, dann sieht man nur in Frankfurt, ja, die machen halt so eine Olympiade unter Gastronomie oder sowas.
Aber sonst kann man ja sein Geld irgendwo anlegen. Also wenn jetzt die, die auch ganz viel in ETF und so weiter reingehen, das hilft ja jetzt der deutschen Volkswirtschaft nicht.
Genau. Und deswegen finde ich dieses Buch am Ende, das ist meine Kritik, es passt nicht ganz zum Anfang, denn sie steigt ja historisch ein. Sie beschreibt uns eine empirische Problemlage in Liberia. Und sie kommt dann, wie die Welt darauf reagiert, was der IWF macht, hier haut doch mal das Geld raus und so weiter. Und ich hätte mir gewünscht, dass das Buch am Ende, also sie hat ein sehr gutes Finale geschrieben, das lohnt sich auch fast vorzulesen. Sie hat als Kind gerne Dr. Noh geguckt. Alles Schlimme in der Welt war immer das Werk von Bösewichten. Und dann habe ich festgestellt, nee, es ist viel profaner. Da greifen so Logiken, Historien, Geschichte, Gedächtnisse von Unternehmen und Finanzministerien, da kommt man da so rein und die haben einen völlig falschen Zeitgeist. Und man fragt sich, wenn ich jetzt das ganze Personal hier austausche, habe ich eine Chance, einfach mit demselben Apparat was ganz anderes zu machen. Also hätte sich so ein Ideenapparat eingeschlichen. Und ich finde, wir sind doch jetzt in so einer Zeit, in der wir beobachten. Und wir haben es ja im Podcast auch schon so ein bisschen mitreflektiert. Systemstreit Amerika gegen China. Also Amerika hat die Schlüsseltechnologien. China möchte sie. Deutschland verliert gerade alles. Automobilindustrie ist ja nur sozusagen der größte Aufhänger. Und selbst in Amerika haben wir dann Spezialdiskussionen zwischen, wenn Donald Trump gewählt wird, macht er einfach, also nimmt den Staat völlig raus und sagt, ich erhebe gar keine Steuern mehr. Wir regeln alles über Verschuldung. Wenn Harris gewinnt und den Apparat von Biden übernimmt, heißt das, die Präsidentschaft beginnt damit, dass wie Biden in der ersten Woche gesagt wird, wir haben Konjunkturprogramm, Größenordnung 5 Billionen Dollar. CHPT verbraucht gerade pro Jahr für 5 Milliarden Euro Strom. 5 Milliarden Dollar. Das Unternehmen hat nur einen Umsatz von 3,5 Milliarden. Also ökonomisch macht nichts Sinn und es verändert die ganze Welt. Also dieser Unsinn verändert die ganze Welt. Und dieser Drang Europas jetzt zu sagen, ne, wir haben aber Sinn, denn wir haben ja Regeln und die halten wir jetzt ein und so, das gerät einfach unter Druck. Also florisch gesehen.
Wie sie schreibt, diese ungefähre Vernunft, die man da glaubt, zu haben, führt in den präzisen Irrsinn, wie sie sich ausdrückt.
Genau, sehr gut. Und das hätte ich mir noch mal richtig gerne ausgearbeitet. Also dass der Druck einfach zu hoch ist. Es macht keinen Sinn, in zehn Jahren in Deutschland da zu stehen und zu sagen, ja, wir dachten zuerst, es reicht, dem EU-Land Österreich Sanktionen zu geben, weil dort die FPÖ mitregiert. Jetzt ist die FPÖ schon die größte Fraktion. Es regt niemanden mehr auf. Aber wir kriegen sie noch mal aus der Rauskalle. Also die Tendenzen sind alle ganz klar. In zehn Jahren oder sagen wir mal in 15 Jahren, also wenn das Jahr 2029 1,4 Millionen Menschen gehen in Rente, aber nur 700.000 werden volljährig und treten in den Arbeitsmarkt ein. Zehn Jahre nach diesem Zeitpunkt, wo dieses eine Jahr 2029 auch nur ein Jahr von vielen ist, ist das alles so verändert, dass wir, wenn wir weitermachen wie bisher, einfach mit einer 45%igen, ja die AfD hat schon mal regiert und es nicht zu schlecht gemacht. Jetzt haben wir halt die Grenzen zugemacht und in Deutschland leben nur noch 65 Millionen Menschen oder so. Das ist doch eine echte Bedrohung, die wirklich ganz realistisch ist. Wenn man jetzt hier nicht diesen großen Hebel umlegt.
Ja, die Dystopie ist ja auch für viele schon spürbar, jetzt nicht nur in Bezug auf die AfD, sondern wie sie durch ihr Leben sich schleppen müssen, unter welchen Umständen sie zu leiden haben, die zu regeln werden. Und das ist für mich diese tolle Pointe, dass sie mit Liberia beginnt und damit auch endet. Und sie sagt dann ganz klar, während sich Liberia tatsächlich die Straßen nicht leisten kann, haben wir entschieden, uns die Schulen und Schienen nicht leisten zu wollen. Sie macht hier nochmal diesen Unterschied auf, der manchmal von MMT-Leuten ja geleugnet wird. Naja, dass MMT so gut funktioniert, gilt auch nur für Länder, die sehr viel Geld haben, die tolle Volkswirtschaften haben. Sie schreibt, während Liberia den Gezeiten der Weltwirtschaft ausgeliefert ist, hat sich Deutschland der zufällig zustande gekommenen 60%-Schuldenquote ausgeliefert. Sie ist die gefährlichste Idee, die nie einer hatte. Diese Selbstauslieferung, das ist für mich so eine schwer zu erkundende Ideologie, weil man immer... Das ist ganz schrecklich. Ja, weil man alles andere kann man immer so... Ich kann also, ich kann sofort, wenn ich das Buch von Julia Friedrichs lese, mich reindenken in so einen super Reichen, warum der so agiert. Das fällt mir jetzt nicht schwer. Das finde ich dann immer noch schlimm, dass der das tut oder blöde oder doof. Aber ich kann es ganz leicht verstehen. Aber diese Selbstauslieferung, wo man auch schon die Gefahr ja ganz klar vor Augen hat. Wir sind ja jetzt auch hier nicht gerade mit Beschluss der Schuldenbremse da, dass man noch nicht weiß, wohin die Reise geht. Aber dass man zum Beispiel weiß, 2015, das bringt sich auch nochmal sehr deutlich, kommt Merkel zu dem Entschluss, dass wir den Menschen helfen müssen und nehmen diese Flüchtlinge auf. Und gleichzeitig macht Schäuble dann mit Merkel eine Austeritätspolitik, die sagt, so, jetzt wird aber mal richtig gespart. Also wo die Bedarfe größer werden, sagt man, jetzt wird aber mal richtig gespart. Also man kann es ja auch mal wieder auf die eigene Familie ziehen. Man hat plötzlich Nachwuchs bekommen und würde dann vom Arbeitgeber gesagt bekommen, ah, sie haben Nachwuchs bekommen. Deswegen bekommen sie ab sofort 500 Euro weniger Lohn im Monat, weil sie ja Nachwuchs bekommen. Dann denkt man, die Bedarfe sind ja eher größer geworden. Jetzt bräuchte man eine Lohnerhöhung. Und dass das präsent ist. Und ich meine, wir haben jetzt so viele Krisen. Und wenn ich jetzt diese Podcast mir anhöre über das, was im Libanon los ist, man müsste eigentlich jetzt sagen, wir müssen sofort mindestens 100.000 Leute aus dem Libanon aufnehmen. Vermutlich mehr. Und das wird nicht geschehen aus anderen politischen Gründen auch dann leider noch. Aber dass man in dieser Lage weiter daran festhalten kann und dass das nicht jeden Tag das einzige Thema eigentlich in den Medien sein sollte, ist mir alles nicht mehr begreiflich.
Ja, wir haben aus dem Text gelesen, den diese wahren Grünen da geschrieben hatten, warum sie ihre Partei verlassen. Und da stand ja was mit die echten Probleme, die eigentlichen Sorgen, der normale Mensch, die Superreichen und so. Man könnte eigentlich, das Finale ihres Textes, und ich meine jetzt wirklich ganz konkret, die allerletzten Sätze, die sie hier nennen, die müssen eigentlich jetzt in jeder Ich steige hier aus Erklärung drinstehen.
Ja, ich steige hier aus.
Wie zum Beispiel diese Grünen, die einfach sagen, keine Ahnung, ich bin 1992 geboren, manche sind ja jünger, die können das dann auch auf sich münzen. Sie schreibt, seit 1992 sind unsere Geldflüsse verkrustet. Die Politik ist versteinert. Das Geld dient nicht mehr der Gesellschaft, sondern ist zum Selbstzweck geworden. Wenn es eine Zeit gibt, das zu ändern, dann heute. Gutes Geld ist keine Unmöglichkeit, sondern eine Frage des politischen Willens. Und jetzt ist nur die Frage, wer zeigt den politischen Willen? Robert Habeck zeigt ihn nicht. Also der zeigt den persönlichen Willen. Der denkt sich einfach, ich habe es jetzt so weit geschafft, vielleicht gibt es ja doch noch die Chance, Kanzler zu werden. Diese jungen Grünen, die sagen sich einfach, ich habe politischen Willen. Wofür? Für den großen Hebel. Für alles einfach. Für diese Leute ist jetzt dieses Buch gemacht. Und zwar so geschrieben, dass man es einfach der Oma zeigt. Und die Hoffnung da sein kann, dass auch die Oma sich fragt, was? Das verstehe ich nicht.
Also besser kann man diese Zusammenhänge nicht erklären. Da bin ich mir ganz sicher. Mit Gutes Geld legt die Ökonomin Philippa Sigl-Glöckner ein wichtiges Buch vor, das uns zeigt, dass wir eigentlich in einer Welt aus Fake News leben. Und zwar, was das Ökonomische anbelangt. Sie setzt sich auseinander mit den Schuldenregeln, mit der Schuldenquote und fragt sich, woher kommen eigentlich diese Regeln? Wer hat sie damals in Gang gesetzt? Und sind es vielleicht doch eher willkürliche Annahmen, die man dann später zu Gesetzmäßigkeiten erklärt hat, ohne dass es dafür eine sachliche Grundlage gibt? Dieses Buch ist wahnsinnig erhellend. Es zeigt, was möglich wäre. Es zeigt, wie sehr der Staat zu einem ungeheuer verkrusteten Apparat verkommen ist. Und dieses Buch ist die Lektüre tatsächlich wert, weil wir so viel Contra-Intuitives auch präsentiert bekommen.
Ganz genau, in dieser irrsinnigen Welt, in der Marx als Schimpfwort gilt, rufen wir als Leser hier Eingrosen, den Marxisten unserer Zeit aus. Und es ist, oh Wunder, Carsten Linnemann. Man kommt aus dem Staunen nicht raus. Dieses Buch sprudelt vor Ideen. Man ist ganz inspiriert. Und diese Marxismus-Idee ist nur eine von 17 Pointen pro Seite. In der Hinsicht, selten habe ich mich so wohl gefühlt mit einem Buch, ein wahres Spektakel.
Und wir werden erfahren, welch unselige Rolle Horst Seehofer wieder einmal gespielt hat. Es ist wirklich, wie würden die US-Demokraten sagen, weird, wenn wir das hier nachlesen. Und wir diskutieren es ausführlich im Neuen Salon der Neuen Zwanziger. Weißt du, was ein Requiem ist?
Ja, natürlich.
Was denn?
Ein Musik, ein Superhit von Mozart. Ein Todesgesang.
Es gibt ein Requiem von Mozart, das ja unverlendet geblieben ist. Es ist eine Totenmesse. Es ist die letzte Messe in dem Sinne. Und es gibt sehr verschiedene von großen Komponisten. Und das Requiem als besondere Messe ist natürlich auch etwas, was man ausweiten könnte darauf, dass die Welt im Ganzen oder die Menschheit untergeht. Wir haben diese apokalyptischen Diskurse. Und die Literatur ist doch ein wunderbarer Ort, um das einmal direkt aufzugreifen und selbst ein Requiem zu verfassen. Auf dem Buch steht nur Requiem. Der Autor ist Alexander Schnickmann. Aber der Verlag hat in der Ankündigung geschrieben, es handele sich um einen Roman. Ich würde auch sagen, ja, man kann es Roman nennen. Es ist ein Roman in Versform. Ein Roman deshalb, weil wir es mit einem Ich-Erzähler oder einem lyrischen Ich zu tun haben, das etwas erlebt, das handelt, das mal da, mal dort ist. Und es gibt auch einen Schluss, es gibt einen Anfang. Es wird etwas erzählt, also aber in Versen. Du hast ja mal vor einer Weile ein Buch vorgestellt von Michel Friedman. Auch das war nicht ein Gedicht, sondern das war ein Buch, das in Versen verfasst ist, sich befragt und die Gesellschaft befragt. So kann man wohl sagen.
Genau, man musste es lesen. Es war überraschend, ich war ja bei der Lesung, bei der Peter Schröder gelesen hatte. Also das Buch Fremd, um das geht es. Und aus dem Lesen selbst hat man noch nicht gesehen, wie es geschrieben ist. Also man musste es wirklich einmal sehen. Ich war dann auch ganz überrascht, weil zuweilen besteht es doch seitenweise nur aus einem Wort pro Zeile. Aber er hat sich selber in Gesprächen, ich habe ihn in der Literatur aus dem Jahr und überall gesehen, nicht festgelegt, ob das jetzt Verse sind oder ein Roman oder wie auch immer, sondern es war eine Form, die aus ihm heraus sprudelte. Und als sie fertig war, sah er, was er angerichtet hat. So ungefähr. So wie eine Biografie auch einfach so, dann ist er halt da, ne? Sense-Making wird retrospektiv gemacht. In der Ansicht, mich interessiert nämlich auch, wenn du jetzt sagst, Verse, ja, reimen sie sich?
Sie reimen sich nicht, aber sie sind vortrefflich komponiert. Alexander Schnickmann ist 1994 geboren, also ein junger Autor, der schon als Lyriker, ich will nicht sagen Poetry Slammer, als jemand, der Lyrik auch performt, wohl von sich reden machte. Ich kannte ihn nicht, ich bin nur durch die Verlagsankündigung draufgestoßen und er beschreibt jetzt erst einmal, was zu vernehmen ist, wenn man sich in der Gegenwart befindet. Und das finde ich das Tolle, dass wir es hier mit einem wirklichen Gegenwartsroman zu tun haben, der aber dann nicht einfach die Gegenwart reproduziert, dass ich mir sagen kann, warum muss ich das nochmal im Buch formlesen? Ich habe doch schon eine Zeitung abonniert, sondern er macht etwas daraus, nämlich ein literarisches Kunstwerk. Und so lesen wir ziemlich zu Beginn schon. In Brandenburg nimmt die Waldbrand-Saison langsam Fahrt auf. Steht in der Zeitung die Waldbrand-Saison. Das gibt es jetzt. Ich kann gar nicht so schnell Luft holen. Da brennt schon der Wald in Bad Liebenwerder. Vor zwei Wochen Entwarnung. Waldbrand bei Bad Liebenwerder gelöscht. Vor zwei Wochen doch keine Entwarnung. Wieder Waldbrand in Jüterburg. Der Waldbrand in Jüterburg breitet sich weiter aus. Steht in der Zeitung und die Seiten riechen nach Rauch. Höre ich im Radio und der Rauch füllt das Zimmer, als es im Grunewald brennt. Kommen zwei oder drei Wochen keine Vögel mehr. Sitze ich allein draußen und die Vögel kommen nicht mehr. Ich denke, es riecht nicht schlecht. Es riecht nach warmen Holz. Es riecht nach Kiefernadeln. Auf der Straße waren die Leute etwas stiller als sonst. Keine Vögel mehr am Abend, keine Vögel mehr am Morgen. Wohin sie wohl geflogen sind, wie die Luft wohl steht in Brandenburg. Und da es keine Satzzeichen gibt und diese Ferse ja nicht jetzt auf einen Reim führen, muss man beim Lesen aufpassen. Und trotzdem ist es eigentlich schon falsch von mir gesagt. Nein, man liest es intuitiv und manchmal aber gerät man ins Stolpern. Also man kann ja zum Beispiel das auch so lesen und sagen, es riecht nach warmen Holz, es riecht nach Kiefernadeln. Auf der Straße waren die Leute etwas stiller als sonst keine Vögel. Mehr am Abend keine Vögel am Morgen. Wohin sie wohl geflogen sind, wie. Dann würde man nur die Ferse für Ferse. Aber man muss natürlich so ein enjambant, man muss die zusammenführen. Und die Frage ist aber, wo endet der eine Sinnabschnitt beginnt der nächste. Also wo ist auch der Nebensatz eigentlich, den man mit dem Komma einfügen würde.
Hat es Großbuchstaben?
Nein. Also es hat Großbuchstaben, ja die, genau, die, also es ist schon in groß und klein Schreibung, wie es sich gehört, geschrieben. Aber es gibt nicht diese Satzzeichen und es sind diese Versformen. Das klingt jetzt vielleicht für manche Leute abschreckend, aber ich bin auch niemand, der viel Lyrik liest. Und ich kann also versprechen, jedem, der sich dem öffnen will, wird das sehr schnell verstehen. Wer wird Lust bekommen, wenn das Lied auch immer wieder laut zu lesen, weil es wunderbar geschrieben ist. Und um mal zu zeigen, wie er Atmosphäre beschreiben kann. Also er ist dann unterwegs, dieses lyrische Ich ist unterwegs. Und da heißt es, wer lang genug in das schwarze Wasser blickt, der sieht ein Augenpaar. Wer nur lang genug, nur eine Nacht in das Landwehrkanalwasser blickt, den starren zwei Augen an, schon schlingen sich die Wellen anders um meine Knöchel. Es ist frisch geworden. Ist ja frisch geworden. Ja, frisch ist es geworden, als sich das Wasser um meine Beine schließt, wie sank die Nacht oder dämmert. Und dämmert schon, rutschen wir so arm in arm die feuchte Böschung hinab. Oder steigt das Wasser im Kanal bis zur Hüfte, zieh schwer eine Hand aus dem Wasser und streich dir das Seegraß aus dem Haar. Nein, ich glaube wirklich, das Wasser steigt und alles, was versunken ist, kehrt zurück an die Ufer. So ziehen sich dünne Rinsale um die Finger. Dein Hemd ist schon ganz durchnässt. Und seh erstmals, seh zum ersten Mal jetzt so einen Funkel, so einen Leuchten in deinen Augen. Aus deinen Haaren tropft's, die Grillen haben aufgehört zu zirpen. Staunen Haaren und sprinten die Böschung hinab. Die Häschen aus dem Görli hetzen, die Würmchen graben sich aus und nehmen die Beine in die Hand. Jedenfalls. Und die Biesamratten und Maulwürfe, Nutrias, machen sich auf den Weg in die Fluten und hören die Käfer jauchzen in den Wellen. Also wir sehen, man kann durchaus den Untergang, der dann möglicherweise hier schon beginnt, ganz anders schildern. Er spricht auch von den Flüssen, die da zum Beispiel aus Polen kommen, wo alles vergiftet ist. Aber er tut das in einer Weise, dass er noch einmal auch versucht, die Schönheit der Welt zu besingen, der Natur zu besingen. Ich habe den Wikipedia-Eintrag gelesen und fand dann ganz interessant, dass dort nochmal explizit erwähnt war, dass der Autor praktizierender Katholik sei. Also da ist natürlich das Requiem nochmal sehr nah. Aber nicht, dass man jetzt meint, das sei jetzt so ein Text, bei dem man irgendwelche religiösen Empfindungen schon mitbringen muss. Aber es ist nochmal eine andere Betrachtung der apokalyptischen Stimmung. Auch wie muss man sich dem wieder entziehen oder kann man sich dem entziehen? Und neben diesen Naturbeschreibungen geht es dann auch wieder ganz basal um das, was wir in unserem Alltag wahrnehmen, wenn wir durch unsere nicht ganz so schönen Städte marschieren. Und da heißt es dann, wie ich da irgendwo zwischen den Bäumen im Treptower Park herum irre. Und das Licht des Bahnhofs Schilds suche. Vielleicht seit Stunden schon. Wann habe ich dich verlassen? Die Matratze auf den Dielen, das Licht des Bahnhofs. Suche das grüne S-Bahnlicht. Suche einen weichen Sitz gleich an der Heizung. Den Geruch der ersten Backshop-Croissants. Den Geruch von warmer Butter. Und es wird hier schon frisch. Und die Bäume stehen so kalt. Und die Bäume stehen so grau. Bin ich nicht hier schon vorbei? Und das finde ich auch nochmal etwas, was diese Literatur auszeichnet ist. Nicht nur diese poetische Kraft, sondern auch eine Atmosphäre mit wenigen Worten zu schaffen. Also jeder weiß jetzt doch, was ganz konkret gemeint ist, wenn dieser Geruch von den Backshop-Croissants aufgerufen wird. Wir wissen es, wenn wir morgens um viertel vor sieben am Bahnhof stehen und sind da so hergegangen, die Straße. Und dann kommt einmal dieser Geruch und denkt, ah ja, das ist jetzt der neue Tag, der beginnt. Und dass er diese gute Beobachtungsgabe beherrscht und dann diese Sprach macht, das in Verse zu gießen und einen eigenen Rhythmus uns als Leser dadurch zu vermitteln und uns auch in so einen Wandermotiv hineinbringt. Wir gehen also mit diesen Protagonisten immer weiter durch und wir verzweifeln auch mit ihm an der Welt, an dem, was wir alles sehen. Das ist eine große, große Stärke. Und jetzt, da du ja einen Fernsehpodcast hast, will ich dir noch eine kurze Passage vorlesen. Und zwar ist auch für das lyrische Ich die Frage, wie gehe ich jetzt eigentlich mit all diesen Katastrophen um? Was machen wir mit den ganzen Nachrichten? Es gibt dann im Roman immer wieder diese Idee, daraus auszusteigen, nichts mehr wahrzunehmen. Und gegen Ende des Buchs heißt aber dann, und auch Gott wird angerufen, denn er, also Gott, ist mild, wirklich. Er ist so mild, dass er sich der Mücken erbarmt. Am Ende sogar meiner selig sind die Trauernden, lese ich mal, denn sie werden getröstet werden. Denn Gott wird selbst den Tod beenden. Und dann wischt er alle Tränen von den Wangen. Das wird was geben, wenn die Feuer verklungen, wenn Dämme gebrochen sind, die Augen glitzern hell im Sonnenlicht. Und 18. August, glaub ich, kauf mir einen Fernseher, schaue am Handy nach Fernsehern. Glaub ich, kauf mir eine riesige, kauf mir zehn riesige Fernseher, zwanzig riesige Fernseher und häng alles voll damit, kein Stück mehr Raufaser, alles Bildschirm, zwanzig riesige Fernseher hängen in meinem Zimmer und auf jedem läuft die Tagesschau, jeden Tag und jede Nacht die Tagesschau. Ich will jeden Tod sehen, jeden muss jeden Waldbrand, jedes versunkenes Schiff, jeden vergifteten Fluss.
Ja, sehr gut. Ich wollte nämlich gerade noch fragen, wo jetzt der Anlass ist, als Requiem zu nennen, wenn das doch so in der Gegenwart hält, dass wir…
Das ist die Klimakatastrophe. Und alle anderen Krisen. Also das ist der, das ist Polykrisen, Lyrik, wenn man so möchte. Ein Buch, das sicherlich einen als Leser herausfordert, aber die Herausforderung sollte man annehmen.
Das lyrische Ich ist wahrscheinlich dieser Frosch, der auf Seite eins bei 25 Grad in den Pool steigt und dann ab Seite 70 kurz vor kochend oder so.
Na also die, es wird schon von Anfang an angekündigt, wir haben es hier mit einem Requiem zu tun. Das heißt, das Ende ist absehbar.
Ich finde es ja schon gut, das Buch Requiem zu nennen, allein weil Requiem so ein schönes Wort ist, dass man dann in einem Buch, an dem es sozusagen so sehr um die Wortwahl geht, gleich von Anfang an sagt, wo es lang geht. Ich möchte ein Buch ganz großspurig kritisieren, was bedeutet, ich werde ihm natürlich nicht gerecht. Also anders als du, ich werde dir nichts vorlesen, obwohl so viel im Angebot ist. Denn ich weiß nicht genau, aber es sind mehrere hundert Seiten zu viel. Und ich weiß nicht, ob es an die tausend Seiten herankommt. Es ist jedenfalls Juwan Noah Harari hat jetzt Nexus vorgestellt. Nexus ist sein Begriff, den er aus der Juristerei nimmt. Wenn es nämlich eine Nexus gibt zwischen, ich habe mir eine App runtergeladen und im Finanzamt wird eine Steuer verbucht, dann ist das gut. Und wenn es diesen Nexus nicht gibt, sondern Apple sagt, wir sind doch in den Niederlanden angestellt oder so. Also, damit es da doch verortet, damit es diesen Nexus nicht gibt, dann ist das schlecht. Also, es gibt so Zusammenhänge und Nicht-Zusammenhänge und wenn alles Zusammenhang ist, dann ist es Nexus. Aber da alles Zusammenhang ist, meint er mit Nexus einfach nur die Welt und sucht da halt einen etwas ausgefalleren Begriff dafür. Über diese ausufernden und undifferenzierten Begriffe gleich. Also, dieses Buch handelt von der ganzen Gesellschaft, vormoderne Neuzeit, moderne und dann unklar, so ein bisschen über, hypermoderne. Irgendwas ist mit dieser Gegenwart, kennt man ja bei ihm.
Aber eigentlich soll es ein KI-Buch sein.
Ja, ab Seite, sagen wir mal auf den letzten, ich habe es nur so in Prozenten, weil ich habe es gehört, 17 Stunden lang. Irgendwann wird es auch ein KI-Buch, aber viel zu spät. Also, man hat einige Stunden damit verbracht, sich von einem Historiker, der sagt, konkrete Empirie ist nicht so wichtig. Die Frage ist, welcher Wandel fand statt? Hat man dann doch relativ viel Empirie bekommen, bei dem man sich so ein bisschen fragte, ja, ich hab das schon verstanden, was du mir sagen willst, als ich das erste empirische Korrelat als Illustration dazu von dir bekam. Beispiel Nummer 17 hat es dann echt nicht mehr gebraucht. So ungefähr.
Ich hörte ihn im Hardfork Podcast und dort erzählt er ausführlich vom Hexenhammer, was jetzt für die Amerikaner wohl was ganz Neues war. Das ist ja hier ein bisschen bekannter, weil es hierzulande kursierte. Also dass man während der Hexenverfolgung, zum Beispiel in Hexenhammer, andere Schriften hatte, die voller Fake News waren, sagten, es gibt Frauen, die stehlen Männern den Penis und sammeln diese überall und machen dann dies und das damit. Und dann laufen die Männer alle geschlechtslos durch die Welt, also solche Geschichten und wie sich sowas verbreiten konnte, obwohl man doch eigentlich schon intuitiv sehen musste, dass das Unsinn ist, aber dann zu realen Folgen geführt hat, nämlich dass Frauen als Hexen diffamiert und verbrannt wurden. Und ich verstehe das als illustratives Beispiel. Fake News gab es immer und die Medien spielen eine sehr entscheidende Rolle dabei. Und dann dachte ich aber, wo ist jetzt die eigene Leistung außer daran zu sagen, ja, ich kombiniere das jetzt mal mit unserer Debatte über Manipulation durch KI und Fake News.
Genau. Also wir kratzen das, wir müssen es rauskratzen. Das ist so ein Bergwerk. Man muss unter diesen ganzen Erklärungen, Erzählungen, also vor allem Erzählung, Erzählung, Erzählung, kleine Erklärung, Erzählung, Erzählung, Erzählung. So muss man das so ein bisschen. Wir haben ja David Graebers Anfänggebuch gelesen, oder von den beiden Davids. Da wird ja ganz klar markiert, lieber Leser, jetzt kommt eine empirische Studie. Wir haben hier Anthro, was auch immer für Wissenschaftler. Die legen uns das noch mal da. Dann kommt wieder ein Textteil von David Graeber, Analyse, Argument, bla, bla, bla. Und das ist hier einfach nicht. Also Harari zieht einfach durch. So würde ich sagen, per Plexity, Gott sei Dank. Also du gibst so eine Idee mit und drei Illustrationen und sagst, ich brauche noch fünf andere historische Beispiele. Und dann füllt sich so ein Buch halt relativ schnell.
Kann das sein, dass diese Leute, ich will ja niemandem was unterstellen, nicht mehr so sehr selbst schreiben, sondern große Rechercheteams haben, die sagen, oder die gesagt bekommen, mein Thema ist KI, Manipulation und wie die Wahrheit abhanden gerät. Bitte such mal historische Beispiele heraus, wo der Einfluss von Medien dafür gesorgt hat, dass sich politische Realitäten ändern und Menschen manipuliert werden. Und dann stiefeln die los, bringen den Hexenhammer ran, suchen dann noch so ein paar wirklich obskure Dinge heraus, wie ja, Frauen rennen nachts in die Schlafzimmer der Männer und klauen denen das Geschlecht. Und das bringt man dann so alles dahin. Und dann hat man noch mal so ein Harari, der da dann einen Text rausmacht, der einheitlich lesbar ist. Aber eigentlich wirkt das immer so ein bisschen wie so ein Kollektiv, das da losgeschritten ist, durch die Jahrhunderte wandert und dann alles herbeibringen.
Kannst du dich noch dran erinnern, im Podcast vor einigen Tagen haben wir irgendwo vier Rembrandt und Springer oder die Bild-Zeitung als…
Genau, es war Roger Wilmsen, der die Bild-Zeitung als Rembrandt-Deutsches Hassblatt bezeichnete. Und der Rembrandt-Deutsche ist ja ein Buch, das Ende des 19. Jahrhunderts entstanden ist, das so einen völkischen Nationalismus pflegte und sagte, dass der Deutsche so erzogen werden soll nach dem Ideale Rembrandts. Und dieses Buch war dann nachher auch für die Nationalsozialisten nicht ganz unwichtig, aber auch für die konservative Revolution. Und darauf bezog sich Wilmsen.
Ah ja, okay. Weil ich dachte, aber es war mir von Anfang an klar, ich habe hier nur so eine inspirierte Idee, kurz. Aber Schömerer hat das FAZ-Föter damals als Atelier wie Rembrandts Atelier verstanden.
Achso, nee, das ist was ganz anderes.
So, genau. Also es gibt so ein Zampano, der denkt so laut vor sich hin und dann ziehen die Leute so los und sammeln. So. Und ich dachte, weil das ein YouTube-Kommentar nochmal nachfragte, was hat Rembrandt mit der Bild zu tun, das ist ja die Bild. Wir haben es ja gerade im Vorgespräch auch gehabt bei Springer. Jetzt so einen zentralen Zampano installiert und die Redaktion soll dann so ausführen.
Das Bezieht sich auf das Buch Rembrandt als Erzieher. Und das ist dieses Ideal des Rembrandt-Deutschen. Das ist so ein nationalistisch-völkisches Buch.
Das eignet sich nicht ganz so, als jetzt hier passend. Aber ich denke mir auch, so jemand wie Harari macht das so ein bisschen wie Goethe oder Rembrandt. Oder Immendorf. Man sitzt so da. Aber Goethe hat schon selbst geschrieben. Aber wie ist die Frage? Ich habe mir Goethes Arbeitszimmer in Weimar angeschaut. Da steht ein großer Tisch in der Mitte. An dem sitzen also stehen drei Stühle und da saßen seine Schreiberlinge drauf. Und Goethe spazierte um diesen Tisch und sagte, was jetzt aufzuschreiben ist, wortwörtlich oder halt für seine Studienrecherche aufträgen.
Ich würde sagen, es ist eher so, und das ist diese moderne Form der Buchproduktion wie bei Kon Salik. Den wird auch kaum noch jemand kennen. Das war damals vor 30 Jahren. Der hat verdächtig viel geschrieben. Ganz genau. Also wer hat es noch geschrieben? Das ist ein bisschen so, dass man ein Team hat. Oder wer auch so gearbeitet hat und das aber auch klarer zugegeben hat, war Crichton, der Jurassic Park geschrieben hat.
Und Westworld?
Der hatte dann Leute, die sich reingefuchst haben in Dinosaurierkunde. Und dann haben die Exerpte geliefert und es auch selbst schon mal vor verfasst. Und dann ist er nochmal drüber. Ich will das Harari jetzt nicht unterstellen. Nur was ich glaube, ist, dass diese Autoren, wenn sie sich mal so etabliert haben, dazu neigen, dann immer so große Weltgeschichten zu erzählen. Man denkt, wann waren die dann jetzt wieder in den Archiven? Und dann kommen sie aber doch auf eher so punktuelles, was dann als Ganzes so eine schöne Narration ergibt, aber vielleicht dann doch unbefriedigend ist, wenn man wirklich was zu KI wissen will.
Und darüber geht die Idee, die dieses Buch hat, vollständig verloren. Also er sitzt in diesem Podcast und erzählt von diesen Hexenbüchern damals. Und man sagt, ja, das ist eine schöne Poarte. Und klar wird es darauf angesprochen. Aber warum geht es denn eigentlich? Und eigentlich geht es nicht mehr darum zu sagen, und dafür braucht man nicht viel Illustration, sondern nur eine einfache Argumentation. Wir sagen immer, die Aufklärung kam mit dem Buchdruck. Und dann nein, da liegen 100 Jahre dazwischen. Zuerst wurden religiöse Texte gedruckt. Und zwar nicht nur die, die man schon immer mal, und dann saß man in den Archiven, hat sie abgeschrieben, wie die Mönche, sondern man konnte sich auch immer mal neue Sachen ausdenken. Also kommen dann solche Hexengeschichten dazu. Und die ganze Hexenverfolgung basiert auf diesem technologischen Wandel, von dem wir heute sagen, das war der zündende Funke für die Aufklärung. Nein, das dunkle Mittelalter brauchte den Buchdruck. So ungefähr. Und diese Sachen sind nun hier in diesem Buch drin, aber sie sind eben auch relativ zügig erklärt. Also 1933 waren nicht alle deutschen Psychopathen. Und trotzdem kam es zum Holocaust. Ausschlaggebend ist eben, sich dafür zu interessieren, wie wir in großen Gruppen kooperieren. Der Volksempfänger war damals ein bloßes Radio, also Medium im eigentlichen Sinne, Sender, Empfänger und dazwischen schaltet man ein Medium, das besser skaliert. Heute schreiben die neuen Technologien ihre Reden einfach selber und halten sie auch noch. Das ist also eine paradigmatische Erkundung. Änderung. Es ist nicht nur ein Wandel in der Sache, sondern das Paradegmal selbst wandelt sich. Also durchaus interessant. Sollte man darüber nachdenken, macht er im Zuge dessen eben auch. Aber man könnte eben einfach auch auf 600 Seiten verzichten. So ungefähr, ist meine Kritik. Er treibt es dann wirklich auf die Höhe, gerade gegen Ende. Also das Buch, also man kann wirklich die ersten zwei Drittel überschlagen und das Ende lesen. Wenn das dann interessiert, kann man nochmal zurückblättern. Denn erst am Ende kommen dann diese etwas größeren Ideen, vor denen ich sage, ja, die kann man durchaus mal so ein bisschen. Aber jetzt nicht so konkret, wie wir das bei Gutes Geld oder so gelesen haben, sondern man fliegt halt aus der Studierstube so drüber. Was ist, wenn wir demnächst nicht nur Werkzeuge haben, die wir als Werkzeuge benutzen, sondern die selber mitdenken, als Agenten Ziele verfolgen und uns als Werkzeug für sich einspannen? Was ja noch eine etwas drastischere Frage ist als was ist, wenn Menschen einen Krieg machen wollen und dann Maschinen benutzen, die ein oder andere Ziel an Visierung selber unternehmen? Sondern was ist, wenn sich verfeindete technologische Netzwerke in Kriegen verstricken und uns dann auch? Ja, also dass wir uns da nicht mehr gegen wehren können. Erschöpft ein neues Wort, was ich spektakulär finde. Ich hätte das ganze Buch drauf, aber er lässt eben bei so einer Erwähnung einfach psychologische Massenvernichtungswaffen. Ich finde, wenn wir so über Facebook und den ganzen Instagram Scheiß nachdenken, dann sollten wir wirklich hier psychologische Massenvernichtung. Muss ja nicht die physische Vernichtung sein, sondern es ist eben psychologische Massenvernichtung. Alle Botschaften fürs 21. Jahrhundert werden umso düsterer, umso mehr man diesen großen technologischen Wandel jetzt beschreibt. Weil aus technologischem Wandel immer auch sozialer Wandel folgt. Und wer sagt denn, dass großer technologischer Wandel nicht gleich mal zu einer großen sozialen Katastrophe führt? Denn das Radio gesellschaftsfähig zu machen als akzeptiertes, ja, ist halt ein Dudelfunk, wo da erst mal ein Holocaust organisiert. Bis man dann sagte, ja, vielleicht ist es gut, wenn wir Regeln haben und Politiker an der Staatskanzlei noch mal kurz drüber gucken, was da so gemacht wird. Das haben wir ja gerade alles gar nicht. Also man macht halt einfach KI, weil Amerika sagt, das ist eine coole Technologie. Den funken wir mal nicht rein. Haben wir bei sozialen Netzen ja auch nicht gemacht. Nun konzentriert er sich aber sehr auf Netzwerke. Also dieser Nexus-Begriff ist eigentlich stellvertretend für Netzwerk. Und er reformuliert die gesamte Menschheitsgeschichte als Netzwerk. Und das verstehe ich nicht, weil er lässt dann alles liegen, was interessant werden kann. Denn nur weil man sieht, ah ja, der Mensch alleine macht keinen Unterschied, denn er muss sich ja koordinieren, in Gruppen finden und so weiter. Und könnte dann sogar ein Holocaust organisieren. Was kann er noch so alles organisieren? Und wir sagen, naja, alles, was wir halt so sehen. Nestle versorgt die ganze Welt mit irgendwelchem Kram und keiner interessiert, wo es herkommt. Man geht einfach zur Rehwirkung, kauft es halt so. Alles andere wird ausgeblendet. Also die Leistungsfähigkeit von Netzwerken sind sehr groß. Politische Netzwerke sind sehr mächtig. Ökonomische Netzwerke regieren bis unter unsere Bettdecke. Aber er belässt es dann halt so bei er. Wir haben so verstopfte Kanäle und wir müssten jetzt mal Institutionen aufbauen, um diesem Problem zu begegnen oder was auch immer. Und ich frage mich dann die ganze Zeit, ne, aber was wäre, wenn man jetzt nicht reingeht mit so einer Geschichtsschreibung? Übrigens, ich muss euch alles nochmal umdeuten. Das sind alles Netzwerke, sondern einfach sagt, ja, die Historiker und die Soziologen haben da schon ein paar Vorarbeiten geleistet. Wir unterscheiden jetzt mal. Wir machen kleinste Unterscheidungen. Die es schon super interessant machen, wie zum Beispiel nicht alle Netzwerke sind organisiert. Es gibt auch reine Interaktionsnetzwerke, super spontan, was auch immer. Dann gibt es aber Netzwerke, die sind politische Institutionen. Die haben so eigene Prinzipien über die empirischen Beispiele hinweg. Die könne man alle mal ernst nehmen. Dann reicht es auch einfach mal, Grundbegriffe zu verwenden, wo man sagt, der etwas vorgebildete Leser weiß so ungefähr, was eine Partei ist und von einem Amtszimmer unterscheidet oder sowas. Nein, es ist plötzlich alles Netzwerke, es muss alles reformuliert werden. Ich lese das und denke mir, es macht alles gar keinen Sinn. Die Beispiele sind völlig beliebig. Plötzlich werde ich aufgeklärt über die Idee, dass vor 500 Jahren irgendwelche Frauen, angeblich irgendwelche Männern, die Penis abgeschnitten haben, um sie in Vogelnestern zu sammeln und so. Das sind dann diese Podcast-Poanten. Und die eigentliche Idee geht ja völlig verloren und wird dann eben auch nicht entsprechend ausgearbeitet. Also dieses ganze Buch läuft sozusagen mit Handbremse, bevor es dann am Ende so ein paar Podcast-Affine oder kann man auch mal in einem 30-Minuten-Vortrag irgendwo noch mal sich einkaufen lassen, runtergebrochen wird. Schon allein dieser Intelligenzbegriff, der hier drin steckt, also von Information ganz zu schweigen. Information ist einfach alles und Intelligenz auch. Wo ich mir denke, wir haben den Grundbegriff Rationalität. Nur weil Sachen so gerichtet sind, weil man sie deuten kann, weil sie so Zusammenhänge zwischen der eine macht was, der andere macht was und jene macht auch noch was. Und da gibt es irgendwie einen Zusammenhang, macht Sinn. Nee, das ist dann noch nicht Intelligenz. Das kann auch erst mal nur eine Organisation, ordnet sich einem Zweck, unterschreibt, das sind Arbeitsverträge und Menschen, die diesen Arbeitsverträgen nachhandeln, sind halt klar erkennbar, ah ja, das ist jetzt Siemens und die bauen hier gerade was zusammen. So, da brauche ich keine Reformulierung über einen völlig unausreichenden Begriff wie Netzwerke, sondern da kann ich einfach mal organisationssoziologisch, das mit politischer Wissenschaft irgendwie verbinden und dann einfach sagen, was jetzt Sache ist. Also völlig bescheuert. Aber einen Gedanken, den er hat, den will ich trotzdem mal rausgreifen, auch wenn ich ihn, wie er ihn verarbeitet, albern finde. Aber das kann man zumindest dann mal hoffen, dass er das zukünftig so ein bisschen deutlicher macht. Netzwerke haben, wie er sagt, Eigenschaften, die in der Weite seiner unbegrenzten Begriffe einfach alles meinen, wie zum Beispiel Mythen, Religion, Regeln, Geschichten, Grundsätze, Satzungen, keine Ahnung, alles Mögliche. Also Netzwerke haben ein Gedächtnis und die Quelle dafür, also die Quelle, ist immer eine menschliche Intuition. Die kann sich dann niederschlagen in das Management, die wollte eigentlich nur Profite und Produkte und plötzlich hat es aber noch irgendwelche Nebenfolgen erzeugt. So, da muss man sich anschauen. Das ist ja dann auch so eine Beraterleistung. Wo genau ist jetzt das Unternehmen falsch abgebogen? Warum ist jetzt das Klima zerstört und so? Und dann könnte man halt so nachsteuern und sagen, aber die menschliche Idee ist ja auch, das Klima zu schützen. Also preisen wir das jetzt als neue menschliche Quelle für eine Ideengebung ein und strukturieren alles andere neu. Das ist ja auch das Ziel, was wir haben, wenn wir so ein politisches Buch wie Gutes Geld lesen, dass wir sagen, ja, diese ganzen Verwaltungsapparate haben so Eigenlogiken und dann kommen auch noch so Attraktoren wie klare Kennziffern hinzu und ein technopolitischer Verwaltungsablauf. Könnten wir nicht mal mit einer neuen menschlichen Idee das alles den großen Hebel umlegen? So. Und was ist, wenn dieser Hebel jetzt mal nicht von Menschen noch umgelegt wird? Also wenn einfach jemand anders diesen großen Hebel umlegt, ohne dass wir es merken. Also wenn wir künftig nicht nur einer Funktionslogik eines Werkzeugs oder einer sozialen Rationalität, einer Organisation oder was auch immer ausgeliefert sind, sondern wirklich grundlegend jetzt wo wir Netzwerke haben, die eben nicht nur sozusagen uns erweitern, sondern grundlegend selbst Agenten sind. Er diskutiert das dann so ein bisschen durch. Noch haben wir keine KI die eigene Ziele formuliert. Er fehlt auch noch ein Körper. Sie kann nicht wirklich einen Willen ausbilden, weil ihr die Anbindung an intrinsische Motivation und sowas fehlt, was Herr Richter David Precht auch immer betont. Ein spontaner Precht in 30 Minuten Gespräch mit Lanz ist auf Augenhöhe mit diesem Buch. Man braucht das einfach alles gar nicht. Trotzdem sind es grundlegende Fragen, die man mal diskutieren kann. Er will natürlich dann noch mal betonen, dass KI jetzt wirklich die vermutlich größte Informationsrevolution der Menschheit ist. Nur was ist eine Informationsrevolution, wenn Revolutionen, wie sie stattfanden, immer nur Netzwerkeffekte sind. Also alles darunter subsumiert wird und man gar nicht unterscheiden kann. Ist das jetzt eine politische Partei oder ist das eine Revolution? So, ist ja bei ihm dann alles gleich. Und der Informationsbegriff, gut, er unterscheidet noch mal zwischen dem naiven Informationsverständnis. Wir denken immer, Information ist Wissen über Sachverhalte, die uns nützen. Und er sagt noch mal ausdrücklich, und das finde ich auch gut, das muss man doch immer wieder sagen, alles ist ausgedacht. Es ist einfach immer Information. Dieses Elementare, ich gehe in den Wald und sehe einen grünen Baum, und er wird mir nicht als Information mitgeteilt. Okay, kann es geben. Aber wie bei Rutger Brechmann ja auch, oder wie er heißt.
Rutger Brechmann.
Die Intelligenz, wenn man sie überhaupt verortet, steckt vielleicht nicht im Menschen, sondern in der Kommunikation. Das ist auch meine Tochter mal, die auch so kam, wir müssen jetzt Gedichtanalyse machen und so. Und da habe ich ihr gesagt, überleg mal, alles, was man tut, alles, was irgendjemand tut, macht man einfach nur, weil man mal irgendwo was erfahren hat, was jemand anders macht. Nichts macht man aus sich heraus, sondern man ist so verknüpft mit, irgendwer hat eine Erfahrung gemacht. Und wie kommt diese Erfahrung eigentlich zu mir? Irgendwer hat sie irgendwann mal wo aufgeschrieben. Man kriegt eine Nachricht per Direktmitteilung oder sonstiges und so. Und ein Gedicht ist einfach nur der Gipfel, wie man etwas aufschreibt. Deswegen bestehe ich auch sehr darauf, dass sich Gedichte reimen müssen, weil man erst, wenn sie sich reimen, wirklich sichtbar ist, dass man sich einer Logik der Sprache unterwirft und nicht einfach sagt, mir hat dieses Wort gefallen, ich werde nicht platziert, das ist jetzt mal. Sondern wenn es nicht passt, dann passt es nicht. Die Regel sagt, es soll sich reimen. Es war albern und hält auch nichts stand.
Ja, ja, es gibt ja schon andere Regeln.
Ja, genau. Aber es ist sozusagen eine, also ob sich etwas reimmt oder nicht, da sagen wir, wenn es sich reimmt, klingt es irgendwie schöner. Aber wenn es sich reimmt, der Reim selbst entzieht sich der ästhetischen, es ist keine Ästhetik, sondern es muss einfach gleich klingen. Das ist auch in jeder Sprache ein bisschen anders. Also an Gedichten, die sich reimen, sieht man, dass die Logik, die Rationalität, die Intelligenz, die Information in der Sprache selbst drin steckt. Wenn man in den Wald geht und nicht mal kommuniziert, verhungert man sofort. Und wenn man zu Hause sitzt und zur Rewe gehen möchte oder in irgendeinen anderen Supermarkt, ich habe es schon dreimal Rewe genannt, dann braucht man eine Intelligenz jenseits der eigenen. Und das geht nur über Sprache. Und jetzt ist die Frage, wo verorten wir zum Beispiel eine Oper? Wir gehen heute Abend in die Oper, es wird auf Russisch gesungen, über drei Stunden. Was ziehen wir da eigentlich raus? Die Oper verzichtet nicht auf Text, nur weil er auf Russisch ist oder wie auch immer. Also wir werden konfrontiert mit Informationen und Intelligenzen und Rationalitäten, die erstmal nicht unsere sind. Wir lesen ein bisschen im Programmbuch nach oder wie auch immer. Also ich finde, das muss man auf die Spitze treiben und auch so viel wie möglich jedem Menschen sagen. Also es ist nicht verkehrt, einer 8, 9, 10-Klasse-Rin schon mal zu sagen, wenn du ein Gedicht liest, ist das ein ganz kleiner Teil einer ganz großen Intelligenz, bei der du immer nur Approximationshoffnung hast. Du musst aber da irgendwie hin und versuche, das im Gedicht mehr zu verstehen, als der Autor reingeließen hat. Solche Sachen. Und Harari schafft es nicht. Oder nicht mehr. Ich habe die Bücher damals anders gelesen, wie er vor zehn Jahren oder so geschrieben hat. Jetzt ist es einfach nur so ein wirklich belangloses Abnudeln von irgendwelchen empirischen Korrelaten. Von was denn eigentlich? Neuerfindung des Netzwerkbegriffs. Ich meine, Netzwerk wurde in meiner Lieblingstheorie aussortiert, weil man meinte Interaktion, Organisation, Gesellschaft. Und wir versuchen mal alles daraus zu begründen, wenn es Gründe gibt, Netzwerke auf diesen Rang hochzuwichten.
Ich habe nur eine Frage dazu. Bezieht er sich etwa auf Bruno Latour, weil der ja diesen Akteurs Netzwerk begriffen hat. Und ich habe den Eindruck, dass Latour in den letzten 10, 15 Jahren noch mal so eine neue Popularität aus unerfündlichen Gründen gewonnen hat, die dann selbst Einzug in Silicon Valley gehalten hat. Denn in Stanford sind auch so Leute, die so Latour-Anhänger sind. Und da wurde dann dieser ganze Netzwerk-Gramm, wurde man überall damit genervt.
Nein, also Latour wird nicht genannt. Aber mein Unwillen, mich tiefer mit diesem Text zu befassen, ist derselbe, wie wenn ich diese französische Literatur vor mir habe. Ich will mich damit nicht befassen. Und dann möchte ich lieber, dass mir eine KI, die hier so verteufelt wird, am Ende noch mal aufschlüsselt. Und in dem Fall, man hat jetzt keine Zugriff. Also es gibt noch keine KI, indem man das Autobild-Book oder so reinlädt, weil kannst du immer nur 10 Prozent und so weiter. Aber am Ende bleibt einfach nur, warum habe ich das jetzt 17 Stunden lang gehört? Hätte ich nicht einfach irgendeine KI fragen können, was sind die zentralen Punkte? Und die zentralen Punkte sind ja durchaus wichtig. Also technologische Entwicklung führten bislang zur Integration der Weltgesellschaft. Jetzt haben wir Informationstechnologie, die uns wieder in Informationssilos separiert. Völlig richtig. Wir haben gerade nicht den Eindruck, dass wir hier eine Weltvergesellschaftung haben, sondern je nachdem, wer in Amerika regiert, sieht man da durchaus Separierungen. Wie auch im Kleinen. Also Israel und Libanon nähern sich gerade nicht an, sondern da finden halt Separierungen statt. Und zwar wirklich getrieben über Informationstechnologie. Also nur weil Israel gerade glaubt, man kann mit technischen Vorsprung eine kriegerische Auseinandersetzung gewinnen, findet das da gerade statt. Also es ist zentral, da die Technik zu verorten. Informationstechnologie ist die erste Technologie, zu der wir ernsthafte emotionale Bindung aufbauen, sagt er. Und da würde ich sagen, ja, aber nimm das doch ernst und sag mir dann auch, dadurch werden soziale Bindungen zu anderen Menschen abgebaut. Weil der Tag hat nur 24 Stunden und ein Drittel davon schlafe ich. Aber dem wird nicht nachgegangen, sondern das sind dann einfach so kurze Snippets. Wir brauchen neue Prinzipien für Umgang mit Technologie, zum Beispiel Fürsorge. Wir gehen zum Arzt und vertrauen ihm, und zwar auch, weil es Gesetze dazu gibt, dass der mit uns so umgeht, dass es nicht nur um seinen Profitinteresse geht. So können wir diese Art von Fürsorge nicht auch im Umgang mit Technologien einfordern. Zu solchen Diskussionen und Argumentationen kommt es aber nicht, weil ich erschlagen werde mit Empirie.
Ach, hier ist jetzt zu viel Empirie.
Ja, das wollte ich gerade als letzte Vororte machen. Es ist einfach zu viel Empirie. Ich brauche Illustration.
Dann gehen wir doch jetzt in die Abstraktion.
Ja, auf in die Abstraktion.
Wir sprechen jetzt über den Gegenstandpunkt. Also die politische Vierteljahreszeitschrift. Wir haben die dritte Ausgabe aus dem Jahr 24 in den Händen. Und jetzt bin ich auf deine Eindrücke gespannt. Nochmal ganz kurz für die Leute, die jetzt gerade verwundert sind. Stefan wurde getriggert von jungen Menschen in seiner Umgebung, die den Gegenstandpunkt lesen, aber in Bielefeld studieren. Also fernab des Gegenstandspunktes und sehr begeistert sind davon. Und dieses linksradikale, staatskritische Organ ist eines, das einen Nischendasein fristet. Man kann das in Bahnhofbuchhandlungen kaufen. Das sind Ausgaben, die etwa 130 Seiten haben, eingebunden in einen schmucklosen, grauen Umschlag. Und es gibt kein Foto in diesem Band. Es gibt keine Grafiken oder sonst irgendetwas, sondern nur Text, Text, Text.
Ja, und es kommt aus dem kapitalistischen EP Zentrum München. Kann man noch dazu sagen, fand ich irgendwie interessant. Ich bin, wie gesagt, kein Gegenstandpunkt Leser, sondern ich bin Laufkunde. Also man könnte mich jetzt einfangen oder halt nicht, aber ich komme halt nur mal so kurz vorbei, ne? Deswegen habe ich noch mal kurz nachgelesen. Es ist eine Vierteljahreszeitschrift, die seit 1992 herausgegeben wird. Also seit wir wissen, dass in Europa die Hebel beim Geld falsch umgelegt werden, ist es sozusagen eine Gegenbewegung. Vielleicht so eine akademisch-aktivistische Gegenbewegung zu einem Mainstream, der irgendwas mit diesen Geldfragen zu tun hat. Es versteht sich selbst als revolutionär-kommunistisch, fand ich überraschend, weil das ist nicht mein Eindruck, den ich aus der einen Lektüre... Ja, es ist mir wirklich nicht aufgefallen.
Ja, also ich wundere mich auch über das Revolutionär vor allem. Es ist ja doch eher so, dass der Gegenstandpunkt, die den Aktivismus eher verneint beziehungsweise sehr skeptisch dem gegenüber steht. Also nicht, dass nicht auch eine Sympathie da ist, wenn irgendwas gelingt, zum Beispiel eine gewerkschaftliche Arbeit. Aber es ist doch eigentlich in der Abstraktion bleibend und vor allem auch oft sehr fatalistisch beziehungsweise kann so eine Fundamentalkritik am Nationalstaat natürlich relativ schnell in einen Fatalismus führen.
Ja, außerdem sagt man nach, dass es um theoretische Abhandlungen ohne journalistischen Stil geht. Ich würde sagen, die Stiltreue, die durchgehalten wird, macht es fast langweilig in der Lektüre. Also ein paar Variationen dürfen durchaus mal sein. Theorie auch kaum gefunden, aber ich habe auch einen sehr strengen Anspruch an Theorie. Also manchmal gehen ja kleine Ideen schon als Theorien durch, kann hier so sein. Dass der Gegenstandpunkt seit 2018 vom Verfassungsschutz als recht-lingsextremistisch eingestuft wird, halte ich für ein Qualitätsmerkmal. Also das ist mehr so ein Attraktor. Das ist wie, wenn die Ärzte verboten werden oder so, dann hört man das erst recht. Ja. Und es gibt wohl einen Dunstkreis aus Autoren, aber man kennt keine oder jedenfalls nicht einzeln auf die Texte, weil die Texte bleiben autorenlos. Das ist so ein bisschen Economist-Style.
Ja, ich kenne eigentlich nur diesen, der auch schon mal in YouTube-Formaten auftritt, Peter Decker.
Der ist der Chef von dem Laden.
Das ist der Chef. Ja. Aber ich weiß auch nicht, wer jetzt sonst dafür schreibt.
Vielleicht schreibt er alle selbst.
Das wäre eigentlich das Schönste, ja.
So, was finde ich gut? Es ist wirklich ein reichhaltiger Zitate-Katalog. Ich mache ja auch gerne Podcasts, die die ganze Zeit von Clips unterbrochen werden, weil ich gerne möchte, dass jeder weiß, worüber man gerade spricht. Und ich habe hier den Eindruck, ich weiß, wovon die gerade reden, weil sie sagen es mir. Sie befassen sich auch mit Lesermeinungen oder so, wenn ich das jetzt richtig gedeutet habe. Also Texte können Diskussionen zum Thema anschließen, so wie, wenn man in Podcasts Audio-Kommentare spielt oder so.
Ja, das war mir neu. Das können wir gerade erzählen. Ich habe ja nicht alle Texte genau gelesen, aber ich lese das ja nicht regelmäßig, deswegen kann ich es nicht beurteilen. Ich fand es nur interessant. Sie waren in diesem Podcast 99 zu 1 zu Gast, irgendjemand, ich vermute Peter Decker oder jemand anderes. Und dort ging es um den Nahost-Konflikt. Und daraufhin auf dieses Gespräch und auch auf die Publikationen dazu.
Ja, aber sie zitieren dann unwörtlich, was im Podcast fortragend gesagt wurde.
Nein, sie zitieren dann ein Schreiben dieser Podcaster, das sich sehr ausführlich mit der Argumentation auseinandersetzt. Ah ja, also die hatten selber noch mal geschrieben, weil ich habe das so verstanden, als ob das so im Podcast fortgetragen wurde. Diese Podcaster sind, wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstanden habe, deren Anliegen ist, dass sie vermissen, dass der Gegenstandpunkt solidarischer sich zu den Palästinensern verhalten sollte. Und die Gegenstandpunktargumentation dagegen ist, nicht, dass sie irgendein Leid der Palästinenser oder so leugnen, aber worauf sie hinweisen ist, dass man sich bei solchen geopolitischen Auseinandersetzungen nicht eine Position zu eigen machen sollte. Also das ist ja eine radikale Nationalstaatskritik. Das heißt ja, im Prinzip, wenn Krieg ist, also bleiben wir, Nordste ist ein bisschen schwieriger, weil wir da noch die Staatlichkeit von Palästina sowieso in Frage gestellt sehen. Aber wenn wir jetzt zum Beispiel den Krieg in der Ukraine, der ja hier auch Thema ist, ansprechen, dann würde also vom Gegenstandpunkt aus man sagen, naja, das ist schlimm. Aber es gibt jetzt keinen Grund, sich auf die eine Seite zu stellen und deren Sieg oder so zu hoffen, weil man immer, egal auf welcher Seite man dann steht, in einem nationalistischen Paradigma über die Dinge nachdenkt. Und da sie eine radikale Kritik am Nationalstaat formulieren, ist für sie also eine Kritik nur außerhalb dieser Paradigmen möglich. Und das bedeutet dann, dass man sich da nicht zu eigen macht. Und wenn es Aktivisten gibt, zum Beispiel, das ist ja dann ein Vorwurf, den sie da artikulieren in ihrer Antwort, von der palästinensischen Seite, die vor allem wollen, dass die Palästinenser einen eigenen Nationalstaat haben, dann ist das nicht Sache von Gegenstandpunkt an zu sagen, ja, da sind wir aber auch dafür. Weil sie sind ja generell gegen den Nationalstaat. Also gegen einen israelischen Nationalstaat müssen sie genauso sein wie gegen einen palästinensischen oder sonst irgendeinen. Und das ist so eine Grundhaltung, die da ist. Und dadurch wird aber natürlich auch jede Argumentation oft darauf zurückgeführt. Was man dann ja sehen kann, dass sie sich mit Klaus Weselsky auseinandersetzen, den sie, glaube ich, genauso wenig mögen wie du, aber aus unterschiedlichen Gründen.
Der wird schon ganz schön abgefeiert da.
Hier in dem Gegenstandpunkt?
Klar.
Nein, über den wird sich doch eher mokiert. Denn sie werfen ja Klaus Weselsky vor, dass er quasi aus einem nationalstaatlichen Interesse heraus handelt und auch noch anti-marxistisch argumentiert. Und deswegen, man achte hier drauf, bei dem Titel steht Klaus Weselsky, Deutschlands radikalster Gewerkschafter. Und das ist aber in Anführungszeichen geschrieben. Also sie sind der Auffassung offenbar nicht, dass das Deutschlands radikalster Gewerkschafter ist.
Also, diese ganze Zeitung verstehe ich nicht. Schon allein, weil ich Probleme mit dem Format habe. Ja. So, bei Weselsky könnte man jetzt in die Textexe gese gehen. Ich habe es, wie gesagt, gehört. Und meine Abläufe sind ja so, egal was ich konsumiere, ich habe immer den Finger am Abzug. Wenn irgendwo irgendwas Interessantes auftaucht, weiß ich, wie ich mir da später einen Clip, eine Notiz oder was auch immer mache. Ich habe mir kaum Notizen gemacht. Und drei Beispiele will ich kurz mal vortragen, wo ich allerdings in so eine Formatkritik einsteige. Denn so wie sie das radikal in Anführungszeichen schreiben, bei Klaus Weselsky sage ich, der Gegenstandpunkt ist keine radikale Publikation. Sondern er schreibt so ein bisschen in diese Richtung auf, wie man darüber redet, wenn man halt über Sachen redet. Ich weiß nicht, ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, auch wenn die ARD, Maischberger und so ein Programm hat, dass alle Menschen, die das schauen, eigentlich Vertreter Maischberger sind, gegen die man jetzt anargumentieren müsste. Sondern Gespräche gegen diesen Kram finde ich ganz schön häufig und auch ganz schön normal. Und der Gegenstandpunkt bricht da nicht aus. Ich finde auch diese grundsätzliche, also damit mal Radikalität ausgeschlossen, in Anführungszeichen gesetzt. Wenn die sagen, wir haben hier keine Autoren, sondern nur Argumente und Analyse, wo? Bei dem Text zum Thema Israel, ja, zugestandener Maßen, den fand ich auch zuweilen überraschend. Also da kann man einfach mal so, wenn man das so nachlesen denkt, ja stimmt. Also gerade durch diesen Widersatz, wir sehen da eigentlich immer Kriege, die so als, da kämpfen Nationen und dann sagen wir mal, ne, da kämpfen eigentlich so Ideen gegeneinander. Es geht um was Größeres. So und in der Deutlichkeit, in der beschrieben wird, wie vermutet wird, wie weitreichend das Denken Netanjahu ist. Das habe ich so noch nirgendwo anders gelesen und das finde ich dann muttäig. Und deswegen würde ich sagen, lohnenswerte Lektüre. Aber bei einigen anderen Sachen. Scheint mir doch statt hier Analyse, Argumentation, Theorie oder irgendwas im Mittelpunkt zu stehen, es ist doch mehr so Gefühl und Befindlichkeit, die man mal ausdrücken wollte. Und wenn ich mir dann, ich lese mal konkrete Texteinstiege vor, beispielehaft. Und wie gesagt, für mich ist das so ein eigentlich einheitliches Buch, das unterbrochen wird durch thematische Sprünge, die man nun ganz selbstverständlich einfach mit Kapitelüberschriften markiert. Deswegen sage ich jetzt nicht im Text von, sondern dann kommt ein neues Kapitel. Das beginnt so. 2023 versetzt die amerikanische Autogewerkschaft UAV, United Automobile Aerospace and Agricultural Implement Workers of America. Muss unbedingt da auf den Zeltrecken schreiben. Mit einem sechswöchigen Arbeitskampf gegen Amerikas stolzer Big Three Autokonzerne, GM Ford Stellantis, heimische und hiesige Beobachter in Erstaunen. Kein Wunder. Was ist das Wunder? Immerhin forderten sie eine Lohnerhöhung von mehr als 40 Prozent innerhalb der nächsten vier Jahre. Also ist das Gegenstandpunkt? Das ist doch Spiel online oder was? Und dann noch für Kinder, also hier Schülerzeitungsniveau. Der erste Entwurf, wir lassen mal so ein bisschen Prosaat drin. Kein Wunder. Nächstes Beispiel, auch einen Textanfang. Im politischen Leben Amerikas fällt das Sommerloch dieses Jahr aus. Also Sommerloch und Ausfallen, ja, das steht im Floskelkatalog. Das wird dir sofort ausgetrieben, sobald du den ersten Tag voluntariat irgendwo machst. Im Herbst wird schließlich der Präsident gewählt. Und weil es um den Posten des wichtigsten Machthabers der Welt geht, des Leaders der Weltordnungsmacht schlechthin, genießt jede Wendung im amerikanischen Wahlkampf eine Aufmerksamkeit der ganzen Welt. Also auch unsere. Wir geben uns geschlagen. In Amerika passiert irgendwas. Wir erzählen euch nach. So, höhere Schöpfungshöhe gibt es da nicht. Nächster Text. Die NATO feiert ihr 75-jähriges Bestehen als Kriegsbündnis und findet, dass sie notwendiger und lebendiger ist als je zuvor. Sie findet sich zwar gar nicht unmittelbar im Krieg, bezieht aber den Krieg in der Ukraine als größte Sicherheitskrise seit Generationen auf sich. Der gewaltsam geltend gemachte Einspruch Russlands gegen die NATO-Ostausdehnung hat dem Bündnis wieder die einende Feindschaft zurückgegeben, die ihm mit dem Abdanken seines Systemrevalen abhandengekommen war. Wenn ich einen Text darüber schreiben möchte, in dem ich den russischen Angriffskrieg zu einem gewaltsam geltend gemachten Einspruch Russlands gegen die NATO-Ostausdehnung formulieren möchte, dann muss ich mir ein bisschen Mühe geben, das so zu formulieren, dass mir nicht direkt, weil das schon im ersten Satz so drin steht, gesagt wird, na sorry, es ist immer noch ein Angriffskrieg, der allerdings durchaus Argumentationen haben könnte, über die man mal nachdenken sollte. Denn wenn man es nicht macht, verliert man einiges aus dem Blick. So, aber entweder sind diese Texteinstiege so Schülerzeitungs-mäßig oder so überfallartig wie diese Kriege selbst, die hier dann, ja, werden die jetzt nicht kritisiert, weil das ja ein geltend gemachter Einspruch ist statt ein Angriffskrieg. Also ich hab dann gar keine Lust, mich weiter mit so was auseinanderzusetzen, weil die Leseliste ist wirklich gigantisch groß. Und ich weiß nicht, ob der Gegenstandpunkt so neue Leser gewinnt. Selbst bei Leuten, von denen ich und ich kenne einige, die anders denken.
Ich habe jetzt nicht den Eindruck, dass die Zeitschrift darauf ausgelegt ist, viele Leser zu gewinnen. Denn dann würde man sie ein bisschen anders aufmachen.
Ich finde, das sollte das Ziel sein.
Es ist jetzt ja nicht so, dass man sich bemüht, darum im Duktus Leute für sich zu gewinnen. Eher muss es ja so sein, dass man schon eingeweihter ist, um gewisse Formulierungen zu verstehen. Also der Außenstehende denkt jetzt, ja relativieren die etwa alles und finden die dann etwa Putin gut oder was? Und dann steht aber natürlich nur dieses, der gewaltsam geltend gemachte Einspruch Russlands gegen die NATO-Ostausdehnung, hat dem Bündnis wieder die einhende Feindschaft zurückgegeben. Das ist ja eine sehr sarkastische Bemerkung darüber.
Ja, die im Texteinstieg nichts zu suchen hat.
Das National-, ja, aber das ist ja nur für Eingeweihte, wie gesagt. Das Nationalstaaten, ich will das ja gar nicht verteilen, sondern nur verstehen, wie die das bauen. Also die Idee ist, dass Nationalstaaten versuchen, ihre Souveränität permanent zu vergrößern, zumindest zu erhalten. Und da spielen alle anderen Fragen, sind dem untergeordnet. Also wie geht es der Bevölkerung damit und wie viele Menschen werden auf dem Schlachtfeld sterben und was machen die Nachbarländer, spielt erstmal nicht die Rolle. Das Wichtigste ist also, dass die Staatsmacht sich selbst repräsentiert und ihre Macht durchsetzt. Und in dieser Betrachtungsweise kann ich natürlich jeden Krieg und jeden Konflikt nur als Souveränitätsspiel betrachten. Der Herrschenden, ob sie dann demokratisch regieren oder autokratisch, ist im Prinzip dann auch egal. Und dann kann ich damit geopolitische Konstellationen beschreiben. Eigentlich ist das sehr nah an dem, was jetzt John Mersheimer tut, allerdings nicht in dieser zugegeben etwas verkomplizierenden Sprache. Mersheimer würde aber auch sagen, naja, da stehen sich zwei Mächte gegenüber, die um die Einflusssphären kämpfen. Der spricht jetzt nicht von gewaltsam geltend gemachten Einsprüchen, aber im Prinzip meint er Ähnliches. Das ist aber nichts, was, glaube ich, Leser heranziehen soll, sondern ich glaube, es ist eher so, dass man so einen Gegenstandpunktrahmen im Kopf hat, also eine Art, die Welt zu betrachten und Marxistisch zu denken. Und dann wird eigentlich diese Denkweise, so verstehe ich diese Zeitschrift, durchextanziert an verschiedenen Phänomenen. Und da würde ich auch sagen, das funktioniert mal besser, mal schlechter. Ich finde zum Beispiel diesen Text zum US-Wahlkampf ziemlich uninteressant.
Der erzählt einfach nur nach.
Der erzählt das mir ja nur nach und mischt das ein bisschen mit deren Vokabular. Aber das weiß ich ja, dass der Wahlkampf so verläuft und warum da alles draufblickt. Also das kann ich mir ja von jedem Podcast mal gerade erzählen lassen. Da finde ich da keine Originalität drin. Wo ich aber zum Beispiel eine Stärke sehe, ist, wenn dann doch mal beschrieben wird, zum Beispiel die Reform der Bürgergeldreform. Da ist der Text nämlich dann konkret und dann wird dann auch der Marxismus deutlich. Also es geht um die Leute, die Bürgergeld empfangen. Und da sagen sie ja, das sind ja vor allem drei Gruppen. Langzeitarbeitslose, Aufstocker und dann auch jetzt inzwischen eine erkleckliche Anzahl an ukrainischen Kriegsflüchtlingen. Und dann wird beschrieben zunächst die Langzeitarbeitslosen. Hier handelt es sich um eigentümliche Figuren, nämlich um Opfer des kapitalistischen Fortschritts. Wovon sie sozial betroffen gemacht sind, ist immerhin der Umstand, dass für die Erwirtschaftung des gesellschaftlichen Reichtums kontinuierlich weniger Arbeitsaufwand erforderlich ist. Und das ist gerade für diejenigen, auf deren Potenz zur Arbeit es darum weniger ankommt, alles andere als eine gute Nachricht. Denn sie sind und bleiben in Fragen ihres Lebensunterhalts in der Lohnabhängigkeit verhaftet, auch wenn sie nicht länger einem Bedarf der Unternehmerschaft nach Lohnen der Arbeit zuzuführen sind. Also, dass es diese marxistische Diktion, die da drin liegt. Und dann geht es um die Frage, wie also jetzt mit den Flüchtlingen umgegangen wird. Und dann sagen sie, die haben mit all dem zwar auf den ersten Blick nicht zu tun. Sie sind ja ohnehin nicht hier, weil das deutsche Kapital nach ihnen verlangt oder sie abgestoßen hätte. Und Bürgergeld erhält diese außerwählte Subspezies der Sozialfälle mit ausländischer Staatsbürgerschaft allein aufgrund des politischen Beschlusses, die Opfer unseres russischen Feindes nicht mit Sachleistungen abzuspeisen, wie man es mit sonstigen Schutzsuchenden am liebsten zu machen pflegt. Also da bilden sie ja nochmal heraus, dass da eine Zwei-Klassengesellschaft innerhalb der Klasse der Flüchtlinge entstanden ist. Natürlich für das deutsche Kapital sind sie in gewisser Weise dennoch und das sogar in zweifacher Hinsicht. Indem sie im Unterschied zu anderen Flüchtlingen explizit arbeitsberechtigt, dem Heer der Arbeitslosen zugeschlagen werden, bieten sie der hiesigen Unternehmerschaft eine bequeme zusätzliche Auswahl an bei Bedarf frei ausnutzbaren billige Arbeitskräften. Also hier argumentieren sie, anders als Sigl-Glöckner, mit der Reservearmee der Arbeitslosen und sie enden dann diesen Beitrag. Ein möglicher Ausweg aus der Debatte liegt darin, dass diese Kostgänger, wie eingangs erwähnt, also das ist ironisch gemeint, die sehen jetzt nicht Flüchtlinge als Kostgänger. Wie eingangs erwähnt, ja bei weitem nicht nur faule Deutsche sind. Im Gegenteil sind unglaubliche 37,3 Prozent der Bürgergeldbezieher noch nicht einmal wirkliche Bürger unseres Staates. Also muss man immer ironisch lesen. Nicht zuletzt im Licht dieser Tatsache fragt man sich, wiederum angetrieben von CDU und FDP, dann schon, wie es mit den ganzen Ukrainern, die hier bei uns sind, anstatt ihrem Vaterland zur Seite zu stehen und die hier noch einmal nicht arbeiten, künftig überhaupt weitergehen soll. Auch wenn die SPD davon, im Ausnahmefall der Ukrainer, einstweilen noch nichts wissen will, die Gehässigkeit des Nationalismus verspricht immer wieder politische Abhilfe in Fragen sozialer Probleme. Und wenn wir jetzt nochmal uns vergegenwärtigen, dass Cem Özdemir in der FAZ ein Artikel schreibt, in dem er sich nicht nur über die angeblich integrationsunwilligen Migranten aufregt, sondern er auch sagt, wir müssen jetzt den Sozialstaat kürzen und gegen Migration vorgehen, um so unsere sozialen Probleme zu lösen, dann würde ich sagen, hat der Gegenstandpunkt hier einen Treffer.
Ja, also Treffer stehen da einige drin, aber das ist ja nicht meine Kritik, denn zumindest ich nehme in einem Medienumfeld teil und ich höre sehr viele Podcasts und ich lese sehr viel, wo ganz viele Treffer gelandet werden. Die Frage ist nur, lande ich pointierte Treffer oder setze ich einen Hebel an, der vielleicht Einfluss hat auf die Gegenseite.
Und die setzen ja keinen Hebel an.
Das Problem mit dem Gegenstandpunkt würde ich jetzt sagen, aufgrund meiner einen Lektüre dieses einen Heftes, und ich habe es wie gesagt gehört, aber ich sage ja, lesen ist beides, hören und sehen. Wir zum Beispiel im Podcast achten darauf, dass wir auch eigene Themen setzen. Wir suchen uns manchmal Themen raus, die noch nicht thematisiert sind. Weil wir sagen, anbetracht der großen Zielsetzung, die wir haben, gibt es Themen, die übersehen werden, obwohl sie behandelt werden müssten überhaupt erst mal. Der Gegenstandpunkt, finde ich jetzt, der sucht sich keine Themen, um ein aus Theorie oder was auch immer gewonnenes Ziel zu verargumentieren, sondern er nimmt sich eigentlich die Mainstream-Thematisierung und macht eine Gegenperspektive. Also es ist sozusagen ein Gegenprozess, kein Gegenstandpunkt. Es geht nicht um so ein paradigmatisches, und hier will ich jetzt in die Gesellschaft hineinwirken. Ich setze jetzt eine Bundestagsentscheidung von 2009 zentral und sortiere 300 Seiten Buch drum rum, sondern was wird gerade diskutiert? Ah ja, dann schließen wir da mal an. Also so nach Dreher, aber nach eigener Drehung, so ungefähr. Und deswegen hätte ich eine Empfehlung an die Redaktion des Gegenstandpunkts. Macht es als Podcast. Es lohnt sich nicht, das als Text zu machen. Also solche Bleiwüsten, die einfach nicht in der Lage sind, neues Publikum zu erreichen, halte ich nicht für zeitgemäß. Und auch als Verschwendung von Ressourcen.
Stefan macht hier Image-Beratung für den Gegenstandpunkt.
Ja, macht es als Podcast. Also wenn euch wichtig ist zu sagen, wir schreiben nicht einfach Texte, sondern wir diskutieren hier und das mündet in Text, dann sage ich, dann gilt für euch, was für alle Redaktionen gilt, die Redaktionskonferenz ist das Produkt. Nicht der Text, der dann, ah ja, dann lass das mal Egon schreiben oder so, sondern, und diesen Shift machen ja gerade alle. Die Politikredaktion des Deutschlandfunk hat Zuhörer, die spontan über die Nachrichtenproduktion, die halt so abläuft, Franck Cappellan berichtet drei Minuten aus Brüssel und so weiter und so fort. Aber sehr treues Publikum hat der Politikpodcast des Deutschlandfunk.
Und da sollten sie sich dann unterhalten und nehmen sie Klaus Weselsky als Thema.
Ja, ich will da die Debatten hören.
Und dann willst du hören, wie das ausdiskutiert wird, dass Klaus Weselsky zwar einiges erreicht hat für seine Gewerkschaft, aber der Vorwurf vom Gegenstandpunkt ist, weil jetzt manche verwirrt sein werden, warum sind die gerade gegen Weselsky oder warum haben sie Kritik an ihm?
Was ich ja nicht teile. Ich bin ja, das ist ein Abfeiern und zwar chronologisch von Weselskys Leistung.
Nein, also ich will das jetzt nicht hier zu lange machen. Ich will nur zwei Punkte erklären, um diesen Gegenstandpunkt im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes zu verstehen. Sie werfen einmal Weselsky vor, dass er ja definitiv sagte, zum Beispiel auch gegenüber Tilo Jung im Interview, dass hier zitiert wird, dass er keinen Klassenkampf will. Also, dass er eigentlich an so eine gute Eintracht glaubt zwischen Arbeitgeber und Arbeitnehmer. Das ist ein Vorwurf, der kommt von diesem…
Weshalb er sich auf die Seite des Unternehmers ja auch schlägt und die Fairtrade gründet.
Diesen marxistischen Standpunkt unterminiert, obwohl er sich als so radikal gebärt. Und der zweite Punkt ist der, dass er eigentlich immer so von einem nationalen Interesse ausgeht und damit eigentlich auch so eine nationalstaatliche Doktrin immer mitschleift und damit ja den guten deutschen Arbeiter sieht, aber die anderen nicht. Und das ist jetzt mal so ganz grob gesagt, das ist ja ein langer Text, der sich damit auseinandersetzt. Und das wäre natürlich etwas, was man in einem Podcast auch sicherlich diskutieren könnte. Da frage ich mich immer bei diesem Absurdismus, wie weit das dann gehen kann, weil ich auch immer sagen muss, ja, ich lebe jetzt in der Gesellschaft, aber so kann ich sonst gar nichts machen, ehe irgendwas sich grundsätzlich geändert hat. Also ich kann natürlich auch Philippa Sigl-Glöckner von Anfang an vorwerfen, dass sie sich in einem kapitalistischen Rahmen bewegt. Und dann brauche ich im Prinzip das Buch nicht mehr lesen, wenn ich sage, ich möchte den aber verlassen. Nur mich interessiert ja schon auch immer, da ich die Revolution jetzt gerade hier nirgends sehe und die vom Gegenstandpunkt sehen die ja wahrscheinlich noch weniger als ich, frage ich mich, was ist eigentlich jetzt möglich? Und dann würde ich ja Weselsky zugestehen wollen, dass er doch einiges möglich gemacht hat, von dem andere Gewerkschaftsbosse glauben, dass es unmöglich sei.
Ja, also wenn, wie du sagst, der Gegenstandpunkt Weselsky so beobachtet und meine Leseimpressionen aber so danebenliegt, ist der Gegenstandpunkt echt gescheitert an diesem Punkt, also an diesem Text, mit diesem Text bei mir als Lese.
Sie sind nicht durchgehend schlecht, aber sie sind schon kritisch mit ihm.
Ja, ich fand jedenfalls witzig, dass sie in diesem Text zum amerikanischen Wahlkampf, wo sie ja schon einsteigen mit, immer wenn da was passiert, müssen wir den nachverfolgen, da ist der journalistische Verstand voll in seinem Element. Die Sorge, dass die Zeit zum Begreifen und Erklären des einen Ereignisses zu knapp sein könnte, bevor das nächste da ist, plagt die Vertreter dieses Berufs jedenfalls nicht. Stimmt, nur mehr als eine Nacherzählung des amerikanischen Wahlkampfes kriege ich eben auch nicht in dem Text, das Gegenstandpunkt. Und daher gilt die Kritik des Journalismus für mich als Leser auch als Kritik am Gegenstandpunkt.
Das heißt, du wirst jetzt kein Abonnent?
Nein, nicht.
Und wir warten auf den Gegenstandpunkt Podcast.
Genau, also beim Hören wäre ich total dabei.
Mit Stefan Schulz als erstem Gast.
Nee, Gäste brauchen die nicht. Die haben ja genug Diskussionen, so wie ich das verstehe.
Vermutlich.
Das müssen sie halt nur dokumentieren. Willst du, darf ich?
Ich mach schnell eine Studie, die ich ja eh nicht ganz jetzt referieren kann, weil sie so irrsinnig lang ist. Die muss man vielleicht auch nicht jetzt ganz lesen, wenn man nicht da rein will in das Thema. Aber die doch ganz erstaunlich ist in den Ergebnissen, ist verfasst worden von Ivan Savin und Jérôme van den Berg. Diese Studie heißt Reviewing Studies of Degrowth are Claims Matched by Data, Methods and Policy Analysis? Fragezeichen. Und man muss wohl sagen, nee. Es heißt da, auf der Grundlage einer Stichprobe von 561 Studien kommen wir zu dem Schluss, dass erstens der Inhalt, dass die große Mehrheit, fast 90 Prozent der Studien, eher Meinungen als Analysen sind. Nur wenige Studien verwenden quantitative oder qualitative Daten, noch weniger Studien verwenden formale Modellierungen. Und das ist ja wirklich ein Ergebnis, bei dem man denkt, ja, aber was sind denn das für Studien? Sie haben sich das dann detailliert angesehen, du hast auch alles aufgelistet. Insgesamt führten 31 Studien, also 5,5 Prozent der untersuchten Studien, eine quantitative Datenanalyse durch. Und weitere 23 Studien eine qualitative Datenanalyse. Insgesamt verwendeten 1,6 Prozent der Studien ein theoretisches Modell. Und weitere 1,4 Prozent ein empirisches Modell.
Ja, der Begriff der Studie ist völlig entgrenzt.
Ja, das zeigt sich nämlich daran, dass sie einfach mal Beispiele aufführen. Weil ich mir immer so dachte, was meinen sie, wenn das nicht so richtig oben ist oder so. Es gibt dann eine Studie von Colombo et al. von 2023. Für diese Studie führte man Interviews mit 41 Personen aus drei italienischen landwirtschaftlichen Sozialgenossenschaften. Man fragt sich jedoch, warum nur drei Genossenschaften untersucht wurden, wenn man bedenkt, dass es in Italien 430 solcher Genossenschaften gibt. Das ist aber dann als Studie. Dann gibt es eine Studie Alternative Ökonomien in Stuttgart. Da geht es um die Frage auch einer Postwachstumsgesellschaft. Potenzielle Postwachstumsorganisationen werden durch Schneeballsystemen identifiziert, was zu Verzerrungen durch Netzwerkverbindungen führen kann. Es wurden Interviews mit Gründern oder lokalen Vertretern von 14 Organisationen geführt. Es werden keine Angaben darüber gemacht, warum die einzelnen Organisationen ausgewählt wurden. Dann gibt es eine Studie, da werden elf Unternehmen zum Gemeinwohl gefragt. Auch hier die Frage, wie repräsentativ das ist, wenn die Größe der Unternehmen, dieser auch nur elf, zwischen einem Beschäftigten und 500 Beschäftigten schwankt.
Ja, ich will daran erinnern, dass der nächste große Kampf Mark Zuckerbergs ist, mit Studienwissen beim Thema Mental Health die Eltern zu überzeugen. Das wird kein Problem sein. Dabei wird uns 7.500 Studien vorlegen.
Es geht eine Studie über nachhaltigen Wachstumsrückgang im Tourismus. Und da geht es um die Türkei. Da hat man für diese Studie 15 persönliche Interviews mit wichtigen Tourismusakteuren in Istanbul geführt. Da fragen die Autoren jetzt dieser Meta-Studie, warum so wenig? Die Stadt hat im Jahr 15 Millionen Besucher. Ja, also das ist doch sehr eigenartig. Ja, und das deckt sich quasi mit dem, was mir aufgefallen ist. Wir haben ja wohl schon für alle mehrere Folgen zu Degrows gemacht. Und dann habe ich einige Bücher mir bestellt und natürlich auch Paypal und sowas gelesen. Dann sagte ich immer zu Ole, ja, das bleibt immer so diffus. Die haben immer neue Wortschöpfungen und so. Oder es kommen irgendwelche kleinsten Modelle, wo man sagen kann, ja, auf den drei Bauernhöfen funktioniert das. Aber das sagt mir ja gar nichts aus über Deutschland. Und das deckt sich hier nochmal ganz klar. Sie sagen dann hier im Fazit aus den vorangegangenen Auflistungen, dass sich schließend das Degrowth noch nicht oder nicht als bedeutendes akademisches Forschungsgebiet angesehen werden kann. Es gibt auch keine Anzeichen dafür, dass sich die Dinge mit der Zeit verbessern. Wir stellen fest, dass sowohl viele ältere als auch neuere Studien unter kleinen und nicht repräsentativen Stichproben leiden. Die Schwäche der Degrowth-Studien in Bezug auf die Datenanalyse ist bis zu einem gewissen Grad verständlich. Die Idee von Degrowth ist so weit von der Realität entfernt, dass gut empirische Studien kaum möglich sind. Die Durchführung von Experimenten mit Degrowth ist ebenfalls unmöglich, da man nicht einen Teil der Gesellschaft vom Rest isolieren und einem völlig anderen Wirtschaftsregime unterwerfen kann. Sie sagen aber dann auch, dass man da dann investieren müsste, um doch irgendwelche Studien durchzuführen. Zum Beispiel könnte man auch mehr psychologische Studien durchführen. Wie weit überhaupt Degrows eine Unterstützung erfährt. Denn auch das ist etwas, was hier bemängelt wird, dass sich viel zu wenige Studien darum kümmern, wie man sowas durchsetzen kann. Also wie bekommt man Mehrheiten für etwas beschafft. Und so heißt es dann, zu viele Studien scheinen bereit zu sein, ein großes sozioökonomisches Experiment mit großen Risiken einzugehen, ohne einen Einblick in das Gesamtbild zu haben. Und wenn ich daran denke, dass wir hier mal ausführlich über das Ende des Kapitalismus von Ulrike Herrmann gesprochen haben, die ja in diese Degrows Richtung argumentiert und wir da auch gerade bei der Empirie E. Kopfschüttelnd da saßen, dann deckt sich das sehr damit.
Ja, das ist ein großer Irrweg. Nicht weitergehen. Nicht auf einem Irrweg ist Taylor Lorenz. Sie hat jetzt ein User-Mag gegründet, also ein User-Magazin, ein Nutzermagazin und will sich weiterhin um ihre Beobachtung der Internetkultur kümmern, aber nicht mehr unter dem Dach der Washington Post, denn dieses Haus verlässt sie und da gibt es ja einige, die das zuletzt gemacht haben. Ich erinnere immer wieder an Casey Newton. Der hat ja auch The Verge verlassen, um dann Plattformer zu gründen. Und sie hat eine sehr interessante Begründung insgesamt dafür, denn sie sagt, Politiker und Unternehmer brauchen keine Medien mehr, um ihr Publikum zu finden. Das machen die selbst. Warum tut der Journalismus so, als wäre es noch anders? Und das ist natürlich ein ordentlicher Einstieg, denn weder bei Politik noch bei Unternehmen haben wir es mit Internetkultur zu tun oder etwa doch. Also für sie ist jetzt großer Singularitätsmoment. Wenn Politiker und Unternehmen ihr Publikum selber finden und keine Medienhäuser mehr brauchen, weil sie Internet haben, dann ist das Internetkultur. Also man könnte jetzt fragen, warum verwandelt sich nicht die ganze Washington Post in ein Usermag? Warum geht Taylor Lorenz und sagt, ich habe es nicht mal in meiner Sparte, wo nur wirklich Internet im Titel steht, geschafft, das Haus darauf zu trimmen, da entsprechend Ressourcen freizugeben? Also wird jetzt Usermag gegründet, als die wahre Geschichte der Technologie, lässt sich nämlich nur aus Perspektive der Nutzer beobachten. Deswegen Usermag. Das finde ich wahnsinnig gut, denn wir haben ja auch schon diese kleinen Hinweise gemacht, dass wenn der ARD-Börsenbericht über die Reservearmee Arbeitslosenzahl redet oder über den DAX als Rendite, dann sind das die Kennzeichen der Superreichen. Das hat mit dem Nutzer vor dem Bildschirm nichts zu tun. Wenn man jetzt sagt, sie möchte jetzt die wahre Geschichte der Technologie aus Perspektive der Nutzer erzählen und gründet dafür ein neues journalistisches Medium, weil die Alten das nicht machen, wie sieht es dann eigentlich mit der Wirtschaft- und Politikberichterstattung aus? Könnten wir die nicht auch mal nutzerzentriert machen?
Finde ich einen sehr guten Ansatz. Wie aber finanziert sie das?
Naja, über Mitgliedschaften wie bei Plattformen auch. Das kostet halt 70 Euro im Jahr, das zu lesen. Crazy Newton hat ja nun auch eine Mitarbeiterin und die publizieren ja jeden Tag. Sie verspricht irgendwie so ein bis drei Texte die Woche, was ich für den qualitativen Output auch erstmal gerechtfertigt finde. Denn wir machen zum Beispiel auch nur ein Podcast im Monat. Und wir haben noch nie die Kritik gehört, dass das Leute gerne einmal in der Woche hätten, sondern sie wollen es einmal im Monat.
Vielleicht, weil wir auch ein bisschen lang sind.
Ja, genau. Also quantitativ nicht ausdehnen, sondern nur qualitativ. So. Und da gibt es sozusagen Formate zu finden, die nicht in so einem Dauerbeschuss, weil Mark Zuckerberg sagt, alle 15 Minuten muss im Feed irgendwas los sein, sonst wirst du runtergerankt oder so. Sondern, nee, da gibt es ja andere Wege, das zu machen. Von daher finde ich, das so einzuschlagen, mit zu sagen, ich überfordere euch nicht mit viel, sondern wenn ihr von mir ein Signal bekommt, dann heißt das, ich habe wirklich gerade was zu berichten. Und das kann aber auch dann einfach am Montag und das nächste Mal am Freitag sein. Das ist doch eigentlich ein Angebot, bei dem ich sage, also das ist mir 70 Euro wert. Nicht 70 Euro wäre mir wert, eine Twitter-Timeline, die einfach die ganze Zeit, und ich verpasse eigentlich alles, und es ist alles durcheinander und so. Sondern das muss halt kostenlos sein.
Nee, man will das, woran man sich orientieren kann, nicht mit Quantität aufwiegen von 1000 Meldungen, die man hat. Und das wäre ja auch jetzt noch mal die Frage, wenn man über diesen Medienwandel nachdenkt, wie weit diese Partikularisierung dann noch haltbar ist. Also jetzt bist du jemand, der sehr digital affin ist, der sich für die sozialen Medien interessiert. Also du bist ein potenzieller Kunde für sie. Andererseits ist natürlich für jemand, der die Washington Post liest, der nicht ganz so digital affin ist, aber grundsätzlich auch mal was Gutes über Instagram lesen will. Der findet das ja dort jetzt nicht mehr. Oder andere werden was schreiben, aber der kann jetzt sich mit Taylor Lorenz lesen. Für den ist es aber nicht so wichtig, dass er das gleich abonniert. Und das macht es ja ein bisschen schwierig bei dieser Partikularisierung, dass man sich zwar an einzelne Dinge dranhängen kann und die dann auch finanziell unterstützen kann. Aber so die Gesamtabdeckung braucht man die. Oder ist das für mich einfach die falsch gestellte Frage, weil ich ja die Gesamtabdeckung im Internet schon bekomme. Also ich bekomme ja sehr viel frei verfügbar. Ich werde ja informiert, weil wenn jetzt Springer mit irgendjemanden zusammen geht oder sich wieder trennt, dann kann ich das ja auch irgendwo lesen. Aber die größere Einordnung, wenn die mich dann wirklich interessiert, dann bin ich bereit dafür, nochmal Geld zu zahlen.
Ja, also über das Buch Gutes Geld kann man sich auch im Internet informieren. Kostenlos, ohne es lesen zu müssen.
Das gibt es ja auch, aber man kriegt nicht eine anderthalb stündige Diskussion über das Buch. Wenn man so weit gehen will, dann abonniert man das. Und genauso auch hier, wenn ich so tief rein will, mit Taylor Lorenz in die Sphäre der sozialen Medien und all das, was mit dem Internet zusammenhängt, dann macht man das.
Ja, aber wenn die Medienhäuser stellen gerade alle fest, dass sie von zwei Seiten bedroht werden, die guten Leute gehen independent. Also sie sagen einfach 70 Euro für mich und das war's. Oder aber es kommen diese kleinen Auswüchse aus den Medienhäusern, die dann sagen, unser Abo kostet 10.000 Euro im Jahr. Und dafür sind wir halt wirklich vor Ort. Und ihr kriegt dann ein zusammengefrahrenes, das ist ja, wir lesen gleich noch hier, Kommunikationenrecht zum Beispiel, ist eine Zeitung, die wirtschaftlich funktioniert und sie liegt einfach als Special Interest Format, nehme ich mal an, so auf Tischen in Kanzleien rum, wo einfach so Abos bezahlt werden und dann geht man so hin und dann liest man Rechtsprechung. Da werden einfach Urteile kommentiert. Aber bevor sie kommentiert werden, auf einer Doppelseite, werden auf anderthalb Doppelseiten Urteilsbegründungen zusammengefasst. Also ihr braucht es einfach einen und das wird wohl auch eine Weile dauern, bis die KI diese Entscheidung trifft. Welche Sätze aus einer Urteilsbegründung kann ich weglassen, weil Anwälte verstehen, hier geht es gerade nicht um den Sachverhalt, sondern um Legitimationsargumentation und so. Und diese Art von Special Interest, würde ich sagen, hat immer Konjunktur. Es ist nur eine Formatfrage, wie man sowas schreibt, publiziert. Das war ja eines dieser ersten, okay wir haben jetzt JTBT und dann kommt plötzlich ja der Prompt-Ingenie. Ja genau, das muss nämlich ingeniert werden, wie diese Prompte aussehen, damit das Resultat stimmt. So und hier ist ja auch schon den Hörern aufgefallen, dass wir so eine KI-Wende durchaus ein bisschen mitmachen und immer mal wieder explizieren und dass ich dann sage, ja also diesen Friedrich-Merz-Auftritt, den habe ich nicht geschaut, sondern den hat mir Whisper AI vertextet und Claude hat mir die Zusammenhänge rausgezogen. So und das sind ja auch Leistungen, wir kommen im letzten Text darauf, wie diese Zusammenarbeit jetzt auch juristisch gefasst wird zwischen KI als Werkzeug und eben, und dann kommt man nicht umhin, Personen, die es tun. Man verliert seinen Job nicht an die KI, sondern an jemanden, der die KI besser benutzt als man selbst. Also dieses menschliche Element kommt ja umso stärker heraus jetzt. Jetzt wird überhaupt erst mal betont.
Das bedeutet aber doch dann für den Medienwandel, dass eigentlich diese Dinge noch weiter zunehmen werden. Also dass sich Einzelne abspalten und dort selbst etwas machen. Und das wirft bei mir die Frage auf, ob nicht so etwas wie dieser skurrile Bürgerrat gegen Fake News, bei dem Bertelsmann und T-Online dran beteiligt sind, und ja ganz viel in diese Richtung gerade passiert, immer mehr in den Mittelpunkt gerückt wird, weil man eigentlich, solange man noch eine gewisse Macht hat, solange man noch, das sind die Medienhäuser von sich sagen würden, dass man da gerne am liebsten jetzt eine staatliche Unterstützung hätte, denn wir gewährleisten zugleich den Schutz vor Fakes und den Schutz der Demokratie, dass man jetzt sagt, die müssen nochmal gesondert hervorgehoben werden. Oder sieh dir auch an, dass ja tatsächlich jetzt Döpfner den Springer verlag, mit der KKR-Aufspaltung jetzt so auf Vordermann gebracht hat, dass er ja jetzt wieder eigentlich das Verlagsgeschäft, das journalistische Geschäft in den Fokus rückt. Also gibt es ja da schon nicht nur Untergangsstimmung, sondern da gibt es ja jemanden, der jetzt zum Beispiel in den USA ganz stark expandieren will, der zum Beispiel dann auch die Möglichkeit hätte zu sagen, ich habe Geld, also kaufe ich die Washington Post. Also es scheint ja noch nicht so zu sein, als würde das alles dem Untergang geweizt.
Die Washington Post ist ja schon gekauft. Die wurde ja vor über zehn Jahren schon von Jeff Bezos für damals ein Prozent seines Vermögens oder sowas, für 250 Millionen gekauft.
Aber jetzt kann er ja dem Döpfner die verkaufen, wenn er die jetzt haben möchte. Politico hat da ja schon gekauft.
Genau, also wir haben hier Auflösungserscheinungen an Stellen, die wir eigentlich schon verloren geben, weil da schon die Milliardäre drin hängen. Auf der anderen Seite, ja, wir sehen jetzt immer so eine noch mal letzte Bekräftigung alter Medienstrukturen, die aber sehr viel mit Cannibalismus und Paradoxien zu tun hat. Also man kommt ja nicht umhin, dass es wie also wie witzig es ist, dass Elon Musk darüber twittert, dass Munga und Charlie Munga und Warren Buffett. Warren Buffett hat jetzt lokalen Redaktionen gekauft, also Zeitungshäuser, 200 Redaktionen, die irgendwie in und so. Und Elon Musk macht sich, also weist auf Twitter darauf hin, dass hier wahrscheinlich aus linker progressiver Seite eine Machtübernahme im Medienbetrieb stattfindet. Und er macht das auf Twitter, einem Ding, das er selber gerade für 40 Milliarden gekauft hat und so weiter. Also das sind ja so, hier sieht man noch mal, wie der eine Milliardär, dem anderen Milliardär und so weiter nur Twitter stirbt und diese Lokalredaktion, also denen sagt man auch nur nach, dass sie sterben. Man fragt sich so ein bisschen, warum investiert er dann da rein? Aber andere Frage, also auch da, wo wir noch Kräftezentren vermuten, gerade weil er Milliardär und so weiter, sagt es Taylor Lorenz nicht, ne, das ist nicht mehr meine Adresse und jetzt gehen halt einfach 30 Jahre ins Land, in dem sie nicht für die Washington Post arbeitet. Und dann gucken wir mal, was daraus kommt. Aus dieser Begründung, die sie jetzt macht, da wird sie ganz deutlich. Also ökonomische Kennziffern, Konflikte in Vorständen sind zweitrangig. Das, was bisher so in Zeitung steht, Unternehmensberichterstattung, wie sieht eine Bilanz aus? Das ist egal. Also bei der Frage, wie sieht eine Bilanz aus, schon seit 20 Jahren können uns die Wirtschaftsredaktion nicht mehr erklären, was es mit diesem Kapitalkurs-Gewinnverhältnis irgendwas von Facebook auf sich hat. Bei OpenAI, das sprengt wirklich alle. Der Stromverbrauch alleine ist mehr wert als der ganze Umsatz, den das Unternehmen macht. Also das kann man nicht mehr erklären. So, das muss man jetzt. Diese Unternehmen werden aus irgendwelchen Gründen am Leben erhalten und gefördert. Warum? Was kommt beim Nutzer da an, aus dieser Perspektive betrachten? Sie sagt, es braucht jetzt so einen neuen impressionistischen Journalismus, eine Mischung aus ursprünglich berichtenden Artikeln, Interviews und Links. Die sich ernsthaft mit den Sachen befassen und sich nicht an diesen alten Doktrinen aufhalten. Internetkultur ist jetzt alles. Medienhäusern ist es nicht gelungen, diesen Wandel mitzumachen. Sie kommt auch aus eigenem Interesse dann auf Gamergate nochmal zu sprechen. Gamergate zeigte, wo im Internet Kräfte wirken, die sich nicht abbilden lassen mit bisherigem Journalismus. Vor allem, weil da Opfer produziert werden wurden, für die sich niemand interessierte. Hätte man das aus Opfersicht mal betrachtet, hätte man viel schneller so auf Shitstormerei und diese ganzen Prinzipien und auch wie viele Profite daraus gezogen werden. Wir kriegen jetzt so ganz langsam die Aufklärung, dass diese ganzen rechten Blogs, die so diesen, der Migrant und so weiter, das sind Profit-Centers. Da sitzt einfach ein Typ, der so Texte macht, irgendeinem Ausland und es erklärt den Deutschen, dass sie ganz bedroht sind vom Ausland. Und zwar nicht, um irgendwie eine Partei zu fördern oder weil das Kreml-Propaganda ist, sondern weil das einfach nur bedeutet, dass ein Typ 17.000 Euro im Monat verdient. So und diese Strukturen kann man ja alle mal ordentlich aufdröseln, fand bisher nicht statt. Online-Akteure tanzen den Journalisten auf der Nase, herumschreibt sie. Ich hatte in Führungsposition, in den Nachrichtenredaktionen Verantwortung inne. Ich habe Lobbyarbeit bei Medienmanagement betrieben. Ich habe Forschungsberichte erstellt, endlose Berichterstattung veröffentlicht und auf Konferenzen in der ganzen Welt gesprochen, in denen ich argumentiert habe, dass wir online zahlen, Veranstaltungen und Bewegungen, die da irgendwie stattfinden, falsch beobachten. Und ich kann mich auch noch daran erinnern, wie irgendwann Marija Slomka am heutigen Nalke so gesagt hat, ja, vielleicht ist ja die Anzahl an Likes nicht immer ausschlaggebend. Dann hat sie das in der Republik dann ausgearbeitet und ließ sich da beklatschen für den Hinweis. Also auch wir in der heutigen Redaktion achten jetzt noch mal drauf, dass wir nicht nur Sachen aufgreifen, nur weil sie viele Likes auf Facebook haben. Und denkt sich so, ja, Applaus, wirklich sehr gut, das ist sehr modern. Also diese alten Medien, Legacy Media, können es nicht. Und sie wird hier ganz deutlich und sagt, für den Journalismus, den ich machen will, brauche ich oder ist es nicht gut, einen Corporate Overlord zu haben. Weiß nicht genau, wen sie damit meint, die Washington Post oder ihren Eigentümer oder wie auch immer.
Naja, also ich denke jetzt gerade an meine Filmanalyse, das wäre nicht unter irgendeinem Dach möglich. Und damit meine ich jetzt nicht, dass jemand ideologisch was dagegen hat, der dann anruft und sagt, Herr Schmitt so, aber nicht. Aber ich weiß, ich müsste irgendwas anfangen zu rechtfertigen, warum jetzt zweimal einen alten Film und jetzt habe ich aber auch Die Neuen so oft schlecht besprochen und der nächste Joker, der muss aber dann doch mal positiv besprochen werden oder was weiß ich. Oder kann man da mal einen anderen Ansatz, dass man mal die schauspielerischen Leistungen sagt, nee, der Film ist nicht gut und das werde ich auch wieder so sagen. Also das glaube ich, würde gar nicht gehen. Das geht für das Publikum, aber das geht nicht für eine Redaktion, die da drübersitzen würde.
Und sie verortet sich so wie du da eben auch explizit selbst. Sie sagt einfach, ich habe immer in diesem Raum operiert, in dem ich schon als Content Creator da war, aber eigentlich noch so Journalismus machen sollte und so. Und aus dieser Zwangslage befreit sie sich jetzt. Sie sagt einfach, wir sind alle Influencer. Markus Söder auch. So ungefähr liest man es aus dem Text. Von daher, jetzt ist es einfach offenes Visier. Influencer beobachten Influencer. Markus Söder sagt irgendwas über irgendwelche Leute, die irgendwelche Leute sagen was über Markus Söder. Das kann man als politischen Journalismus behandeln und sich dann irgendwie, keine Ahnung, nachher hergebracht. Aber sie sagt, nein, ab jetzt wird das alles anders gemacht. Wir haben hier ein und dasselbe Medienökosystem, in dem sind wir alle ein Teil. Also in Teilen unterscheiden wir uns, aber das Medienökosystem ist alle dasselbe. Und von daher muss man das jetzt neu machen. Und das finde ich wirklich sehr gut. Das ist sozusagen die alte deutsche Diskussion. Dürfen Journalisten auch Aktivisten sein? Und dann sagen alle nein. Und dann fragt man so, ja, aber warum sollten sich Journalisten für irgendwas interessieren? Ja, die sollen nur über Sachen schreiben, für die sie sich nicht interessieren, weil sonst wären die ja Aktivisten. Man fragt sich so, also Journalisten sollen jetzt ihr Interesse abgeben und in der Redaktion sich nur zu den Themen melden, für die sie sich nicht interessieren, weil man ihnen sonst einen Aktivismus unterstellt. Kann man das nicht mal noch ein bisschen einhegen oder so? Nein, kann man nicht. Also das einfach mal alles abschütteln und sagen, ich mach das jetzt selber. Das finde ich gut.
Ich habe einen Artikel gelesen in Le Monde Diplomatiek von Didier Ortolan. Der ist im französischen Außenministerium zuständig gewesen für das internationale Seerecht und der beschäftigt sich in diesem Artikel mit der Arktis. Da schreibt er gleich zu Beginn, die Arktis zählt zu den Kollateralopfern des russischen Krieges gegen die Ukraine. Grund dafür ist weniger die zunehmende Militarisierung als die lahmgelegte Verwaltung der gesamten Polarregionen. Das beeinträchtigt nicht nur die politische Stabilität der Arktis, sondern auch die wissenschaftliche Forschung, die zum Verständnis klimatischer Entwicklung unverzichtbar ist. Zudem nutzen Öl- und Gastanker immer häufiger die Nordost-Passage, die durch ein besonders empfindliches Ökosystem führt. Eine weitere überraschende Folge des Krieges ist, dass die USA ihre Gebietsansprüche auf einen 500.000 Quadratkilometer großen Kontinentalsockel in der Chugtschen und Beaufortsee modifiziert haben. Ja, und zwar ist es so, dass nach dem Kalten Krieg es gelungen war, eine einzigartige multilaterale Verwaltung der Arktis aufzubauen. Also da hat der Multilateralismus schon funktioniert, noch ehe man so viel darüber gesprochen hat. Und seit 1996 ist es so, dass diesem arktischen Rat, wie der sich nennt, acht Anreinerstaaten angehören. Das sind Kanada, Dänemark, USA, also Dänemark für Grönland, USA, Finnland, Island, Norwegen, Russland und Schweden. Und dazu kommen dann noch Vertreter der indigenen Bevölkerung. 2021 übernahm Russland den Vorsitz und sollte ihn dann eigentlich bis 2023 ausüben. Aber dann hat man mit Beginn des Krieges beschlossen, seitens der anderen Mitgliedsstaaten die Zusammenarbeit mit Moskau ruhen zu lassen. Er schreibt, es ging niemals darum, Russland dauerhaft auszuschließen, denn die Hälfte der betroffenen Küsten und der nördlich des Polarkreises lebenden Menschen sind Russisch. Auch Moskau wollte sich nicht aus dem Rat zurückziehen, um die Zusammenarbeit in dem strategisch wichtigen Gebiet nicht zu gefährden. So fuhr die russische Präsidentschaft ohne die übrigen Mitglieder mit der Umsetzung ihres Programms FORT mit Unterstützung befreundeter Beobachter aus China und Indien. Das Problem ist nun, dass eigentlich ganz vieles zu regeln wäre. Zum Beispiel Forschung in Bezug auf die Klimakrise. Dort nämlich kann man beobachten, was das bedeutet, wenn Permafrostböden auftauen. Also da geschehen eigentlich ganz, ganz wichtige Dinge. Aber da die Geopolitik dazwischenkommt, ist das alles zum Erliegen gekommen. Hier heißt es dann, das Nordpolarmeer ist das beste Beispiel für die aktuelle Bestrebung zahlreicher Küstenstaaten, ihre Festlandsockel über die ausschließlich Wirtschaftszone von 200 Seemeilen hinaus auszudehnen. Gemäß dem UN-See-Rechtsübereinkommen ist die Festlandsockel-Grenzkommission für die Prüfung und Anerkennung solcher Territorialforderungen zuständig. Und da gibt es jetzt also einen großen Streit, wo beginnt das eine Territorium, wo endet das der anderen. Und so wird da einiges jetzt gerade verschoben. Die Grenzen zwischen den Hochheitsgewässern der USA und Russland verläuft entlang des festgelegten Längengrads. Allerdings behauptet Washington, dass Schelf der Chukchi-See-Reiche bis 82 Grad nördlicher Breite, wie an Moskau meint, sein Festlandsockel erstrecke sich bis zum Nordpol. Und da gibt es also jetzt einen Widerstreit. Und selbstredend geht es darum, wer hat da welche Einflussschneise dann auch für den Welthandel. Es sieht also nicht gut aus für die Klimaforschung gerade, die dort betrieben werden müsste und könnte. Man wird sehen, ob, wenn es zu einem Frieden kommt in der Ukraine, dies dann wieder aufgenommen wird. Denn eigentlich hat da, man möchte fast sagen, der Multilateralismus funktioniert.
Ja, sehr gut. Erstaunlicherweise kann man ja im Weltraum immer noch zusammenarbeiten. Und ich hätte jetzt gedacht, die Arktis und die Antarktis sind auch so ein mehr akademisch. Aber nein, es wird so langsam durchökonomisiert mit allen Folgen. Mein letzter Text hier heute kommt eben aus der angesprochenen Kommunikation und Recht Zeitung, die untersteht im DFV, deutschen Fachverlag, dem Thorsten, den wir auf der Bühne hatten im Sommersalon. Und hier werden immer special interestmäßig Urteile, also es werden ein paar Diskussionen geführt, aber auch viele Urteile besprochen. Wie zum Beispiel ein Urteil im Juni 2024 vom Bundesgerichtshof, das sagt, KI-System kann kein Erfinder sein.
Sehr richtig.
Ja, hier wird sich nur auf die juristischen Argumentationen konzentriert. Was bedeutet, ich spekuliere jetzt, dass es offensichtlich irgendwo ein Typ gab, das wird auch hier namentlich genannt. Der hat ein KI-System erfunden und er wollte gerne weltweit der Erste sein, der sagen kann, meine KI hat ein Patent angemeldet. Also hat er das auch durchgeboxt, denn bevor das beim Bundesgerichtshof landet, kommt es natürlich erst mal vor, das Patentgericht, das da zuständig ist und so weiter und so fort. Aber im Beschluss wird nun gesagt, Erfinder im Sinne von Paragraph 37 Absatz 1, Patg, also Patentgesetz, kann nur eine natürliche Person sein. Ein maschinelles, aus Hard- oder Software bestehendes System kann auch dann nicht als Erfinder benannt werden, wenn es über Funktion Künstliche Intelligenz verfügt. Das ist sozusagen Punkt A. Es wird dann ewig lange, also es scheint ein sehr ausführliches Gesetz zu sein. Denn nachdem die Begründung des Urteils hier so ein bisschen vorgestellt wird, hat David Pfahler, ein Rechtsanwalt, geschrieben und meinte dann auch Folgen für die Praxis, der BGH verwendet einigen Begründungsaufwand auf. Ein vordergründig betrachtet wenig überraschendes Ergebnis. Wenn eine Erfindung angemeldet wird, muss immer eine natürliche Person benannt sein. Der BGH orientiert sich hier auch an Rechtsprechung anderer. Zum Beispiel, und das ist jetzt direkt aus der Urteilsbegründung, da wird es aufgezählt, der UK Supreme Court hat sich schon mit dieser Frage befasst, 2023. Der Court of Appeal for England and Wales hat sich damit schon befasst, der Federal Court of Australia, der United States Court of Appeals for the Federal Circuit und das Hohe Gericht in New Zealand auch. Alles so Rechtsprechung 2023, BGH 24 also nachgezogen. Und ich bin ein Liar. Ich habe diesen Kommentar, der eine Doppelseite geht, gelesen und sage, das Urteil des BGH lautet in seiner Begründung Vorsicht, sonst Teufels Küche. Denn die Implikationen sind wirklich weitreichend, denn angenommen, man hätte jetzt die KI als Erfinder geduldet im Patentrecht. Das Patentrecht hat vor allem ökonomische Funktionen. Dann hätte man sich gefragt, wenn jetzt der BGA gesagt hätte, na gut, vielleicht ist es nicht der Erfinder, aber so wie man auch bei einer Abschlussarbeit oder so dazuschreiben muss, von wem man sich hat helfen lassen oder bei einer Steuererklärung, und man schreibt dann da rein, die KI hat mir geholfen. Und das muss beispielsweise verpflichtend mit rein in den Patentantrag und damit ins Patent. Dann hat es ja ökonomische Konsequenzen. Also dafür ist es ja da. Der BG hat jetzt gesagt, nein, darf niemals der Erfinder sein, kann aber genannt werden. Und das genannt werden können, wenn gewisse schöpferische Beiträge oder wie auch immer gibt es Argumentation. Aber so wie ich das verstanden habe, muss nicht, denn und jetzt gehen wir auf die letzten beiden Punkte hier ein, die Herr Pfahler, ein Bioinformatik absolvierter heutiger Jurist hier aufzählen. Bei der Anmeldung von Erfindung kann und muss immer eine natürliche Person als Erfinder genannt werden. Zusätzlich kann auf den Einsatz eines, also kann auf den KI-Einsatz als Mittel hingewiesen werden. Dies sollte aber wohl überlegt sein, da hier mit Streitigkeiten mit anderen Beteiligten der KI-Supply-Chain Vorschub geleistet werden kann. Also ich lese mal diesen zweiten. Wir können uns schon mal überlegen, KI-Supply-Chain, was soll denn das sein? Alle Beteiligten in der KI-Supply-Chain, Klammer auf, Hersteller, Verwender, Urheber oder andere Rechteinhaber an den verwendeten Trainingsdaten sollten insbesondere jegliche menschlichen Beiträge zum KI-System wie Herstellung, Prüfung, Inputs, Klammer auf, Promps, also die Promps stehen ja überhaupt nur als Klammer hinter und so weiter, Nachjustierungen, Änderungen und so weiter genauestens dokumentieren. Es ist wahrscheinlich, dass diesen in zukünftigen Rechtsstreitigkeiten eine besondere Rolle zugesprochen wird.
Das heißt, wir brauchen dann Lieferketten-Gesetz.
Genau. Und bei der Frage, wenn also wir haben uns, also wir beschäftigen uns ja nur mit Ideenrechtung, so auf diesem Level kann man aufschreiben und dann inspiriert das jemanden, weil die Argumentation gut lief oder so. Formulierung gelungen, 1a. Gut, dann kann die Clot natürlich immer mal helfen und sagen, hier formuliert auch so und so oder was ist mit diesem inhaltlichen Fakt. Nur wenn jetzt Diamanten gebraucht werden und dann kommt so eine Forschungsabteilung auf die Idee, die alten Ingredienzen, die man so hat, zur Diamantenzüchtung mal durchzuspielen in so einem virtuellen KI-Raum, dass ja auch Diamanten dann virtuell züchten kann. Und das fand ja schon wirklich so statt. Also Google kam ja schon und sagte, wir haben 300 Millionen neue Diamanten gefunden und die mussten dann halt überprüft werden, taugen die denn in der Praxis? Also hat man so ein paar gezüchtet und festgestellt, ne, so die meisten dann doch nicht. Also die Idee war ganz gut der KI. Aber angenommen aus so einem Prozess kommt jetzt ein Diamant raus, der sagt, ja, Apples oder Facebooks Brille muss jetzt gar nicht 10.000 Euro kosten, das Material kann man auch für 3,50 Euro herstellen, dann hat das ja nun wirklich einschlagende Charakter. Wer wird jetzt beteiligt an dem Gewinn? Wer hat hier Ansprüche? Irgendwer, die KI entwickelt, irgendwer, die KI alignt. Das ist wie bei Taylor Swift. Ja gut, also sie hat die Songs geschrieben, aber irgendwer hat halt das Mikrofon hingestellt und kriegt dann Leistungsschutz rechtsmäßig Anteile und sie sagt, oh gut, wenn das verkauft wird, nehme ich halt meine Musik nochmal neu auf und zack, ist jemand entwertet.
Aber warum muss das so sein? Also zum Beispiel hast du jetzt einen Buchvertrag und da gibt es Lizenzen an dich und sowas, aber du schreibst das mit Word zum Beispiel das Buch und du zahlst ja Word jetzt nicht nochmal zehn Prozent deines Vorschusses.
Ja, weil Word in der juristischen Kette nicht als Mitautor meines Buches gilt. Alles, was ich als Herstellerfirma Microsoft schulde, ist mit dem Bezahlen der Lizenz für Word abgegolten.
Und das frage ich mich jetzt zum Beispiel bei Diepel.
Und jetzt ging es hier um die Frage, ändern wir das?
Ja, das ist ja eine ganz wichtige Frage. Denke mal, wie viele Leute jetzt mit Diepel was übersetzen.
Genau, weshalb ja durchaus dadurch, dass die Energiepreise sind, wie sie sind, Chetjibiti intern überlegt, ob man nicht den Monatspreis von 20 auf 2000 Euro anhebt. Ja, weil man nämlich weiß, wir wollen uns nicht einmischen in Rechtsschreddigkeiten, wenn dann die Kreationen da sind, selbst wenn sie zu unseren Gunsten sind und wir vielleicht auch noch mal einen Anteil haben können. Sondern wir wollen einfach, dass der Wert, dass dann Cut, keine Supply Chain, sondern ein Cut. Chetjibiti selbst ist ein Produkt, das wir verkaufen, danach verwendet das jemand. Aber nicht eine durchgezogene, ideelle Wertschöpfungskette bis hinzu, ach so, das habt ihr dann mitgemacht, dann werden wir jetzt beteiligt. Weil irgendwo muss ja auch mal ein Anfang und ein Ende sein. So und wenn Chetjibiti davon überzeugt ist, dass man Erfindungen damit hinkriegt, ja dann rechtfertigt erzahlt, dass sie 2000 Euro im Monat verlangen. Die Frage ist dann marktwirtschaftlich, wird das bezahlt? Ja oder nein?
Du steigst dann wahrscheinlich aus.
Naja, also die Frage ist ja hier ganz ernsthaft. Wenn wir Produkte haben, die am Anfang als universal gelten, und dann stellt sich aber raus, ne, mit so einer Heidelberger Druckmaschine, das macht keinen Sinn, dass wir die im Supermarkt anbieten für 5,80 Euro, sondern die gibt es von uns nur maßgeschneidert. Und dann gibt es sie nur einmal. Und wenn GPT jetzt sagt oder Open AI, wir haben jetzt mit Hilfe von was auch immer, dafür brauchten wir eine breite Nutzerbasis, das System so weit auf die Spitze getrieben und allein, dass wir jetzt ein finales Ding haben. Aber das kostet pro Monat 25.000 Euro. Dann wird es Leute geben, die das bezahlen. Also solche Produkte können durchaus mal den Charakter einfach umstellen, zu völlig Special Interest werden, obwohl sie eigentlich ein Universalkomputer sind. Es war ja auch diese Idee von Intel damals. War es Intel, eine IBM? Die sagten, also wir haben jetzt Prozessoren erfunden und der Bedarf auf der Welt schätzen wir auf fünf. Und dann stellte sie sich heraus, nee, nicht fünf pro Welt, sondern fünf pro Person. Also man kann sich da wirklich ganz groß verdenken, weshalb solche Rechtsprechungen hier wirklich tiefgreifend sind. Also hier wird wirklich was entschieden, was über Jahrhunderte wahrscheinlich gilt, wo solche Ketten abgebrochen werden. Und man sagt, nee, hier macht man keine Verkettung mehr zwischen Elon Musk hat mal irgendwas mitgegründet und deswegen wird jetzt diese und jede Forschungsabteilung muss jetzt einen Zehnten an den Fürsten Elon Musk zahlen. In der Hinsicht sollte man häufiger vielleicht mal Special Interest Magaziner lesen. Da steht sowas drauf.
Ja, sehr gut. Jetzt gibt es noch Musik von Franz Schubert. Franz Schubert stirbt früh. Anfang 30 ist er. What? Ja.
Erstaunlich.
In den letzten Lebenswochen widmet er sich vor allem. Nein, der Winterreise. Die Winterreise erzählt von einem lyrischen Ich oder einem Mann, könnte man sagen, wenngleich die Winterreise heute auch von Frauen immer wieder gesungen wird. Erzählt also von einem, der die Geliebte verlässt. Das Ganze beginnt mit dem Lied Fremd, bin ich eingezogen, fremd ziehe ich wieder aus. Der Mai war mir gewogen, mit manchem Blumenstrauß. Das Mädchen sprach von Liebe, die Mutter gar von E. Nun ist die Welt so trübe, der Weg gehüllt in Schnee. So beginnt diese Winterreise, ein Liederzyklus. 24 Lieder sind es und wir verfolgen diesen einsamen Wandern. Wir gehen mit ihm, wir laufen mit ihm, wir schleppen uns mit ihm durch den Schnee. Und diese Winterreise ist wahrscheinlich der berühmteste Liederzyklus überhaupt. Für mich ist es auch der schönste Liederzyklus, das sage ich gleich dazu. Und ich freue mich sehr, dass es jetzt eine wunderbare Neu-Einspielung gibt. Der Bariton André Schuhn, geschrieben S-C-H-U-E-N, und der Pianist Daniel Heide haben diese Winterreise neu eingespielt. Der Liederabend besteht ja daraus, dass ein Mensch steht und singt und einer sitzt am Klavier und begleitet. Das ist der Liederabend ganz reduktionistisch. Und er ist etwas sehr Deutsches, denn sogar die Franzosen und auch die Engländer sagen das Lied oder Le Lied. Denn das Lied, das deutsche Lied, ist etwas ganz besonderes, eine eigene Form, die dann auch später Anklang gefunden hat im Ausland. Also insofern, dass das auch andere ausländische Komponisten, die da geschrieben haben. Aber das Lied ist eine ganz eigene Form, eine besondere Form. Und das Tolle hier ist, dass diese Gedichte von Wilhelm Müller, von Franz Schubert so vertont werden, dass man die Rhythmik des Gehens, das Laufen, das Gehetztsein, aber auch das Langsamerwerden nachverfolgen kann. Man hört es in der Klavierbegleitung allein schon.
Also muss ich in einfacher Geschwindigkeit hören oder was?
Du musst es definitiv in einfacher Geschwindigkeit hören. Es werden also die Bilder, die die Sprache aufruft, dann auch von Klavier mit abgebildet. Zum Beispiel in dem siebten Lied auf dem Flusser heißt es, der du so lustig rauschtest. Du heller, wilder Fluss, wie still bist du geworden, gibst keinen Scheidekurs. Mit harter, starrer Rinde hast du dich überdeckt, liegst kalt und unbeweglich im Sande ausgestreckt. Und hin kommt jetzt der Erzähler. In deine Decke grab ich mit einem spitzen Stein den Namen meiner Liebsten und Stund und Tag hinein. Und auch dieses Klopfen, dieses Hineinritzen, auch das wird vom Klavier nach geahmt. Und wir sind da in einem ganz besonderen Rhythmus unterwegs. Und man muss diese Aufnahme besonders loben, deshalb, weil André Schuhn das zwar auch expressiv bereit ist, zu singen, aber nie gerät das, wenn er laut wird, in ein Schreien, was schlechte Liedsänger mitunter machen, sondern es bleibt immer ein Singen. Und er hat ein sehr warmes Tampere, kann aber auch Härten zulassen, hat lyrische Stellen. Und es sind wunderschöne Gedichte, die dann dort erklingen. Eines meiner Lieblingslieder ist der Frühlingstraum, weil der so kontrastreich ist. Und ich werde jetzt den Teufel tun und das singen, das ist ein bisschen zu schwer. Aber ich will versuchen mal, es reicht nicht zu schreien. indem ich das vorlese, deutlich zu machen. Oder vielleicht ein bisschen diese Rhythme klar zu machen. Und das beginnt also tänzerisch. Das müssen dann alle jetzt nachher hören. Es beginnt tänzerisch. Ich träumte von bunten Blumen, so wie sie wohl blühen im Mai. Ich dräumte von grünen Wiesen, von lustigem Vogelgeschrei. Diese Rhythmik ist klar und es ist tänzerisch. Dann aber abrupter Wechsel. Und als die Hähne gräten, da ward mein Auge wach. Da war es kalt und finster. Es schrien die Raben vom Dach. So muss man das auch dann singen. Und dann kommt aber das ganz lyrische Moment zurückgenommen. Doch an den Fensterscheiben, wer malte die Blätter da? Ihr lacht wohl über den Träumer, der Blumen im Winter sah. Und diese Blumen im Winter, die da am Fenster zu sehen sind, das sind die Eisblumen. Und ich empfehle generell die Winterreise zu hören. Es gibt tausende Aufnahmen. Ihr seid ja alle bei den Streamingplattformen. Ihr werdet viel finden. Aber damit einzusteigen mit der von André Schuhn lohnt sich sehr erschienen. Bei Gramophon gibt es natürlich auch eine CD. Ich habe hier die Platte vor mir liegen, die die CD vor mir liegen. Das ist wunderbar, mit welch großer Empfindsamkeit, mit welcher ungeheuren Textverständlichkeit und Schönheit André Schuhn diesen wunderbaren Liederzyklus uns wieder in die Gegenwarte ins Gehör holt. Und das ist also diese Reise, die jetzt bitte alle unternehmen. Die Winterreise von Franz Schubert.
Sehr gut, damit machen wir uns auf in die Oper. Heute ist Textverständlichkeit Null, denn es wird auf Russisch gesungen.
Ja.
Aber morgen gehen wir wieder in die Oper und dann ist es nicht Russisch.
Dann ist es Italienisch. Bin ich gespannt, wie gut du das kannst. Ja. Bis dann.
Bis dann.